artificial intelligence has been one of
the most commonly heard buzzwords ai
defined as the intelligence exhibited by
machines is dominating every aspect of
human computer interaction today if
you're looking to learn artificial
intelligence you're in the right place
hi guys welcome to the full artificial
intelligence course by simply learn
today we will be covering the most
important topics on artificial
intelligence let's have a look at these
topics first we will watch a short
animated video to get you introduced to
artificial intelligence picture this a
machine that could organize your
cupboard just as you like it or serve
every member of the house a customized
cup of coffee makes your day easier
doesn't it these are the products of
artificial intelligence but why use the
term artificial intelligence well these
machines are artificially incorporated
with human-like intelligence to perform
tasks as we do this intelligence is
built using complex algorithms and
mathematical functions but ai may not be
as obvious as in the previous examples
in fact ai is used in smartphones cars
social media feeds video games banking
surveillance and many other aspects of
our daily life the real question is what
does an ai do at its core here is a
robot we built in our lab which is now
dropped onto a field in spite of a
variation in lighting landscape and
dimensions of the field the ai robot
must perform as expected this ability to
react appropriately to a new situation
is called generalized learning the robot
is now at a crossroad one that is paved
and the other rocky the robot must
determine which path to take based on
the circumstances this portrays the
robots reasoning ability after a short
stroll the robot now encounters a stream
that it cannot swim across using the
plank provided as an input the robot is
able to cross this stream so our robot
uses the given input and finds the
solution for a problem this is problem
solving these three capabilities make
the robot artificially intelligent in
short ai provides machines with the
capability to adapt
reason and provide solutions
well now that we know what ai is let's
have a look at the two broad categories
an ais classified into
weak ai also called narrow ai focuses
solely on one task
for example alphago is a maestro of the
game go but you can't expect it to be
even remotely good at chess
this makes alphago a weak ai
you might say alexa is definitely not a
weak ai since it can perform multiple
tasks
well that's not really true when you ask
alexa to play despacito it picks up the
keywords play and despacito
and runs a program and is trained to
alexa cannot respond to a question it
isn't trained to answer for instance try
asking alexa the status of traffic from
work to home
alexa cannot provide you this
information as she is not trained to
and that brings us to our second
category of ai strong ai
now this is much like the robots that
only exist in fiction as of now
ultron from avengers is an ideal example
of a strong ai
that's because it's self-aware and
eventually even develops emotions
this makes the ai's response
unpredictable
you must be wondering well how is
artificial intelligence different from
machine learning and deep learning
we saw what ai is machine learning is a
technique to achieve ai and deep
learning in turn is a subset of machine
learning
machine learning provides a machine with
the capability to learn from data and
experience through algorithms
deep learning does this learning through
ways inspired by the human brain
this means through deep learning data
and patterns can be better perceived ray
kurzweil a well-known futurist predicts
that by the year 2045 we would have
robots as smart as humans this is called
the point of singularity well that's not
all
in fact elon musk predicts that the
human mind and body will be enhanced by
ai implants which would make us partly
cyborgs so here's a question for you
which of the below ai projects don't
exist yet
a an ai robot with citizenship
b a robot with a muscular skeletal
system
c ai that can read its owner's emotions
d ai that develops emotions over time
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comment section below
since the human brain is still a mystery
it's no surprise that ai2 has a lot of
unventured domains
for now ai is built to work with humans
and make our tasks easier
however with the maturation of
technology we can only wait and watch
what the future of ai holds for us
well that is artificial intelligence for
you in short do not forget to leave your
answer to the quiz in the comment
section below also like share and
subscribe to our channel if you enjoyed
this video stay tuned and keep learning
then we'll draw a comparison between
machine learning deep learning and
artificial intelligence we will also
learn about machine learning with a
tutorial and a use case demo after that
we'll see the top 10 applications of
machine learning in various industries
we will also understand the basics of
deep learning deep learning with python
and a deep learning tutorial we will
look at some important deep learning
applications at the end we'll explain to
you how to become an ai engineer and
look at a few important questions that
will help you crack an ai interview all
right i hope that has got you excited we
now have richard mohan and rahul who
will explain the various concepts of
artificial intelligence what is
artificial intelligence hello my name is
richard kirchner and today we're going
to go over what is artificial
intelligence one example of today's
artificial intelligence is a smart home
so welcome to my smart home smart homes
are run by artificial intelligence let's
have a look at some of the key features
of a smart house home appliances are
voice controlled sensors adjust lights
and air coolers according to the climate
security systems can detect movement
outside and worn at the residence all
the appliances are interconnected to
each other and can detect vehicles in
the driveway and let the owner know home
appliances can be controlled remotely
through the phone now this is just one
example in today's world so what's in it
for you today today we're going to cover
a brief history of artificial
intelligence what is artificial
intelligence types of artificial
intelligence applications of artificial
intelligence and just a quick glimpse of
the future of artificial intelligence
let us start with a brief history of
artificial intelligence let's start with
john mccarthy he was the first one to
coin the word artificial intelligence
and in 1956 had the first artificial
intelligence conference let's jump
forward to 1969 was shaky shaky was the
first general-purpose mobile robot built
and although by today's standard he was
very simple he did mark a milestone in
that we were now processing data
differently he was now able to do things
with a purpose versus just a list of
instructions albeit the list included
things like turning on and off lights
and pushing boxes around the room we're
going to move forward to 1990s
in 1997 the super computer deep blue was
designed which defeated the world's
chess champion in a game this is the
first time when we're actually seeing
the computer using logic to beat a human
doing some kind of logical uh in this
case a game so it was a huge milestone
by ibm to create this large computer
that was able to do that in a timely
fashion let's jump up to 2002 when we
have our first commercially successful
robotic vacuum cleaner nowadays you can
go down to the target and buy one but
back in 2002 that was the first model
that was put out and finally 2005 to
2018 today in the last more than a
decade we have a speech recognition rpa
dancing robot smart homes and many more
to come what i want you to notice about
this brief history of artificial
intelligence is the compression of time
in 1956 it was just an idea and more
than 10 years later we have our shaky
the first one who's able to flip light
switches and then we go all the way to
97 where we have deep blue and there's a
lot of little steps between 69 and 97
but it's actually able to take on a
human in chess and beat them regularly
now they did have a lot of ties so don't
think that it won every game and then we
go only four years later we have our
first commercially successful robotic
vacuum cleaner and as we go from 2005 to
2018 we go from simple speech
recognition to very complicated able to
really register with your google voice
and your siri we have our rpa we have
dancing robot smart homes and many more
things are just coming out almost
monthly in the world of artificial
intelligence so what is artificial
intelligence ai is a form of computer
science used to create intelligent
machines that can recognize human speech
objects can learn plan and solve
problems like humans and i'd like you to
focus just on that last one can solve
problems like humans as we saw earlier
we compare the computer that can beat
the chess champion it's able to the one
before that able to turn on and off
lights in the house so right now our
concept of artificial intelligence is
based primarily on our understanding of
how it interacts with humans and how we
can compare it to humans so speech
recognition that's a big one today
object detection solve problems and
learn from the given data and plan an
approach for future tasks to be done
these are all very human things that we
do to plan and solve for the future
types of artificial intelligence hi
heard you want to know the types of a.i
you can imagine a little robot taking us
on a tour the first type is purely
reactive the second type is limited
memory the third type theory of mind
which is still in the process of being
invented and definitely the question of
self-awareness being the fourth which is
still not invented yet or is it let's
look at these a little closer here we
have our purely reactive he does not
have any past memory or data to work
with he takes actions reacts based on
what he sees okay it's not that tough
observes every move you can see we have
a nice game of chess going on here and
wins takes the best possible decision
purely reactive machines specialize in
one field of work only in this case we
see a chess game where they figure out
the best moves calculating all the
different moves maybe it's calculating
the next one in a row in a linear
regression model so you can figure out
the best marketing but they're very
reactive they don't have a lot of data
they just have what's in front of them
to look at next let's look at limited
memory let's try to understand the
limited memory setup these machines use
previous data and keep adding it to
their memory so just me a good
restaurant so maybe we're looking to go
out for dinner tonight and we're not
sure what we want to eat hmm i see you
have been to kfc quite a lot in the past
week there is a kfc nearby so it goes
through the previous location data and
where they ate prior and says hmm this
is probably a good suggestion for you
tonight thanks it has enough memory or
experience to make proper decisions but
the memory is very limited this isn't
trying to
guess what a new location would be or
anything like that it just takes what it
has in front of it and goes okay this is
where you've been this is what you liked
you gave it two thumbs up one thumb down
whatever and then it goes from these
suggestions this is where i think you
should go theory of mind this kind of ai
has a capacity to understand thoughts
and emotions and interact socially a
machine based on this type is yet to be
built that human looks lonely hey human
you want to be my friend huh okay theory
of mind is a thing of the future
certainly we see a lot of the industry
poking a little bit at this as it tries
to guess how you feel about things but
most of that is still based on previous
data you know yes no two thumbs up one
thumb down theory in mind we take it one
step further in understanding the
emotions behind it and finally as we get
deep into the sci-fi futuristic we have
self-aware self-aware machines are
future generation of machines they will
be super intelligent sentient sentient
and conscious like the terminator the
good guy in the thing or ultron or
vision from avengers for right now these
are mostly movie characters or cartoon
characters but we certainly are getting
closer to seeing them in the real world
hopefully they'll be of the type of the
good guys and not the bad guys we see
also in the artificial intelligence
sci-fi movies applications of artificial
intelligence let's take a look at some
of today's commercial business uses for
the ai we have banking fraud detection
from a large data consisting of
fraudulent and non-fraudulent
transactions the ai learns to predict if
a new transaction is fraud or not online
customer support most of the customer
support is now being automated by
artificial intelligence cyber security
using machine learning algorithms and a
lot of sample data ai can be used to
detect anomalies adapt and respond to
threats virtual assistants siri cortana
alexa and google now use voice
recognition to follow the user's
commands these are all wonderful
examples of current ais that are in the
commercial and business world and these
ones in particular have matured over the
last half a decade for instance very few
large banks in today world would not use
banking for fraud detection or for
deciding whether it's a good person to
give a loan to or not based on their
credit scores and where they're from and
their income same thing with cyber
security detecting anomalies or online
customer support could you imagine in
say hp who has over 70 000
help pages across 17 different languages
now they have to figure out how to do
online customer support to cover new
problems that come up and track them so
they can build new pages if they had one
person doing that that would take them a
year just to do what they need to have
posted yesterday and of course our
virtual assistants i don't know about
you but i love mine kind of like having
a private secretary without having a
private secretary future of artificial
intelligence if we see where it's at now
commercially and business-wise then
where is it going of course the
imagination is a limit on this one but
you can already see the development in
the world today for automated
transportation they'll become a common
thing maybe even early as 2020 when they
have the final release from the leaders
in the industry humans will be able to
augment themselves with robots certainly
the idea of having the robot bring me my
coffee is lovely or when i'm doing
reports or something else on the
computer it does part of that work for
me so that i'm freed up to think about
other things there will be more numbers
of smart cities as vehicles phones home
appliances will be run by ai home robots
will help elderly people with the
day-to-day work japan already has a very
in-depth program where they begin to
integrate robots helping elderly even
some of the simple things like getting
that box of cereal off the top shelf or
monitoring if they fall and need to
contact the doctor in an emergency to
show up robots will take over hazardous
jobs like bomb defusing welding etc for
the future of artificial intelligence
you can see here a number of robotic
uses that are already in development
people are already working on these and
trying to bring them to us in a
commercial business fashion your own
imagination can take this to the next
level or a simple google search will
show you some of the stuff that's out
there now in addition to these versus
deep learning versus artificial
intelligence some of the most exciting
technologies evolving in today's world
covering the basics of these three
topics and how they connect and how they
are different let's just look at a few
examples so we get an understanding of
what's going on here's an example of
artificial intelligence in today's world
amazon echo
amazon echo is a wonderful tool you can
go in there and you can say hey alexa
what's the temperature in chicago
and the amazon echo then translates that
into zeros and ones and something the
computer understands
then it comes in and processes that
information to identify what you're
asking and what you need and where to
get that information
and then it comes back and says the
current temperature in chicago is 6
degrees fahrenheit or whatever it is at
the moment
so this is a wonderful example of
artificial intelligence that we're using
right now today where that's at as far
as a commercial deployment
machine learning a machine learning
example out there is google you're on
your google search engine it comes up
you spend a lot of time on the first
link you come into and you read the page
and uh google looks at that and says
okay he spent five minutes on this let's
give it a thumbs up
and then you go to the second page and
the third page you just kind of skip
over them and glance at them for a
couple seconds and google says i wasn't
interested in those pages let's give
them a thumbs down
so this is a good example of machine
learning as it starts guessing what you
like and what you don't like so it gives
you more information along what you're
going to read and actually use
and then we have an example of deep
learning
in this example we have a black and
white image
it comes into in this case a neural
network
some people like to call it a magic box
because you really it's hard to follow
all that's going on in there there's all
these different weights and connections
and nodes
and then it comes out
and colors the beach ball the people the
background
what's going on in here is the black and
white image goes into this neural
network and before it's ever gone in
the neural network has looked at all
these different pictures on the web or
wherever it pulls the data from
and it's already itemized them and kind
of separated them that
we have some that look like beach balls
we have some that look like people and
it programs that so that when the black
and white image comes in it goes okay
that piece right there
resembles this and all these other
photos
and the network is able to identify that
and then color the beach ball with the
colors that you see on there so it gives
it this is really wonderful because they
did a wonderful job coloring this
picture
and that's the full setup is where the
deep learning example comes in and they
usually center around neural networks
so we looked at a few examples what's in
it for you
first we're going to talk about human
versus artificial intelligence
this is very important because this is
our marker we as humans are amazing and
so we want to understand how artificial
intelligence compares
and what it does that it can accelerate
above humans and how it can integrate
with the human experience
what is machine learning and deep
learning all about are they really all
that different
we'll have a few more examples in here
and then we'll talk a little bit about
types of ai and machine learning and
comparing machine learning and deep
learning and finally a glimpse into the
future
human versus artificial intelligence
humans are amazing let's just face it
we're amazing creatures we're all over
the planet we're exploring
every nic chinook we've gone to the moon
we've gone into outer space we're just
amazing creatures
we're able to use the available
information to make decisions
to communicate with other people
identify patterns and data remember what
people have said adapt to new situations
so let's take a look at this so you can
get a picture you're a human being so
you know it's like to be human let's
take a look at artificial intelligence
versus the human artificial intelligence
develops computer systems that can
accomplish texts that require human
intelligence
so we're looking at this
one of the things that computers can do
they can provide more accurate results
this is very important
recently i did a project on cancer
whereas identifying markers
and as a human being you look at that
and you might be looking at all the
different images and the data that comes
off of them and say i like this person
so i want to give them a very good
outlook and the next person you might
not like so you want to give a bad
outlook well with artificial
intelligence you're going to get a
consistent prediction of what's going to
come out interacts with humans using
their natural language we've seen that
as probably the biggest development
feature right now that's in the
commercial market that everybody gets to
use as we saw with the example of alexa
they learn from their mistakes and adapt
to new environments so we see this
slowly coming in more and more and they
learn from the data and automate
repetitive learning
has a lot to do with the neural networks
you have to program thousands upon
thousands of pictures in there and it's
all automated so as today's computers
evolve it's very quick and easy and
affordable to do this
what is machine learning and deep
learning all about
imagine this say you had some time to
waste not that any of us really have a
lot of time anymore to just waste in
today's world
and you're sitting by the road and you
have a whole lot and a whole lot of time
passes by there's a few hours
and suddenly you wonder
how many cars buses trucks and so on
passed by in the six hours
now chances are you're not going to sit
by the road for six hours and count
buses cars and trucks unless you're
working for the city and you're trying
to do city planning and you want to know
hey do we need to add a new truck route
maybe we need a bicycle length we have a
lot of bicyclists here that kind of
thing so maybe city planning would be
great for this
machine learning well the way machine
learning works is we
have labeled data with features
okay so you have a truck or a car a
motorcycle a bus or a bicycle and each
one of those are labeled
it comes in and based on those labels
and comparing those features it gives
you an answer it's a bicycle it's a
truck it's a motorcycle this is a little
bit more in depth on this
and the model here it actually the
features we're looking at would be like
the tires someone sits there and figures
out what a tire looks like it takes a
lot of work if you try to try to figure
the difference between a car tire a
bicycle tire a motorcycle tire
so in the machine learning field this
could take a long time if you're going
to do each individual
aspect of a car
and try to get a result on there and
that's what they did do that was a very
this is still used on smaller amounts of
data where you figure out what those
features are and then you label them
deep learning so with deep learning
one of our solutions is to take a very
large unlabeled data set
and we put that into a training model
using artificial neural networks and
then that goes into the neural network
itself when we create a neural network
and you'll see the arrows are actually
kind of backward but
which actually is a nice point because
when we train the neural network
we put the bicycle in and then it comes
back and says if it's a truck it comes
back and says well you need to change
that to bicycle and then it changes all
those weights going backward they call
it back propagation
and let it know it's a bicycle and
that's how it learns once you've trained
the neural network you then put the new
data in and they call this testing the
model so you need to have some data
you've kept off to the side where you
know the answer to and you take that and
you provide the required output and you
say okay is this is this neural network
working correctly did it identify a bike
as a bike a truck as a truck a
motorcycle as a motorcycle let's just
take a little closer look at that
determining what objects are present in
the data so how does deep learning do
this and here we have the image of the
bike
it's 28 by 28 pixels that's a lot of
information there could you imagine
trying to guess that this is a bicycle
image by looking at each one of those
pixels and trying to figure out what's
around it
and we actually do that as human beings
it's pretty amazing we know what a
bicycle is and even though it comes in
as all this information
and what this looks like is the image
comes in
it converts it into a bunch of different
nodes in this case there's a lot more
than what they show here
and it goes through these different
layers and out comes and says okay this
is a bicycle
a lot of times they call this the magic
black box why because as we watch it go
across here
all these weights
and all the math behind this and it's
not it's a little complicated on the
math side you really don't need to know
that when you're programming or doing
working with the deep learning but it's
like magic you don't know you really
can't figure out what's going to come
out by looking what's in each one of
those dots and each one of those lines
are firing and what's going in between
them so we like to call it the magic box
so that's where deep learning comes in
and in the end it comes up and you have
this whole neural network it comes up
and says okay
we fire all these different pixels and
we connects all these different dots and
gives them different weights and says
okay this is a bicycle and that's how we
determine what the object is present in
the data with deep learning
machine learning we're going to take a
step into machine learning here and
you'll see how these fit together in a
minute the system is able to make
predictions or take decisions based on
past data that's very important for
machine learning is that we're
looking at stuff and based on what's
been there before we're creating a
decision on there we're creating
something out of there we're coloring a
beach ball we're telling you what the
weather is
in chicago
what's nice about machine learning is a
very powerful processing capability it's
quick and accurate outcomes so you get
results right away once you program the
system the results are very fast
and the decisions
and predictions are better they're more
accurate they're consistent
you can analyze very large amounts of
data some of these data things that
they're analyzing now are petabytes and
terabytes of data it would take
hundreds of people
hundreds of years to go through some of
this data and do the same thing that the
machine learning can do in a very short
period of time and it's inexpensive
compared to hiring hundreds of people so
it becomes a very affordable way to move
into the future is to apply the machine
learning
to whatever businesses you're working on
and deep learning systems think and
learn like humans using artificial
neural networks again it's like a magic
box performance improves with more data
so the more data the deep learning gets
the more it gives you better results
it's scalability so you can scale it up
you can scale it down you can increase
what you're looking at
currently you know we're limited by the
amount of computer processing power as
to how big that can get but that
envelope continually gets pushed every
day on what it can do
problem solved in an end-to-end method
so instead of having to break it apart
and you have the first piece coming in
and you identify tires and the second
piece is identifying
labeling handlebars and then you bring
that together that if it has handlebars
and tires it's a bicycle and if it has
something that looks like a large square
it's probably a truck the neural
networks does this all in one network
you don't really know what's going on in
all those weights and all those little
bubbles
but it does it pretty much
in one package that's why the neural
network systems are so big nowadays and
coming into their own
best features are selected by the system
and it this is important they kind of
put it's on a bullet on the side here
it's a subset of machine learning this
is important
we talk about deep learning it is a form
of machine learning there's lots of
other forms of machine learning data
analysis but this is the newest and
biggest thing that they apply to a lot
of different packages and they use all
the other machine learning tools
available to work with it and it's very
fast to test
you put in your information
you then have your group of tests
and then you held some aside you see how
does it do it's very quick to test it
and see what's going on with your deep
learning in your neural network
are they really all that different
ai versus machine learning versus deep
learning
concepts of ai so we have concepts of
iii you'll see natural language
processing
machine learning an approach to create
artificial intelligence so it's one of
the subsets of artificial intelligence
knowledge representation automated
reasoning computer vision
robotics
machine learning versus ai versus deep
learning or ai and machine learning and
deep learning
so we look at this we have ai with
machine learning and deep learning
and so we're going to put them all
together we find out that ai is the big
picture we have a collection of books
it goes through some deep learning
the digital data is analyzed text mining
comes through
the particular book you're looking for
maybe it's a genre books is identified
and in this case we have a robot that
goes and gives a book to the patron i
have yet to be at a library that has a
robot bring me a book but that will be
cool when it happens
so we'll look at some of the pieces here
this information goes into uh there's as
far as this example
the translation of the handwritten
printed data to digital form
that's pretty hard to do that's pretty
hard to go in there and translate
hundreds and hundreds of books and
understand what they're trying to
say
if you've never read them so in this
case we use the deep learning because
you can already use examples where
they've already classified a lot of
books and then they can compare those
texts and say oh okay this is a book on
automotive repair this is a book on
robotic building the digital data is in
analyzed then we have more text mining
using machine learning so maybe we'd use
a different program to do a basic
classify
what you're looking for and say oh
you're looking for
auto repair and computers so you're
looking for automated cars once it's
identified then of course it brings you
the book
so here's a nice summation of what we
were just talking about ai with machine
learning and deep learning deep learning
is a subset of machine learning which is
a subset of artificial intelligence
so you can look at artificial
intelligence as the big picture how does
this compare to the human experience
in either doing the same thing as a
human we do or it
does it better than us
and machine learning which has a lot of
tools
is something that learns from
data past experiences it's programmed
it's uh comes in there and it says hey
we already had these five things happen
the sixth one should be about the same
and then there's a lot of tools in
machine learning but deep learning then
is a very specific tool in machine
learning it's the artificial neural
network which handles large amounts of
data and is able to take huge pools
of experiences pictures and ideas and
bring them together
real life examples
artificial intelligence news generation
very common nowadays as it goes through
there and finds the news articles or
generates the news based upon
the news feeds
or the back end coming in and says okay
let's give you the actual news based on
this there's all the different things
amazon echo they have a number of
different prime music on there of course
there's also the
google command and there's also
cortana there's tons of smart home
devices now where we can ask it to turn
the tv on or play music for us that's
all artificial intelligence from front
to back
you're having a human experience
with these computers and these
objects that are connected to the
processing machine learning
spam detection very common machine
learning
doesn't really have the human
interaction part
so this is the part where it goes and
says okay that's a spam that's not a
spam and it puts it in your spam folder
search engine result refining
another example of machine learning
whereas it looks at your different
results and it go and it is able to
categorize them as far as this had the
most hits this is the least viewed this
has five stars you know however they
want to weight it
all exactly good examples of machine
learning and then the deep learning uh
deep learning another example is
as you have like a exit sign
in this case is translating it into
french
sorti i hope i said that right
neural network has been programmed with
all these different words and images and
so it's able to look at the exit in the
middle and it goes okay we want to know
what that is in french and it's able to
push that out in france french and learn
how to do that
and then we have chat bots
i remember when microsoft first had
their little paper clip
boy that was like a long time ago they
came up and you would type in there and
chat with it
these are growing you know it's nice to
just be able to ask a question and it
comes up and gives you the answer and
instead of it being were you just doing
a search on certain words it's now able
to start linking those words together
and form a sentence in that chat box
types of ai and machine learning
types of artificial intelligence this in
the next few slides are really important
so one of the types of artificial
intelligence is reactive machines
systems that only react they don't form
memories they don't have past
experiences they have something that
happens to them and they react to it
my washing machine is one of those
if i put a ton of clothes in it and it
all clumped on one side
it automatically adds a weight to
recenter it so that my washing machine
is actually a reactive machine working
with whatever the load is and keeps it
nice and so when it spins it doesn't go
thumping against the side
limited memory another form of
artificial intelligence
systems look into the past
information is added over a period of
time and information is short-lived when
we're talking about this
and you look at like a neural network
that's been programmed to identify cars
it doesn't remember all those pictures
it has no memory as far as the hundreds
of pictures you process through it all
it has is this is the pattern i use to
identify cars as the final output for
that neural network we looked at
so when they talk about limited memory
this is what they're talking about
they're talking about i've created this
based on all these things but i'm not
going to remember anyone specifically
theory of mind systems being able to
understand human emotions and how they
affect decision making to adjust their
behaviors according to their human
understanding
this is important because this is our
page mark this is how we know
whether it is an artificial intelligence
or not
is it interacting with humans in a way
that we can understand
without that interaction is just an
object uh so we talk about theory of
mind we really understand how it
interfaces that whole if you're in web
development user experience would be the
term i would put in there so the theory
of mind would be user experience how's
the whole ui connected together and one
of the final things is as we get into
artificial intelligence is systems being
aware of themselves
understanding their internal states and
predicting other people's feelings and
act appropriately so as artificial
intelligence continues to progress uh we
see ones that are trying to understand
well what makes people happy how would
they increase our happiness
uh how would they keep themselves from
breaking down if something's broken
inside they have that self-awareness to
be able to fix it and just based on all
that information
predicting which action would work the
best what would help people
if i know that you're having a cup of
coffee first thing in the morning is
what makes you happy as a robot i might
make you a cup of coffee every morning
at the same time
to help your life and help you grow
that'd be the self-awareness is being
able to know all those different things
types of machine learning and like i
said on the last slide this is very
important this is very important if you
decide to go in and get certified
machine learning or know more about it
these are the three primary types of
machine learning
the first one is supervised learning
systems are able to predict future
outcome based on past data requires both
an input and an output to be given to
the model for it to be trained
so in this case we're looking at
anything where you have a hundred images
of a bicycle
and those hundred images you know are
bicycle so it's they're presets someone
already looked at all hundred images and
said these are pictures of bicycles and
so the computer learns from those and
then it's given another picture
and maybe the next picture is a bicycle
and it says oh that resembles all these
other bicycles so it's a bicycle and the
next one's a car and it says that's not
a bicycle
that would be supervised learning
because we had to train it we had to
supervise it unsupervised learning
systems are able to identify hidden
patterns from the input data provided by
making the data more readable and
organized the patterns similarities or
anomalies become more evident you'll
heard the term cluster how do you
cluster things together some of these
things go together some of these don't
this is unsupervised where you can look
at an image
and start pulling the different pieces
of the image out
because they aren't the same the human
all the parts of the human are not the
same as a fuzzy tree behind them just
slightly out of focus which is not the
same as the beach ball it's unsupervised
because we never told it what a beach
ball was we never told them what the
human was and we never told it that
those were trees
all we told it was hey separate this
picture by things that don't match
and things that do match and come
together
and finally there's reinforcement
learning systems are given no training
it learns on the basis of the reward
punishment it received for performing
its last action it helps increase the
efficiency of a tool function or a
program reinforced learning a
reinforcement learning is kind of you
give it a yes or no yes you gave me the
right response no you didn't and then it
looks at that and says oh okay so based
on this data coming in
what i gave you was a wrong response so
next time i'll give you a different one
comparing machine learning and deep
learning so remember that deep learning
is a subcategory of machine learning so
it's one of the many tools and so they
we're grouping a ton of machine learning
tools all together linear regression
k means clustering there's all kinds of
cool tools out there you can use in
machine learning enables machines to
take decisions to make decisions on
their own based on past data
enables machines to make decisions with
the help of artificial neural networks
so it's doing the same thing but we're
using an artificial neural network as
opposed to one of the more traditional
machine learning tools
needs only a small amount of training
data this is very important when you're
talking about machine learning they're
usually not talking about huge amounts
of data we're talking about maybe your
spreadsheet from your business and your
totals for the end of the year when
you're talking about neural networks you
usually need a large amount of data to
train the data so there's a lot of
training involved if you have under 500
points of data that's probably
not going to go into machine learning or
maybe you have like the case of one of
the things 500 points of data and 30
different fields
it starts getting really confusing there
in artificial intelligence or machine
learning and the deep learning aspect
really shines when you get to that
larger data that's really complex
works well on a low-end systems
so a lot of the machine learning tools
out there you can run on your laptop
with no problem and do the calculations
there
where with the machine learning usually
needs a higher end system to work it
takes a lot more processing power to
build those neural networks and to train
them it goes through a lot of data we're
talking about the general machine
learning tools most features need to be
identified in advanced and manually
coded so there's a lot of human work on
here
the machine learns the features from the
data it is provided so again it's like a
magic box you don't have to know what a
tire is
it figures it out for you
the problem is divided into parts and
solved individually and then combined so
machine learning you usually have all
these different tools and use different
tools for different parts and the
problem is solved in an end-to-end
manner so you only have one neural
network or two neural networks that is
bringing the data in and putting it out
it's not going through a lot of
different processes to get there and
remember you can put machine learning
and deep learning together so you don't
always have just the deep learning
solving the problem by having selling
one piece of the puzzle
with regular machine learning and most
machine learning tools out there they
take longer to test and understand how
they work and with the deep learning
it's pretty quick once you build that
neural network you test it and you know
so we're dealing with very crisp rules
limited resources
you have to really explain how the
decision was made when you use most
machine learning tools but when you use
the deep learning tool inside the
machine learning tools
the system takes care of it based on its
own logic and reasoning and again it's
like a magic black box
you really don't know how it came up
with the answer you just know it came up
with the right answer a glimpse into the
future
so a quick glimpse into the future
artificial intelligence
using it to detecting crimes before they
happen
humanoid ai helpers which we already
have a lot of there'll be more and more
maybe it'll actually be androids that'd
be cool to have an android that comes
and get stuff out of my fridge for me
machine learning increasing efficiency
in healthcare that's really big in all
the forms of machine learning better
marketing techniques
any of these things
if we get into the sciences it's just
off the scale machine learning and
artificial intelligence go everywhere
and then the subcategory deep learning
increased personalization so what's
really nice about the deep learning is
it's going to start now catering to you
that'll be one of the things we see more
and more of
and we'll have more of a hyper
intelligent personal assistant i'm
excited about that hello and welcome to
machine learning tutorial part one this
is part one of a machine learning series
put on by simplylearn what's in it for
you today well we'll start off with a
brief explanation of why machine
learning and what is machine learning
and then we'll get into a few of the
types of machine learning machine
learning algorithms linear regression
decision trees support vector machine
and finally we'll do a use case where
we're going to classify whether recipe
is of a cupcake or a muffin using the
svm or the support vector machine sounds
like a delicious way to explore machine
learning so why machine learning why do
we even care about having these
computers come up and be able to do all
these new things for us well because
machines can now drive your car for you
still very in the infant stage but it's
just exploding as we see with google's
waymo and then uber had their program
which unfortunately crashed they know
that this is huge this is going to be
the huge industry to change our whole
transportation infrastructure machine
learning is now used to detect over 50
eye diseases do you know how amazing
that is to have a computer that double
checks for the doctor for things they
might miss that's just huge in the
health industry pretty soon they
actually do already have that in some
areas where maybe not for eyes but for
other diseases where they're using the
camera on your phone to help
pre-diagnose before you go and see the
doctor and because the machine can now
unlock your phone with your face
i mean that's just cool having it being
able to identify your face or your voice
and be able to turn stuff on and off for
you depending on where you're at and
what you need talking about an ultimate
automation or world we live in and as we
dig in deeper we have a nice example of
facebook as you can see here they have
the facebook post with halloween comment
yes if you want it order here nobody
likes spam post on facebook that annoy
them into interacting with likes shares
comments and other actions i remember
the original ones were all if you don't
click on here you will have bad luck or
some kind of fear factor well this is a
huge thing in social media when people
are getting spammed and so this tactic
known as engagement bait takes advantage
of facebook's news feed algorithm by
choosing engagement in order to get the
greater reach to eliminate engagement
bait the company reviewed and
categorized hundreds of thousands of
posts to train a machine learning model
that detects different types of
engagement bait so in this case we have
we're using facebook but this is of
course across all the different social
media they have different tools or
building and the facebook scroll gif
will be replaced kind of like a virus
coming in there and notices that there's
a certain set up with facebook and it's
able to replace it and they have like
vote baiting react baiting share baiting
they have all these different these are
kind of general titles but there
certainly are a lot of way of baiting
you to go in there and click on
something so they fed all this this data
was fed into the machine and then they
have the new post the new post comes up
that takes over part of the facebook
setup and that's what you're looking at
you're looking at this new post that's
replaced like a virus has replaced that
so what facebook do to eliminate this is
they start scanning for keywords and
phrases like this and checks the
click-through rate so it starts looking
for people who are clicking through it
without even looking at it or clicking
through it and it's not something that
normally would be clicked through once
facebook has scanned for these keywords
and phrases it is now able to identify
the spam coming in and this makes your
life easier so you're not getting
spammed it's not like walking through an
airport and a lot of countries you have
like hundreds of people trying to sell
you time share come join us sign up for
this eliminates that annoyingness so now
you can just enjoy your facebook and
your cat pictures or maybe it's your
family pictures mine is family certainly
people like their cat pictures too
another good example is google's
deepmind project alphago a computer
program that plays a board game go has
defeated the world's number one go
player and i hope i say his name right
kiji the ultimate go challenge game of
three of three was on may 27 2017 so
it's just last year that this happened
and what makes this so important is that
you know go is just is a game so it's
not like you're driving a car or
something in our real world but they are
using games to learn how to get the
machine learning program to learn they
want it to learn how to learn and that
is a huge step a lot of this is still in
its infant stage as far as development
as we saw what happened with the as i
referred to earlier the uber cars they
lost their whole division because they
jumped ahead too fast so it's still an
infant stage but boy is this like the
beginning of just an amazing world that
is automated in ways we can't even
imagine what tomorrow's going to look
like we've looked at a lot of examples
of machine learning so let's see if we
can give a little bit more of a concrete
definition
what is machine learning machine
learning is the science of making
computers learn and act like humans by
feeding data and information without
being explicitly programmed
we see here we have a nice little
diagram where we have our ordinary
system and your computer nowadays you
can even run a lot of the stuff on a
cell phone because cell phones advance
so much and then with artificial
intelligence and machine learning it now
takes the data and it learns from what
happened before and then it predicts
what's going to come next and then
really the biggest part right now in
machine learning that's going on is it
improves on that how do we find a new
solution so we go from descriptive words
learning about stuff and understanding
how it fits together to predicting what
it's going to do to post scripting
coming up with a new solution and when
we're working on machine learning
there's a number of different diagrams
that people have posted for what steps
to go through a lot of it might be very
domain specific so if you're working on
photo identification versus language
versus medical or physics some of these
are switched around a little bit or new
things are put in they're very specific
to the domain this is kind of a very
general diagram first you want to define
your objective very important to know
what it is you're wanting to predict
then you're going to be collecting the
data so once you've defined an objective
you need to collect the data that
matches
you spend a lot of time in data science
collecting data and the next step
preparing the data you got to make sure
that your data is clean going in there's
the old saying bad data in bad answer
out or bad data out and then once you've
gone through and we've cleaned all this
stuff coming in then you're going to
select the algorithm which algorithm are
you going to use you're going to train
that algorithm in this case i think
we're going to be working with svm the
support vector machine then you have to
test the model does this model work is
this a valid model for what we're doing
and then once you've tested it you want
to run your prediction you want to run
your prediction or your choice or
whatever output it's going to come up
with and then once everything is set and
you've done lots of testing then you
want to go ahead and deploy the model
remember i said domain specific this is
very general as far as the scope of
doing something a lot of models you get
halfway through and you realize that
your data is missing something and you
have to go collect new data because
you've run a test in here someplace
along the line you're saying hey i'm not
really getting the answers i need so
there's a lot of things that are domain
specific that become part of this model
this is a very general model but it's a
very good model to start with and we do
have some basic divisions of what
machine learning does that's important
to know for instance do you want to
predict a category well if you're
categorizing thing that's classification
for instance whether the stock price
will increase or decrease so in other
words i'm looking for a yes no answer is
it going up or is it going down and in
that case we'd actually say is it going
up true if it's not going up it's false
meaning it's going down this way it's a
yes no zero one do you want to predict a
quantity that's regression so remember
we just did classification now we're
looking at regression these are the two
major divisions in what data is doing
for instance predicting the age of a
person based on the height weight health
and other factors so based on these
different factors you might guess how
old a person is
and then there are a lot of domain
specific things like do you want to
detect an anomaly that's anomaly
detection this is actually very popular
right now for instance you want to
detect money withdrawal anomalies you
want to know when someone's making a
withdrawal that might not be their own
account we've actually brought this up
because this is really big right now if
you're predicting the stock whether to
buy stock or not you want to be able to
know if what's going on in the stock
market is an anomaly use a different
prediction model because something else
is going on you got to pull out new
information in there or is this just the
norm i'm going to get my normal return
on my money invested so being able to
detect anomalies is very big in data
science these days
another question that comes up which is
on what we call untrained data is do you
want to discover structure in unexplored
data and that's called clustering for
instance finding groups of customers
with similar behavior given a large
database of customer data containing
their demographics and past buying
records and in this case we might notice
that anybody who's wearing certain set
of shoes go shopping at certain stores
or whatever it is they're going to make
certain purchases by having that
information it helps us to market or
group people together so that we can now
explore that group and find out what it
is we want to market to them if you're
in the marketing world and that might
also work in just about any arena you
might want to group people together
whether they're based on their different
areas and investments and financial
background whether you're going to give
them a loan or not before you even start
looking at whether they're a valid
customer for the bank you might want to
look at all these different areas and
group them together based on unknown
data so you're not you don't know what
the data is going to tell you but you
want to cluster people together that
come together
let's take a quick detour for
quiz time oh my favorite so we're going
to have a couple questions here under
quiz time and we'll be posting the
answers in this part two of this
tutorial so let's go ahead and take a
look at these quiz times questions and
hopefully you'll get them all right
we'll get you thinking about how to
process data and what's going on can you
tell what's happening in the following
cases of course you're sitting there
with your cup of coffee and you have
your checkbox and your pen trying to
figure out what's your next step in your
data science analysis
so the first one is grouping documents
into different categories based on the
topic and content of each document very
big these days you know you have legal
documents you have maybe it's a sports
group documents maybe you're analyzing
newspaper postings
but certainly having that automated is a
huge thing in today's world
b identifying handwritten digits in
images correctly
so we want to know whether they're
writing an a or capital a b c
what are they writing out in their hand
digit their handwriting c behavior of a
website indicating that the site is not
working as designed
d predicting salary of an individual
based on his or her years of experience
hr hiring set up there so stay tuned for
part two we'll go ahead and answer these
questions when we get to the part two of
this tutorial or you can just simply
write at the bottom and send a note to
simply learn and they'll follow up with
you on it
back to our regular content
now these last few bring us into the
next topic which is another way of
dividing our types of machine learning
and that is with supervised unsupervised
and reinforcement learning supervised
learning is a method used to enable
machines to classify predict objects
problems or situations based on labeled
data fed to the machine and in here you
see we have a jungle of data with
circles triangles and squares and then
we label them we have what's a circle
what's a triangle what's a square and we
have our model training and it trains it
so we know the answer very important
when you're doing supervised learning
you already know the answer to a lot of
your information coming in so you have a
huge group of data coming in and then
you have a new data coming in so we've
trained our model the model now knows
the difference between a circle a square
a triangle and now that we've trained it
we can send in in this case a square and
a circle goes in and it predicts that
the top one's a square and the next
one's a circle and you can see that this
is uh being able to predict whether
someone's going to default on a loan
because i was talking about banks
earlier supervised learning on stock
market whether you're going to make
money or not that's always important and
if you are looking to make a fortune in
the stock market keep in mind it is very
difficult to get all the data correct on
the stock market it is very it
fluctuates and weighs you really hard to
predict so it's quite a roller coaster
ride if you're running machine learning
on the stock market you start realizing
you really have to dig for new data so
we have supervised learning and if you
have supervised we should need
unsupervised learning in unsupervised
learning machine learning model finds
the hidden pattern in an unlabeled data
so in this case instead of telling it
what the circle is and what a triangle
is and what a square is it goes in there
looks at them and says for whatever
reason it groups them together maybe
they'll group it by the number of
corners and it notices that a number of
them all have three corners a number of
them all have four corners and a number
of them all have no corners and it's
able to filter those through and group
them together we talked about that
earlier with looking at a group of
people who are out shopping we want to
group them together to find out what
they have in common and of course once
you understand what people have in
common maybe you have one of them who's
a customer at your store or you have
five of them our customer your store and
they have a lot in common with five
others who are not customers at your
store how do you market to those five
who aren't customers at your store yet
they fit the demographics of who's gonna
shop there and you'd like them to shop
at your store not the one next door of
course this is a simplified version you
can see very easily the difference
between a triangle and a circle which
might not be so easy in marketing
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning is an important type of machine
learning where an agent learns how to
behave in an environment by performing
actions and seeing the result we have
here where the in this case a baby it's
actually great that they used an infant
for this slide because the reinforcement
learning is very much in its infant
stages but it's also probably the
biggest machine learning demand out
there right now or in the future it's
going to be coming up over the next few
years is reinforcement learning and how
to make that work for us
and you can see here where we have our
action in the action on this one it goes
into the fire hopefully the baby didn't
it was just a little candle not a giant
fire pit like it looks like here when
the baby comes out and the new state is
the baby is sad and crying because they
got burned on the fire and then maybe
they take another action the baby's
called the agent because it's the one
taking the actions and in this case they
didn't go into the fire they went a
different direction and now the baby's
happy and laughing and playing
reinforcement learning is very easy to
understand because that's how as humans
that's one of the ways we learn we learn
whether it is you bring yourself on the
stove don't do that anymore don't touch
the stove in the big picture being able
to have a machine learning program or an
ai be able to do this is huge because
now we're starting to learn how to learn
that's a big jump in the world of
computer and machine learning and we're
going to go back and just kind of go
back over supervised versus unsupervised
learning understanding this is huge
because this is going to come up in any
project you're working on
we have in supervised learning we have
labeled data we have direct feedback so
someone's already gone in there and said
yes that's a triangle no that's not a
triangle and then you predict an outcome
so you have a nice prediction this is
this this new set of data is coming in
and we know what it's going to be and
then with unsupervised training it's not
labeled so we really don't know what it
is there's no feedback so we're not
telling it whether it's right or wrong
we're not telling it whether it's a
triangle or a square we're not telling
it to go left or right all we do is
we're finding hidden structure in the
data grouping the data together to find
out what connects to each other and then
you can use these together so imagine
you have an image and you're not sure
what you're looking for so you go in and
you have the unstructured data find all
these things that are connected together
and then somebody looks at those and
labels them now you can take that label
data and program something to predict
what's in the picture so you can see how
they go back and forth and you can start
connecting all these different tools
together to make a bigger picture there
are many interesting machine learning
algorithms let's have a look at a few of
them hopefully this gives you a little
flavor of what's out there and these are
some of the most important ones that are
currently being used we'll take a look
at linear regression decision tree and
the support vector machine
let's start with a closer look at linear
regression linear regression is perhaps
one of the most well-known and
well-understood algorithms in statistics
and machine learning linear regression
is a linear model for example a model
that assumes a linear relationship
between the input variables x and the
single output variable y and you'll see
this if you remember from your algebra
classes y equals mx plus c imagine we
are predicting distance traveled y from
speed x our linear regression model
representation for this problem would be
y equals m times x plus c or
distance equals m times speed plus c
where m is the coefficient and c is the
y-intercept and we're going to look at
two different variations of this first
we're going to start with time is
constant and you can see we have a
bicyclist he's got a safety gear on
thank goodness
speed equals 10 meters per second and so
over a certain amount of time his
distance equals 36 kilometers we have a
second bicyclist who's going twice the
speed or 20 meters per second and you
can guess if he's going twice the speed
and time is a constant then he's going
to go twice the distance and that's easy
to compute 36 times 2 you get 72
kilometers and so if you had the
question of how fast would somebody is
going three times at speed or 30 meters
per second is you can easily compute the
distance in our head we can do that
without needing a computer but we want
to do this for more complicated data so
it's kind of nice to compare the two but
let's just take a look at that and what
that looks like in a graph so in a
linear regression model we have our
distance to the speed and we have our m
equals the ve slope of the line and
we'll notice that the line has a plus
slope and as the speed increases
distance also increases hence the
variables have a positive relationship
and so your speed of the person which
equals y equals mx plus c distance
traveled in a fixed interval of time and
we could very easily compute either
following the line or just knowing it's
3 times 10 meters per second that this
is roughly 102 kilometers distance that
this third bicyclist has traveled one of
the key
definitions on here is positive
relationship so the slope of the line is
positive as distance increase so to
speed increase let's take a look at our
second example where we put distance is
a constant so we have speed equals 10
meters per second they have a certain
distance to go and it takes them 100
seconds to travel that distance and we
have our second bicyclist who's still
doing 20 meters per second since he's
going twice the speed we can guess that
he'll cover the distance in about half
the time 50 seconds and of course you
could probably guess on the third one
100 divided by 30 since he's going three
times the speed you can easily guess
that this is 33.333
seconds time we put that into a linear
regression model or graph if the
distance is assumed to be constant let's
see the relationship between speed and
time and as time goes up the amount of
speed to go that same distance goes down
so now your m equals a minus ve slope of
the line as the speed increases time
decreases hence the variable has a
negative relationship again there's our
definition positive relationship and
negative relationship depended on the
slope of the line and with a simple
formula like this
and even a significant amount of data
let's see with the mathematical
implementation of linear regression and
we'll take this data so suppose we have
this data set where we have x y x equals
1 2 3 4 5 standard series and the y
value is 3 2 2 4 3. when we take that
and we go ahead and plot these points on
a graph you can see there's kind of a
nice scattering and you could probably
eyeball a line through the middle of it
but we're going to calculate that exact
line for linear regression and the first
thing we do is we come up here we have
the mean of x i and remember mean is
basically the average so we added five
plus four plus three plus two plus one
and divide by five and that simply comes
out as three and then we'll do the same
for y we'll go ahead and add up all
those numbers and divide by five and we
end up with the mean value of y of i
equals 2.8 where the x i references it's
an average or means value and the y i
also equals a means value of y and when
we plot that you'll see that we can put
in the y equals 2.8 and the x equals 3
in there on our graph we kind of gave it
a little different color so you could
sort it out with the dashed lines on it
and it's important to note that when we
do the linear regression the linear
regression model should go through that
dot
now let's find our regression equation
to find the best fit line remember we go
ahead and take our y equals mx plus c so
we're looking for m and c so to find
this equation for our data we need to
find our slope of m and our coefficient
of c
and we have y equals mx plus c where m
equals the sum of x minus x average
times y minus y average or y means and x
means over the sum of x minus x means
squared that's how we get the slope of
the value of the line and we can easily
do that by creating some columns here we
have x y computers are really good about
iterating through data and so we can
easily compute this and fill in a graph
of data and in our graph you can easily
see that if we have our x value of one
and if you remember the x i or the means
value is three one minus three equals a
negative two and two minus three equals
a negative one so on and so forth and we
can easily fill in the column of x minus
x i y minus y i and then from those we
can compute x minus x i squared and x
minus x i times y minus y i and you can
guess it that the next step is to go
ahead and sum the different columns for
the answers we need so we get a total of
10 for our x minus x i squared and a
total of 2 for x minus x i times y minus
y i
and we plug those in we get 2 10 which
equals 0.2 so now we know the slope of
our line equals 0.2 so we can calculate
the value of c that'd be the next step
is we need to know where it crosses the
y axis and if you remember i mentioned
earlier that the linear regression line
has to pass through
the means value the one that we showed
earlier we can just flip back up there
to that graph and you can see right here
there's our means value which is 3
x equals 3 and y equals 2.8 and since we
know that value we can simply plug that
into our formula y equals 0.2 x plus c
so we plug that in we get 2.8 equals 0.2
times 3 plus c and you can just solve
for c so now we know that our
coefficient equals 2.2 and once we have
all that we can go ahead and plot our
regression line y equals 0.2 times x
plus 2.2 and then from this equation we
can compute new values so let's predict
the values of y using x equals 1 2 3 4 5
and plot the points remember the 1 2 3 4
5 was our original x values so now we're
going to see what y thinks they are not
what they actually are and we plug those
in we get y of designated with y of p
you can see that x equals 1 equals 2.4 x
equals 2 equals 2.6 and so on and so on
so we have our y predicted values of
what we think it's going to be when we
plug those numbers in and when we plot
the predicted values along with the
axial values we can see the difference
and this is one of the things that's
very important with linear aggression in
any of these models is to understand the
error and so we can calculate the error
on all of our different values and you
can see over here we plotted x and y and
y predict and we've drawn a little line
so you can sort of see what the error
looks like there between the different
points so our goal is to reduce this
error we want to minimize that error
value on our linear regression model
minimizing the distance there are lots
of ways to minimize the distance between
the line and the data points like sum of
squared errors sum of absolute errors
root mean square error etc we keep
moving this line through the data points
to make sure the best fit line has the
least square distance between the data
points and the regression line so to
recap with a very simple linear
regression model we first figure out the
formula of our line through the middle
and then we slowly adjust the line to
minimize the error keep in mind this is
a very simple formula the math gets even
though the math is very much the same it
gets much more complex as we add in
different dimensions so this is only two
dimensions y equals mx plus c but you
can take that out to x
z i j q all the different features in
there and they can plot a linear
regression model on all of those using
the different formulas to minimize the
error let's go ahead and take a look at
decision trees a very different way to
solve problems in the linear regression
model decision tree is a tree-shaped
algorithm used to determine a course of
action each branch of a tree represents
a possible decision occurrence or
reaction we have data which tells us if
it is a good day to play golf and if we
were to open this data up in a general
spreadsheet you can see we have the
outlook whether it's a rainy overcast
sunny temperature
hot mild cool humidity windy and did i
like to play golf that day yes or no so
we're taking a census and certainly i
wouldn't want a computer telling me when
i should go play golf or not but you can
imagine if you got up in the night
before you're trying to plan your day
and it comes up and says tomorrow would
be a good day for golf for you in the
morning and not a good day in the
afternoon or something like that this
becomes very beneficial and we see this
in a lot of applications coming out now
where it gives you suggestions and lets
you know what would be fit the match for
you for the next day or the next
purchase or the next uh whatever you
know next meal out in this case is
tomorrow a good day for playing golf
based on the weather coming in and so we
come up and let's uh determine if you
should play golf when the day is sunny
and windy so we found out the forecast
tomorrow is going to be sunny and windy
and suppose we draw our tree like this
we're going to have our humidity and
then we have our normal which is uh if
it's if you have a normal humidity
you're going to go play golf and if the
humidity is really high then we look at
the outlook and if the outlook is sunny
overcast or rainy it's going to change
what you choose to do so if you know
that it's a very high humidity and it's
sunny you're probably not going to play
golf because you're going to be out
there miserable fighting off the
mosquitoes that are out joining you to
play golf with you maybe if it's raining
you probably don't want to play in the
rain but if it's slightly overcast you
get just the right
shadow that's a good day to play golf
and be outside out on the green now in
this example you can probably make your
own creep pretty easily because it's a
very simple set of data going in but the
question is how do you know what to
split where do you split your data what
if this is much more complicated data
where it's not something that you would
particularly understand like studying
cancer they take about 36 measurements
of the cancerous cells and then each one
of those measurements represents how
bulbous it is how extended it is how
sharp the edges are something that as a
human we would have no understanding of
so how do we decide how to split that
data up and is that the right decision
tree but since the question is going to
come up is this the right decision tree
for that we should calculate entropy and
information gain two important
vocabulary words there are the entropy
and the information gain entropy entropy
is a measure of randomness or impurity
in the data set entropy should be low so
we want the chaos to be as low as
possible we don't want to look at it and
be confused by the images or what's
going on there with mixed data and the
information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split also known as entropy reduction
information gain should be high so we
want our information that we get out of
the split to be as high as possible
let's take a look at entropy from the
mathematical side
in this case we're going to denote
entropy as i of p of and n where p is
the probability that you're going to
play a game of golf and n is the
probability where you're not going to
play the game of golf now you don't
really have to memorize these formulas
there's a few of them out there
depending on what you're working with
but it's important to note that this is
where this formula is coming from so
when you see it you're not lost when
you're running your programming unless
you're building your own decision tree
code in the back and we simply have a
log squared of p over p plus n minus n
over p plus n times the log squared of n
of p plus n but let's break that down
and see what actually looks like when
we're computing that from the computer
script side entropy of a target class of
the data set is the whole entropy so we
have entropy play golf and we look at
this if we go back to the data you can
simply count how many yeses and no in
our complete data set for playing golf
days in our complete set we find we have
five days we did play golf and nine days
we did not play golf and so our i equals
if you had those together nine plus five
is fourteen and so our i equals five
over
and 9 over 14. that's our p and n values
that we plug into that formula and you
can go
5 over 14 equals 0.36 9 over 14 equals
0.64 and when you do the whole equation
you get the minus 0.36 log root squared
of 0.36 minus 0.64 log squared root of
0.64 and we get a set value we get
0.94
so we now have a full entropy value for
the whole set of data that we're working
with and we want to make that entropy go
down and just like we calculated the
entropy out for the whole set we can
also calculate entropy for playing golf
and the outlook is it going to be
overcast or rainy or sunny and so we
look at the entropy we have p of sunny
times e of three of two and that just
comes out how many sunny days yes and
how many sunny days no over the total
which is five don't forget to put the
we'll divide that five out later on
equals p overcast equals 4 comma 0 plus
rainy equals 2 comma 3. and then when
you do the whole setup we have 5 over
14. remember i said there was a total of
5 5 over 14 times the i of 3 of 2 plus 4
over 14 times the 4 comma 0 and 514 over
i of 2 3. and so we can now compute the
entropy of just the part that has to do
with the forecast and we get 0.693
similarly we can calculate the entropy
of other predictors like temperature
humidity and wind and so we look at the
gain outlook how much are we going to
gain from this entropy play golf minus
entropy play golf outlook and we can
take the original 0.94 for the whole set
minus the entropy of just the
rainy day and temperature and we end up
with a gain of 0.247
so this is our information gain remember
we define entropy and we define an
information gain the higher the
information gain the lower the entropy
the better the information gain of the
other three attributes can be calculated
in the same way so we have our gain for
temperature equals 0.029
we have our gain for humidity equals
0.152 and our gain for a windy day
equals 0.048 and if you do a quick
comparison you'll see the 0.247
is the greatest gain of information so
that's the split we want
now let's build the decision tree so we
have the outlook is it going to be sunny
overcast or rainy that's our first split
because that gives us the most
information gain and we can continue to
go down the tree using the different
information gains with the largest
information we can continue down the
nodes of the tree where we choose the
attribute with the largest information
gain as the root node and then continue
to split each sub node with the largest
information gain that we can compute and
although it's a little bit of a tongue
twister to say all that you can see
that's a very easy to view visual model
we have our outlook we split it three
different directions if the outlook is
overcast we're going to play and then we
can split those further down if we want
so if the outlook is sunny but then it's
also windy if it's windy we're not going
to play if it's not windy we'll play so
we can easily build a nice decision tree
to guess what we would like to do
tomorrow and give us a nice
recommendation for the day so we want to
know if it's a good day to play golf
when it's sunny and windy remember the
original question that came out
tomorrow's weather report is sunny and
windy you can see by going down the tree
we go outlook sunny outlook windy we're
not going to play golf tomorrow so our
little smart watch pops up and says i'm
sorry tomorrow is not a good day for
golf it's going to be sunny and windy
and if you're a huge golf fan you might
go uh-oh
it's not a good day to play golf we can
go in and watch a golf game at home so
we'll sit in front of the tv instead of
being out playing golf in the wind
now that we've looked at our decision
tree let's look at the third one of our
algorithms we're investigating support
vector machine support vector machine is
a widely used classification algorithm
the idea of support vector machine is
simple the algorithm creates a
separation line which divides the
classes in the best possible manner for
example dog or cat disease or no disease
suppose we have a labeled sample data
which tells height and weight of males
and females
a new data point arrives and we want to
know whether it's going to be a male or
a female so we start by drawing a line
we draw decision lines but if we
consider decision line 1 then we will
classify the individual as a male and if
we consider decision line two then it
will be a female so you can see this
person kind of lies in the middle of the
two groups so it's a little confusing
trying to figure out which line they
should be under we need to know which
line divides the classes correctly but
how the goal is to choose a hyperplane
and that is one of the key words they
use when we talk about support vector
machines choose a hyperplane with the
greatest possible margin between the
decision line and the nearest point
within the training set
so you can see here we have our support
vector we have the two nearest points to
it and we draw a line between those two
points and the distance margin is the
distance between the hyperplane and the
nearest data point from either set so we
actually have a value
and it should be equal the distance
between the two
points that we're comparing it to when
we draw the hyperplanes we observe that
line one has a maximum distance so we
observe that line one has a maximum
distance margin so we'll classify the
new data point correctly and our result
on this one is going to be that the new
data point is mel one of the reasons we
call it a hyperplane versus a line
is that
a lot of times we're not looking at just
weight and height we might be looking at
36 different features or dimensions and
so when we cut it with a hyperplane it's
more of a three-dimensional cut in the
data multi-dimensional it cuts the data
a certain way and each plane continues
to cut it down
until we get the best fit or match let's
understand this with the help of an
example problem statement i always start
with a problem statement when you're
going to put some code together we're
going to do some coding now classifying
muffin and cupcake recipes using support
vector machines so the cupcake versus
the muffin let's have a look at our data
set and we have the different recipes
here we have a muffin recipe that has so
much flour i'm not sure what measurement
55 is in but it has 55 maybe it's ounces
but has a certain amount of flour
certain amount of milk sugar butter egg
baking powder vanilla and salt and so
based on these measurements we want to
guess whether we're making a muffin or a
cupcake and you can see in this one we
don't have just two features we don't
just have height and weight as we did
before between the male and female in
here we have a number of features
in fact in this we're looking at eight
different features to guess whether it's
a muffin or a cupcake
what's the difference between a muffin
and a cupcake turns out muffins have
more flour while cupcakes have more
butter and sugar so basically the
cupcakes a little bit more of a dessert
where the muffins a little bit more of a
fancy bread but how do we do that in
python how do we code that to go through
recipes and figure out what the recipe
is and i really just want to say
cupcakes versus muffins like some big
professional wrestling thing before we
start in our cupcakes versus muffins we
are going to be working in python
there's many versions of python many
different editors that is one of the
strengths and weaknesses of python is it
just has so much stuff attached to it
it's one of the more popular data
science programming packages you can use
in this case we're going to go ahead and
use anaconda and jupyter notebook the
anaconda navigator has all kinds of fun
tools once you're into the anaconda
navigator you can change environments i
actually have a number of environments
on here we'll be using python36
environment so this is in python version
36 although it doesn't matter too much
which version you use
i usually try to stay with the 3x
because they're current unless you have
a project that's very specifically in
version 2x 27 i think is usually what
most people use in the version 2. and
then once we're in our
jupiter notebook editor i can go up and
create a new file and we'll just jump in
here
in this case we're doing svm muffin
versus cupcake and then let's start with
our packages
for
data analysis
and we almost always use a couple
there's a few very standard packages we
use
we use
imports import import
numpy
that's for number python they usually
denote it as np that's very comma
that's very common
and then we're going to import pandas as
pd
and numpy deals with number arrays
there's a lot of cool things you can do
with the numpy
setup
as far as multiplying all the values in
an array in a numpy array data array
pandas
i can't remember if we're using it
actually in this data set i think we do
as an import it makes a nice data frame
and the difference between a data frame
and a numpy array is that a data frame
is more like your excel spreadsheet you
have columns you have indexes you have
different ways of referencing it easily
viewing it and there's additional
features you can run on a data frame and
pandas kind of sits on numpy so they you
need them both in there
and then finally we're working with the
support vector machine so
from sk learn we're going to use the sk
learn model
import svm support vector machine
and then
as a data scientist you should always
try to visualize your data some data
obviously is too complicated or doesn't
make any sense to the human but if it's
possible it's good to take a second look
at it so you can actually see what
you're doing now for that we're going to
use two packages we're going to import
matplotlibrary.piplot as plt
again very common
and we're going to import seaborn as sns
and we'll go ahead and set the font
scale in the sns right in our import
line that's what this
semicolon followed by a line of data
we're going to set the sns and these are
great because the seaborne sits on top
of map plot library just like pandas
hits on numpy so it adds a lot more
features and uses and control we're
obviously not going to get into matplot
library and seabourn that'd be its own
tutorial we're really just focusing on
the svm the support vector machine from
sk learn and since we're in jupiter
notebook uh we have to add a special
line in here for our matplot library and
that's your percentage sign or amber
sign matplot library in line
now if you're doing this in just a
straight code project a lot of times i
use like notepad plus plus and i'll run
it from there you don't have to have
that line in there because it'll just
pop up as its own window on your
computer depending on how your
computer's set up because we're running
this in the jupyter notebook as a
browser setup this tells it to display
all of our graphics right below on the
page so that's what that line is for
remember the first time i ran this i
didn't know that i had to go look that
up years ago it was quite a headache so
matplot library inline is just because
we're running this on the web setup and
we can go ahead and run this make sure
all our modules are in they're all
imported which is great if you don't
have an import you'll need to go ahead
and pip use the pip or however you do it
there's a lot of other install packages
out there although pip is the most
common and you have to make sure these
are all installed on your python setup
the next step of course is we got to
look at the data you can't run a model
for predicting data if you don't have
actual data so to do that let me go and
open this up and take a look and we have
our cupcakes versus muffins
and it's a csv file or dot csv meaning
that it's comma separated variable
and it's going to open it up in a nice
spreadsheet for me and you can see up
here we have the type we have muffin
muffin muffin cupcake cupcake cupcake
and then it's broken up into flour milk
sugar butter egg baking powder vanilla
and salt
so we can do is we can go ahead and look
at this data also in our python
let us create a variable recipes equals
we're going to use our pandas module
dot read
csv remember is a comma separated
variable
and the file name happened to be
cupcakes versus muffins oops i got
double brackets there
do it this way
there we go cupcakes versus muffins
because the program i loaded or the the
place i saved this particular python
program is in the same folder we get by
with just the file name but remember if
you're storing it in a different
location you have to also put down the
full path on
there then because we're in pandas
we're going to go ahead and you can
actually inline you can do this but let
me do the full print and you can just
type in
recipes dot head
in the jupiter notebook but if you're
running in code in a different script
you need to go ahead and type out the
whole print recipes dot head
and panda's nose is that's going to do
the first five lines of data and if we
flip back on over to the spreadsheet
where we opened up our csv file
you can see where it starts on line two
this one calls it zero and then
two three four five six is going to
match
go and close that out because we don't
need that anymore
and it always starts at zero and these
are it automatically indexes it since we
didn't tell it to use an index in here
so that's the index number for the
left-hand side and it automatically took
the top row
as labels so panda's
using it to read a csv is just really
slick and fast one of the reasons we
love our pandas
not just because they're cute and cuddly
teddy bears
and let's go ahead and plot our data
and i'm not going to plot all of it i'm
just going to plot the
sugar and flower
now obviously
you can see where they get really
complicated if we have tons of different
features
and so you'll break them up and maybe
look at just two of them at a time to
see how they connect
and to plot them we're going to go ahead
and use seaborne
so that's our sns
and the command for that is sns.lm plot
and then the two different variables i'm
going to plot is flour and sugar
data equals recipes
the hue equals type
and this is a lot of fun because it
knows that this is pandas coming in
so this is one of the powerful things
about pandas mixed with seabourn and
doing
graphing
and then we're going to use a palette
set one there's a lot of different sets
in there you can go look them up for
seabourn or do a regular fit regular
equals false so we're not really trying
to fit anything
and it's a scatter kws
a lot of these settings you can look up
in seabourn half these you could
probably leave off when you run them
somebody played with this and found out
that these were the best settings for
doing a seaborn plot
let's go ahead and run that
and because it does it in line it just
puts it right on the page
and you can see right here that just
based on sugar and flour alone
there's a definite split
and we use these models because you can
actually look at it and say hey if i
drew a line right between the middle of
the blue dots and the red dots
we'd be able to do an svm and a hyper
plane right there in the middle
then the next step is to
format or pre
process
our
data and we're going to break that up
into two parts
we need a type
label and remember we're going to decide
whether it's a muffin or cupcake well a
computer doesn't know muffin or cupcake
it knows 0 and 1. so what we're going to
do is we're going to create a type label
and from this we'll create a numpy array
and p
where
and this is where we can do some logic
we take our recipes from our panda and
whatever type equals muffin it's going
to be zero and then if it doesn't equal
muffin which is cupcakes it's going to
be one so we create our type label
this is the answer so when we're doing
our training model remember we have to
have a training data this is what we're
going to train it with is that it's zero
or one it's a muffin or it's not
and then we're going to create our
recipe
features
and if you remember correctly from right
up here the first column is type
so we really don't need the type columns
that's our muffin or cupcake
and in pandas we can easily sort that
out
we take our value
recipes dot
columns that's a pandas function built
into pandas
we've got values converting them to
values so it's just the column titles
going across the top
and we don't want the first one so what
we do is since it always starts at zero
we want one
colon till the end
and then
we want to go ahead and make this a list
and this converts it to a list of
strings
and then we can go ahead and just take a
look and see we're looking at for the
features make sure it looks right
let me go ahead and run that
and i forgot the s on recipes so we'll
go ahead and add the s in there and then
run that and we can see we have flour
milk sugar butter egg
baking powder vanilla and salt and that
matches what we have up here right where
we printed out everything but the type
so we have our features and we have our
label
now the recipe features is just the
titles of the columns and we actually
need
the ingredients
and at this point we have a couple
options one we could run it over all the
ingredients
and when you're doing this usually you
do but for our example we want to limit
it so you can easily see what's going on
because if we did all the ingredients we
have you know that's what uh
seven eight different hyper planes that
would be built into it we only want to
look at one so you can see what the svm
is doing
and so we'll take our recipes and we'll
do just a flour and sugar
again you can replace that with your
recipe features and do all of them but
we're going to do just flour and sugar
and we're going to convert that to
values
we don't need to make a list out of it
because it's not string values these are
actual
values on there and we can go ahead and
just print
ingredients and you can see what that
looks like
and so we have just the amount of flour
and sugar just the two sets of plots
and just for fun let's go ahead and take
this over here and
take our recipe features
and so if we decided to use all the
recipe features
you'll see that it makes a nice column
of different data so it just strips out
all the labels and everything we just
have just the values
but because we want to be able to view
this easily in a plot later on we'll go
ahead and take that and just do flower
and sugar
and we'll run that you'll see it's just
the two columns
so the next step is to go ahead and fit
our model
we'll go ahead and just call it model
and it's a svm we're using a package
called svc
in this case we're going to go ahead and
set the kernel equals linear so it's
using a specific setup on there and if
we go to the reference on their website
for the
svm you'll see that there's about
there's eight of them here
three of them are for regression
three are for classification the svc
support vector classification is
probably one of the most commonly used
and there's also one for detecting
outliers
and another one that has to do with
something a little bit more specific on
the model but svc and sbr are the two
most commonly used standing for support
vector classifier and support vector
regression remember regression is an
actual value a float value or
whatever you're trying to work on and
sbc is a classifier so it's a yes no
true false
but for this we want to know zero one
muffin cupcake
if we go ahead and create our model and
once we have our model created we're
going to do model dot fit and this is
very common especially in the sk learn
all their models are followed with the
fit command
and what we put into the fit what we're
training with it is we're putting in the
ingredients which in this case we
limited to just flour and sugar
and the type label is it a muffin or
cupcake
now in more complicated data science
series you'd want to split into we won't
get into that today we split it into uh
training data and test data and they
even do something where they split it
into thirds where a third is used for
whether you switch between which ones
training and test there's all kinds of
things go into that it gets very
complicated when you get to the higher
end not overly complicated just an extra
step which we're not going to do today
because this is a very simple set of
data
and let's go ahead and run this and now
we have our model fit
and i got an error here so let me fix
that real quick
capital sbc it turns out
i did it lowercase
support vector
classifier there we go let's go ahead
and run that
and you'll see it comes up with all this
information that it prints out
automatically
these are the defaults of the model
you notice that we change the kernel to
linear and there's our kernel linear on
the printout and there's other different
settings you can mess with
we're going to just leave that alone for
right now for this we don't really need
to mess with any of those
so next we're going to dig a little bit
into our newly trained model and we're
going to do this so we can show you on a
graph
and let's go ahead and get the
separating
and we're going to say we're going to
use a w for our variable on here
we're going to do model
dot coefficient underscore 0.
so what the heck is that again we're
digging into the model so we've already
got a prediction and a train
this is a math behind it that we're
looking at right now
and so
the w is going to represent two
different coefficients and if you
remember we had y equals mx plus c
so these coefficients are connected to
that but in two-dimensional it's a plane
we don't spend
too much time on this because you can
get lost in the confusion of the math so
if you're a math whiz this is great you
can go through here and you'll see that
we have a equals minus w0 over w of one
remember there's two different values
there
and that's basically
the slope that we're generating
and then we're going to build an x x
what is xx we're going to set it up to a
numpy array there's our np dot line
space
so we're creating a line
of values between 30 and 60. so it just
creates a set of numbers for
x and then if you remember correctly we
have
our formula y equals the slope times x
plus the intercept
well to make this work we can do this as
y y
equals the slope times each value in
that array that's the neat thing about
numpy so when i do a times x x which is
a whole numpy array of values it
multiplies a across all of them
and then it takes those same values and
we subtract the model intercept that's
here uh
where we had mx plus c so that'd be the
c from the formula y equals mx plus c
and that's where all these numbers come
from a little bit confusing because it's
digging out of these different arrays
and then we want to do is we're going to
take this and we're going to go ahead
and plot it
so plot the parallels to separating
hyperplane that pass through the support
vectors
and so we're going to create b equals a
model
support vectors
pulling our support vectors out there
here's our y y which we now know is a
set of data and we have we're going to
create y y down
equals a times x x plus
b one minus a times b zero
and then model support vector b is going
to be set that to a new value the minus
one set up and y y up equals a times x x
plus b one minus a times b0
and we go ahead and just run this to
load these variables up if you wanted to
know understand a little bit more of
what's going on you can see if we print
yy let me just run that
you can see it's an array this is a line
it's going to have in this case between
30 and 60 so it's going to be 30
variables in here
and the same thing with yy up yy down
and we'll we'll plot those in just a
minute on the graph so you can see what
those look like
just go ahead and delete that out of
here
and run that so it loads up the
variables nice clean slate
i'm just going to copy this from before
remember this our sns
our seaborn plot lm plot flower sugar
and i'll just go ahead and run that real
quick so you can see remember what that
looks like it's just a straight graph on
there
and then one of the new things is
because seaborne sits on top of pie plot
we can do the pie plot for the line
going through and that is simply
plt.plot
and that's our xx
and yy are two corresponding values x y
and then somebody played with this to
figure out that the line width equals
two in the color black would look nice
so let's go ahead and run this whole
thing with the pie plot on there
and you can see when we do this it's
just doing flour and sugar on here
corresponding line between the sugar and
the flour and the muffin versus cupcake
and then we generated the support
vectors the yy down and yy out so let's
take a look and see what that looks like
so we'll do our pl plot
and again this is all against x
our x value but this time we have yy
down
and let's do something a little fun with
this
we can put in a k
dash dash
that just tells it to make it a dotted
line
and if we're going to do the down one
we also want to do the up one
so here's our yy
up
and when we run that it
both sets a line
and so here's our support and this is
what you expect you expect these two
lines to go through the nearest data
point so the dashed lines go through the
nearest muffin and the nearest cupcake
when it's plotting it and then your svm
goes right down the middle so it gives
it a nice split in our data and you can
see how easy it is to see based just on
sugar and flour
which one's a muffin or a cupcake
let's go ahead and create a function
to predict
muffin or cupcake
i've got my
recipes i pulled off the
internet and i want to see the
difference between a
muffin or a cupcake and so we need a
function to push that through and create
a function with def
and let's call it muffin or cupcake now
remember we're just doing flour and
sugar today we're not doing all the
ingredients
and that actually is a pretty good split
you really don't need all the
ingredients to know it's flour and sugar
and let's go ahead and do an if else
statement so if model predict
is of flour and sugar equals zero
so we take our model and we do it run a
predict it's very common in sk learn we
have a dot predict you put the data in
and it's going to return a value in this
case if it equals zero then print you're
looking at a muffin recipe
else if it's not zero that means it's
one then you're looking at a cupcake
recipe
that's pretty straightforward for a
function or def for definition d e f is
how you do that in python
and of course if you're going to create
a function you should run something in
it and so let's run a cupcake and we're
going to send it values 50 and 20 a
muffin or cupcake i don't know what it
is
and let's run this and just see what it
gives us
it says oh it's a muffin you're looking
at a muffin recipe
so it very easily predicts whether we're
looking at a muffin or a cupcake recipe
let's
plot this
there we go plot this on the graph so we
can see what that actually looks like
and i'm just going to copy and paste it
from below where we're plotting all the
points in there
so this is nothing different than we did
before if i run it
you'll see it has all the points and the
lines on there and what we want to do is
we want to add another point
and we'll do plt plot
and if you remember correctly we did for
our test we did 50
and 20.
and then somebody went in here and
decided we'll do uh y o for yellow or
it's kind of a oranges yellow color is
going to come out marker size nine those
are settings you can play with somebody
else played with them to come up with
the right setup so it looks good
and you can see there it is graphed
clearly a muffin
in this case in cupcakes versus muffins
the muffin has won
and if you'd like to do your own muffin
cupcake
contender series you certainly can send
a note down below and the team at
simplylearn will send you over the data
they use for the muffin and cupcake and
that's true of any of the data we didn't
actually run a plot on it earlier we had
min vs women
you can also request that information to
run it on your data setup so you can
test that out
so to go back over our setup we went
ahead for our support vector machine
code we did a predict 40 parts flower 20
parts sugar i think it was different
than the one we did whether it's a
muffin or a cupcake hence we have built
a classifier using svm which is able to
classify if a recipe is of a cupcake or
a muffin which wraps up our cupcake
versus muffin
welcome to machine learning tutorial
part 2. my name is richard kirchner with
the simply learn team that is
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead today in our
second tutorial we're going to cover
k-means and linear regression along with
going over the quiz questions we had
during our first tutorial
what's in it for you we're going to
cover clustering what is clustering k
means clustering which is one of the
most common use clustering tools out
there including a flow chart to
understand k-means clustering and how it
functions and then we'll do an actual
python live demo on clustering of cars
based on brands then we're going to
cover logistic regression what is
logistic regression logistic regression
curve and sigmoid function
and then we'll do another python code
demo to classify a tumor as malignant or
benign based on features
and let's start with clustering suppose
we have a pile of books of different
genres now we divide them into different
groups like fiction horror education and
as we can see from this young lady she
definitely is into heavy you can
just tell by those eyes and the maple
canadian leaf on her shirt but we have
fiction horror and education we want to
go ahead and divide our books up well
organizing objects into groups based on
similarity is clustering and in this
case as we're looking at the books we're
talking about clustering things with
known categories but you can also use it
to explore data so you might not know
the categories you just know that you
need to divide it up in some way to
conquer the data and to organize it
better but in this case we're going to
be looking at clustering in specific
categories and let's just take a deeper
look at that we're going to use k means
clustering k means clustering is
probably the most commonly used
clustering tool in the machine learning
library k-means clustering is an example
of unsupervised learning if you remember
from our previous thing it is used when
you have unlabeled data so we don't know
the answer yet we have a bunch of data
that we want to cluster to different
groups define clusters in the data based
on feature similarity so we've
introduced a couple terms here we've
already talked about unsupervised
learning and unlabeled data so we don't
know the answer yet we're just going to
group stuff together and see if we can
find an answer of how things connect
we've also introduced feature similarity
features being different features of the
data now with books we can easily see
fiction and
horror and history books but a lot of
times with data some of that information
isn't so easy to see right when we first
look at it and so k-means is one of
those tools where we can start finding
things that connect that match with each
other suppose we have these data points
and want to assign them into a cluster
now when i look at these data points i
would probably group them into two
clusters just by looking at them i'd say
two of these group of data kind of come
together
but in k-means we pick k clusters and
assign random centroids to clusters
where the k clusters represents two
different clusters we pick k clusters
and cirandom centroids to the clusters
then we compute distance from objects to
the centroids now we form new clusters
based on minimum distances
and calculate the centroids so we figure
out what the best distance is for the
centroid then we move the centroid and
recalculate those distances repeat
previous two steps iteratively till the
cluster centroid stop changing their
positions and become static
repeat previous two steps iteratively
till the cluster centroid stop changing
and the positions become static once the
clusters become static then k-means
clustering algorithm is said to be
converged and there's another term we
see throughout machine learning is
converged that means whatever math we're
using to figure out the answer has come
to a solution or it's converged on an
answer so we see the flowchart to
understand make a little bit more sense
by putting it into a nice easy step by
step so we start we choose k we'll look
at the elbow method in just a moment we
assign random centroids two clusters and
sometimes you pick the centroids because
you might look at the data in a graph
and say oh these are probably the
central points then we compute the
distance from the objects to the
centroids
we take that and we form new clusters
based on minimum distance and calculate
their centroids then we compute the
distance from objects to the new
centroids and then we go back and repeat
those last two steps we calculate the
distances so as we're doing it brings
into the new centroid and then we move
the centroid around and we figure out
what the best which objects are closest
to each centroid so the objects can
switch from one centroid to the other
the centroids are moved around and we
continue that until it is converged
let's see an example of this
suppose we have this data set of seven
individuals and their score on two
topics a and b so here's our subject
in this case referring to the person
taking the test
and then we have subject a where we see
what they've scored on their first
subject and we have subject b and we can
see what they score on the second
subject now let's take two farthest
apart points as initials cluster
centroids remember we talked about
selecting them randomly or we can also
just put them in different points and
pick the furthest one apart so they move
together either one works okay depending
on what kind of data you're working on
and what you know about it
so we took the two furthest points one
and one and five and seven and now let's
take the two farthest apart points as
initial cluster centroids
each point is then assigned to the
closest cluster with respect to the
distance from the centroids so we take
each one of these points in there we
measure that distance and you can see
that if we measure each of those
distances and you use the the
pythagorean theorem for a triangle in
this case because you know the x and the
y and you can figure out the diagonal
line from that or you just take a ruler
and put it on your monitor that'd be
kind of silly but it would work if
you're just eyeballing it you can see
how they naturally come together in
certain areas now we again calculate the
centroids of each cluster so cluster one
and then cluster two and we look at each
individual dot there's one two three
we're in one cluster the centroid then
moves over it becomes one point eight
comma two point three so remember is
that one and one well the very center of
the data we're looking at would put it
at the one point roughly two two but one
1.8 and 2.3 and the second one if we
wanted to make the overall mean vector
the average vector of all the different
distances to that centroid we come up
with 4 comma 1 and 5 4. so we've now
moved the centroids we compare each
individual's distance to its own cluster
mean and to that of the opposite cluster
and we find
build a nice chart on here that the as
we move the centroid around we now have
a new different kind of clustering of
groups and using euclidean distance
between the points and the mean we get
the same formula you see these new
formulas coming up so we have our
individual dots distance to the mean
centroid of the cluster and distance to
the mean centroid of the cluster
only individual 3 is nearer to the mean
of the opposite cluster cluster two then
its own cluster one and you can see here
in the diagram where we've kind of
circled that one in the middle so when
we've moved the cluster the centroids of
the clusters over one of the points
shifted to the other cluster because
it's closer to that group of individuals
thus individual 3 is relocated to
cluster 2 resulting in a new partition
and we regenerate all those numbers of
how close they are to the different
clusters for the new clusters we will
find the actual cluster centroids so now
we move the centroids over and you can
see that we've now formed two very
distinct clusters on here on comparing
the distance of each individual's
distance to its own cluster mean and to
that of the opposite cluster we find
that the data points are stable hence we
have our final clusters now if you
remember i brought up a concept earlier
k-mean on the k-means algorithm choosing
the right value of k will help in less
number of iterations and to find the
appropriate number of clusters in a data
set we use the elbow method and within
sum of squares wss is defined as the sum
of the squared distance between each
member of the cluster in its centroid
and so you see we've done here is we
have the number of clusters and as you
do
the same k-means algorithm over the
different clusters and you calculate
what that centroid looks like and you
find the optimal you can actually find
the optimal number of clusters using the
elbow the graph is called as the elbow
method and on this we guessed it two
just by looking at the data but as you
can see
the slope you actually just look for
right there where the elbow is in the
slope and you have a clear answer that
we want two different to start with k
means equals two a lot of times people
end up computing k-means equals 2 3 4 or
5 until they find the value which fits
on the elbow joint sometimes you can
just look at the data and if you're
really good with that specific domain
remember domain i mentioned that last
time you'll know that where to pick
those numbers or where to start guessing
at what that k value is
so let's take this and we're going to
use a use case using k-means clustering
to cluster cars into brands using
parameters such as horsepower cubic
inches make year etc so we're going to
use the dataset cars data having
information about three brands of cars
toyota honda and nissan we'll go back to
my favorite tool the anaconda navigator
with the jupiter notebook and let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupiter
notebook and in our jupiter notebook i'm
going to go ahead and just paste the
basic
code that we usually start a lot of
these off with we're not going to go too
much into this code because we've
already discussed numpy we've already
discussed matplot library and pandas
they'll be being the number array pandas
being the pandas data frame and map plot
for the graphing and don't forget uh
since if you're using the jupiter
notebook you do need the matte plot
library inline so that it plots
everything on the screen if you're using
a different python editor then you
probably don't need that because it'll
have a pop-up window on your computer
and we'll go ahead and run this just to
load our libraries and our setup into
here the next step is of course to look
at our data which i've already opened up
in a spreadsheet and you can see here we
have the miles per gallon cylinders
cubic inches horsepower
how weight pounds how heavy it is time
it takes to get to 60
my card is probably on this one at about
80 or 90. what year it is so this is you
can actually see this is kind of older
cars and then the brand toyota
honda nissan so the different cars are
coming from all the way from 1971 if we
scroll down
to
the 80s we have between the 70s and 80s
the number of cars that they've put out
and let's uh when we come back here
we're going to importing the data so
we'll go ahead and do data set equals
and we'll use pandas to read this in and
it's a from a csv file remember you can
always post this in the comments and
request the data files for these either
in the comments here on the youtube
video or go to simplylearn.com and
request that the car csv i put it in the
same folder as the code that i've stored
so my python code is stored in the same
folder so i don't have to put the full
path if you store them in different
folders you do have to change this and
double check your name variables and
we'll go ahead and run this and we've
chosen data set arbitrarily because it's
a data set we're importing and we've now
imported our car csv into the data set
as you know you have to prep the data so
we're going to create the x data this is
the one that we're going to try to
figure out what's going on with and then
there's a number of ways to do this but
we'll do it in a simple loop so you can
actually see what's going on so we'll do
4 i
and x dot columns so we're going to go
through each of the columns
and a lot of times it's important i'll
make lists of the columns and do this
because i might remove certain columns
or there might be columns that i want to
be processed differently but for this we
can go ahead and take x of i
and we want to go fill in a and that's a
pandas command but the question is what
are we going to fill the missing data
with we definitely don't want to just
put in a number that doesn't actually
mean something and so one of the tricks
you can do with this
is we can take x of i
and in addition to that we want to go
ahead and turn this into
an integer because a lot of these are
integers so we'll go ahead and keep it
integers and let me add the bracket here
and a lot of editors will do this
they'll think that you're closing one
bracket make sure you get that second
bracket in there if it's a double
bracket that's always something that
happens regularly so once we have our
integer of x of y this is going to fill
in any missing data with the average and
i was so busy closing one set of
brackets i forgot that the mean is also
has brackets in there for the pandas so
we can see here we're going to fill in
all the data with the average value for
that column so there's missing data it's
in the average of the data it does have
then once we've done that we'll go ahead
and loop through it again
and just check and see
to make sure everything is filled in
correctly and we'll print and then we
take x
is null and this returns a set of the
null value or the how many lines are
null and we'll just sum that up to see
what that looks like and so when i run
this
and so with the x what we want to do is
we want to remove the last column
because that had the models that's what
we're trying to see if we can cluster
these things and figure out the models
there is so many different ways to sort
the x out for one we could take the x
and we could go data set our variable
we're using and use the i location one
of the features that's in pandas
and we could take that and then take all
the rows
and all but the last column of the data
set
and at this time we could do values we
just converted to values so that's one
way to do this and if i let me just put
this down here and print
x
it's a capital x we chose and i run this
you can see it's just the values we
could also take out the values and
it's not going to return anything
because there's no values connected to
it what i like to do with this
is instead of doing the i location which
does integers more common is to come in
here and we have our data set and we're
going to do data set
dot or data set dot columns and remember
that lists all the columns so if i come
in here
let me just mark that as red
and i print
data set dot columns
you can see that i have my index here i
have my mpg cylinders everything
including the brand which we don't want
so the way to get rid of the brand would
be to do data columns of everything but
the last one minus one so now if i print
this you'll see the brand disappears
and so i can actually just take data set
columns minus one
and i'll put it right in here for the
columns we're going to look at
and let's un mark this
and unmark this
and now if i do an x dot head
i have a new data frame and you can see
right here we have all the different
columns except for the brand at the end
of the year
and it turns out when you start playing
with the data set you're going to get an
error later on and it'll say cannot
convert string to float value and that's
because if for some reason these things
the way they recorded them must been
recorded as strings so we have a neat
feature in here on pandas to convert
and it is simply convert objects
and for this we're going to do convert
oops convert underscore
numeric numeric
equals
true and yes i did have to go look that
up i don't have it memorized the convert
numeric in there if i'm working with a
lot of these things i remember them but
depending on where i'm at what i'm doing
i usually have to look it up and we run
that oops i must have missed something
in here let me double check my spelling
and when i double check my spilling
you'll see i missed the first underscore
in the convert objects when i run this
it now has everything converted
into a numeric value because that's what
we're going to be working with is
numeric values down here
and the next part is that we need to go
through the data and eliminate null
values
most people when they're doing small
amounts working with small data pools
discover afterwards that they have a
null value and they have to go back and
do this
so you know be aware
whenever we're formatting this data
things are going to pop up and sometimes
you go backwards to fix it
and that's fine that's just part of
exploring the data and understanding
what you have
and i should have done this earlier but
let me go ahead and increase the size of
my window one notch
there we go easier to see
so we'll do 4i in
working with x dot
columns we'll page through all the
columns and we want to take
x of i and we're going to change that
we're going to alter it
and so
with this we want to go ahead and fill
in
x of i pandas has
the fill in a
and that just fills in any non-existent
missing data
and we'll put my brackets up and there's
a lot of different ways to fill this
data
if you have a really large data set some
people just void out that data because
and then look at it later in a separate
exploration of data
one of the tricks we can do is we can
take our column
and we can find the means
and the means is in other or quotation
marks
so we take the columns we're going to
fill in the non-existing one with the
means the problem is that returns a
decimal float so some of these aren't
decimals
certainly let me be a little careful of
doing this but for this example we're
just going to fill it in with the
integer version of this it keeps it on
par with the other data that isn't a
decimal point
and then what we also want to do is we
want to double check
a lot of times you do this first part
first to double check then you do the
fill and then you do it again just to
make sure you did it right so we're
going to go through and test
for missing data
and one of the ways you can do that is
simply go in here
and take our x of i
column so it's going to go through the x
of i column it says is null
so it's going to return any any place
there's a null value it actually goes
through all the rows of each column is
null and then we want to go ahead and
sum that so we take that and we add the
sum value and these are all pandas so is
null is a panda command and so is sum
and if we go through that we go ahead
and run it
and we go ahead and take and run that
you'll see that all the columns have
zero null values so we've now tested and
double checked and our data is nice and
clean we have no null values everything
is now a number value we turned it into
numeric
and we've removed the last column in our
data
and at this point we're actually going
to start using the elbow method to find
the optimal number of clusters so we're
now actually getting into the sk learn
part
uh the k means clustering on here
i guess we'll go ahead and zoom it up
one more not so you can see what i'm
typing in here
and then from
sk learn we're going to our sk learn
cluster
we're going to import
k means
i always forget to capitalize the k and
the m when i do this so it's capital k
capital m k means
and we'll go and create a um
array wcs
equals when we get an empty array if you
remember from the elbow method from our
slide
within the sums of squares wss is
defined as the sum of square distance
between each member of the cluster and
its centroid so we're looking at that
change in differences as far as a
squared distance and we're going to run
this over a number of k-mean values
in fact let's go for i in range we'll do
11 of them
rain 0 11
and the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to create the actual
[Music]
all lower case
and so we're going to create this object
from the k-means that we just imported
and the variable that we want to put
into this is in
clusters
we're going to set that equals to i
that's the most important one because
we're looking at how increasing the
number of clusters
changes our answer there are a lot of
settings to the k-means
our guys in the back did a great job
just kind of playing with some of them
the most common ones that you see in a
lot of stuff is how you init your
k-means so we have k-means plus
plus
this is just a tool to let the model
itself be smart how it picks the
centroids to start with its initial
centroids we only want to iterate no
more than 300 times we have a max
iteration we put in there
we have the infinite the random state
equals zero you really don't need to
worry too much about these when you're
first learning this as you start digging
in deeper you start finding that these
are shortcuts that will speed up the
process
as far as a setup but the big one that
we're working with is the in clusters
equals i so we're going to literally
train our k means 11 times we're going
to do this process 11 times
and if you're working with big data you
know the first thing you do is you run a
small sample of the data so you can test
all your stuff on it
and you can already see the problem that
if i'm going to iterate through a
terabyte of data 11 times and then the
k-means itself is iterating through the
data multiple times that's a heck of a
process
so you got to be a little careful with
this a lot of times though you can find
your elbow using the elbow method find
your optimal number on a sample of data
especially if you're working with larger
data sources
so we want to go ahead and take our
k-means and we're just going to fit it
if you're looking at any of the sk learn
very common that you fit your model and
if you remember correctly our variable
we're using is the capital x
and once we fit this value we go back to
the
array we made and we want to go and just
append that value on the end
and it's not the actual fit we're
pinning in there it's when it generates
it it generates the value you're looking
for is inertia so k means dot inertia
will pull that specific value out that
we
need and let's get a visual on this
we'll do our plt plot
and what we're plotting here
is first the x axis which is range 0
11 so that will generate a nice little
plot there
and the wcss for our y-axis
it's always nice to give our plot a
title
and let's see we'll just give it the
elbow method for the title and let's get
some labels so let's go ahead and do plt
x label
and
we'll do number of clusters for that
and plt y label
and for that we can do oops there we go
wcss since that's what we're doing on
the plot on there and finally we want to
go ahead and display our graph which is
simply plt dot oops
dot show there we go and because we have
it set to inline it'll appear in line
hopefully i didn't make a type error on
there
and you can see we get a very nice graph
you can see a very nice elbow joint
there at
2 and again right around three and four
and then after that there's not very
much
now as a data scientist if i was looking
at this
i would do either three or four and i'd
actually try both of them to see what
the
output look like and they've already
tried this in the back so we're just
going to use three as a setup on here
and let's go ahead and see what that
looks like when we actually use this to
show the different kinds of cars
and so let's go ahead and apply the
k-means to the car's data set
and basically we're going to copy the
code that we loop through up above
where k means equals k means number of
clusters and we're just going to set the
number of clusters to 3.
since that's what we're going to look
for and you can do 3 and 4 on this and
graph them just to see how they come up
differently be kind of curious to look
at that but for this we're just going to
set it to 3. go ahead and create our own
variable y
k means for our answers
and we're going to set that equal to
whoops a double equal there to k means
but we're not going to do a fit we're
going to do a fit predict is the setup
you want to use and when you're using
untrained models you'll see a slightly
different usually you see fit and then
you see just the predict but we want to
both fit and predict the k-means on this
and that's fit underscore predict and
then our capital x is the data we're
working with
and before we plot this data we're going
to do a little pandas trick we're going
to take our x value and we're going to
set x as matrix
so we're converting this into a nice
rows and columns kind of set up but we
want the we're going to have columns
equals none so it's just going to be a
matrix of data in here
and let's go ahead and run that
a little warning you'll see these
warnings pop up because things are
always being updated so there's like
minor changes in the versions and future
versions
instead of matrix now that it's more
common to set it dot values instead of
doing as matrix but math matrix works
just fine for right now and you'll want
to update that later on but let's go
ahead and dive in and plot this and see
what that looks like
and before we dive into plotting this
data i always like to take a look and
see what i am plotting so let's take a
look at y
k means i'm just going to print that out
down here
and we see we have an array of answers
we have 2 1 0 2 1 2
so it's clustering these different
rows of data
based on the three different spaces it
thinks it's going to be
and then let's go ahead and print x and
see what we have for x and we'll see
that x is an array it's a matrix so we
have our different values in the array
and what we're going to do it's very
hard to plot all the different values in
the array so we're only going to be
looking at the first two or positions
zero and one
and if you were doing a full
presentation in front of the board
meeting
you might actually do a little different
than and dig a little deeper into the
different aspects because this is all
the different columns we looked at but
we look at columns one and two for this
to make it easy
so let's go ahead and clear this data
out of here and let's bring up our plot
and we're going to do a scatter plot
here so plt scatter
and
this looks a little complicated so let's
explain what's going on with this
we're going to take the x values
and we're only interested in y of k
means equals 0 the first cluster okay
and then we're going to take value 0 for
the x-axis and then we're going to do
the same thing here
we're only interested in
k means equals 0 but we're going to take
this second column so we're looking at
the first two columns in our answer or
in the data
and then the guys in the back played
with this a little bit to make it pretty
and they discovered that it looks good
if that's the size equals 100 that's the
size of the dots
we're going to use red for this one and
when they were looking at the data and
what came out it was definitely the
toyota on this we're just going to go
ahead and label it toyota again that's
something you really have to explore in
here as far as playing with those
numbers and see what looks good we'll go
ahead and hit enter in there and i'm
just going to paste in the next
two lines which is the next two cars
and this is our nissa and honda
and you'll see with our scatter plot
we're now looking at where y underscore
k means equals one
and we want the zero column and y k
means equals two again we're looking at
just the first two columns zero and one
and each of these rows then corresponds
to nissan and honda
and i'll go ahead and hit enter on there
and finally let's take a look and put
the centroids on there
again we're going to do a scatter plot
and on the centroids you can just pull
that from our k-means the model we
created
dot cluster centers
and we're going to just do
all of them in the first number and all
of them and the second number which is 0
1 because you always start with 0 and 1.
and then they were playing with the size
and everything to make it look good
we'll do a size of 300 we're going to
make the color yellow and we'll label
them it's always good to have some good
labels centroids
and then we do want to do a title plt
title
and pop up there
plt title cause you always want to make
your graphs look pretty and we'll call
it clusters of car make
and one of the features of the
plot library is you can add a
legend it'll automatically bring in it
since we've already labeled the
different aspects of the legend with
toyota nissan and honda
and finally we want to go ahead and show
so we can actually see it and remember
it's in line so if you're using a
different editor that's not the jupiter
notebook you'll get a pop-up of this
and you should have a nice set of
clusters here so we can look at this and
we have a clusters of honda and green
toyota and red
nissan and purple and you can see where
they put the centroids to separate them
now when we're looking at this we can
also plot a lot of other different data
on here as far because we only looked at
the first two columns this is just
column one and two or zero one as you
label them in computer scripting but you
can see here we have nice clusters of
car make and we were able to pull out
the data and you can see how just these
two columns form very distinct clusters
of data
so if you were exploring new data you
might take a look and say well what
makes these different
almost going in reverse you start
looking at the data and pulling apart
the columns to find out
why is the first group set up the way it
is maybe you're doing loans and you want
to go well why is this group not
defaulting on their loans and why is the
last group defaulting on their loans and
why is the middle group 50 defaulting on
their
bank loans and you start finding ways to
manipulate the data and pull out the
answers you want
so now that you've seen how to use
k-mean for clustering
let's move on to the next topic
now let's look into logistic regression
the logistic regression algorithm is the
simplest classification algorithm used
for binary or multi-classification
problems and we can see we have our
little girl from canada who's into
horror books is back that's actually
really scary when you think about that
with those big eyes in the previous
tutorial we learned about linear
regression dependent and independent
variables so to brush up y equals mx
plus c
very basic algebraic function of
y and x the dependent variable is the
target class variable we are going to
predict
the independent variables x1 all the way
up to xn are the features or attributes
we're going to use to predict the target
class
we know what a linear regression looks
like but using the graph we cannot
divide the outcome into categories
it's really hard to categorize 1.5 3.6
9.8
for example a linear regression graph
can tell us that with increase in number
of hours studied the marks of a student
will increase but it will not tell us
whether the student will pass or not in
such cases where we need the output as
categorical value we will use logistic
regression and for that we're going to
use the sigmoid function so you can see
here we have our marks 0 to 100 number
of hours studied that's going to be what
they're comparing it to in this example
and we usually form a line that says y
equals mx plus c and when we use the
sigmoid function we have p equals 1 over
1 plus e to the minus y
it generates a sigmoid curve and so you
can see right here when you take the ln
which is the natural logarithm i always
thought it should be nl not ln that's
just the inverse of
e your e to the minus y and so we do
this we get ln of p over 1 minus p
equals m times x plus c that's the
sigmoid curve function we're looking for
and we can zoom in on the function and
you'll see that the function as it
derives goes to one or to zero depending
on what your x value is and the
probability if it's greater than 0.5 the
value is automatically rounded off to 1
indicating that the student will pass so
if they're doing a certain amount of
studying they will probably pass then
you have a threshold value at the 0.5 it
automatically puts that right in the
middle usually and your probability if
it's less than 0.5 the value rendered
off to zero indicating the student will
fail so if they're not studying very
hard they're probably going to fail this
of course is ignoring the outliers or
that one student is just a natural
genius and doesn't need any studying to
memorize everything that's not me
unfortunately i have to study hard to
learn new stuff
problem statement to classify whether a
tumor is malignant or benign and this is
actually one of my favorite data sets to
play with because it has so many
features and when you look at them you
really are hard to understand you can't
just look at them and know the answer so
it gives you a chance to kind of dive
into what data looks like when you
aren't able to understand the specific
domain of the data but i also want you
to remind you that in the domain of
medicine if i told you that my
probability
was really good it classified things
that say 90 or 95
and i'm classifying whether you're going
to have a malignant or a b9 tumor i'm
guessing that you're going to go get it
tested anyways so you got to remember
the domain we're working with so why
would you want to do that if you know
you're just going to go get a biopsy
because you know it's that serious this
is like an all or nothing just
referencing the domain it's important it
might help the doctor know where to look
just by understanding what kind of tumor
it is so it might help them or aid them
and something they missed from before so
let's go ahead and dive into the code
and i'll come back to the domain part of
it in just a minute so use case and
we're going to do our normal imports
here we're importing numpy
pandas seaborn the matplot library and
we're going to do matplot library in
line since i'm going to switch over to
anaconda so let's go ahead and flip over
there and get this started
so i've opened up a new window in my
anaconda jupiter notebook
and by the way jupiter notebook you
don't have to use anaconda for the
jupiter notebook i just love the
interface and all the tools and anaconda
brings so we got our import numpy as in
p
for our numpy number array we have our
pandas pd we're going to bring in
seaborn to help us with our graphs as
sns
so many really nice tools in both
seaborne and matplot library and we'll
do our
matplotlibrary.pyplot as plt and then of
course we want to let it know to do it
in line and let's go and just run that
so it's all set up
and we're just going to call our data
data
not creative today
equals pd and this happens to be in a
csv file
so we'll use the pd.read underscore csv
and i happened to name the file i
renamed it
dataforp2.csv you can of course write in
the comments below the youtube and
request for the dataset itself or go to
the simplylearn website and we'll be
happy to supply that for
you and let's just open up the data
before we go any further and let's just
see what it looks like in a spreadsheet
so when i pop it open in a local
spreadsheet this is just a csv file
comma separated variables we have an id
so i guess the
categorize this for reference or what id
which test was done the diagnosis m for
malignant b for b9 so there's two
different options on there and that's
what we're going to try to predict is
the m and b and test it and then we have
like the radius
mean or average the texture average
perimeter mean area mean smoothness i
don't know about you but unless you're a
doctor in the field most of stuff i mean
you can guess what concave means just by
the term concave but i really wouldn't
know what that means in the measurements
they're taking so they have all kinds of
stuff like how smooth it is
the symmetry and these are all float
values we just page through them real
quick and you'll see there's i believe
36 if i remember correctly in this one
so there's a lot of different values
they take and all these measurements
they take when they go in there and they
take a look at the different growth the
tumorous growth
so back in our data and i put this in
the same folder as a code so i saved
this code in that folder obviously if
you have it in a different location you
want to put the full path in there and
we'll just do
pandas
first five lines of data with the data
dot head
when we run that we can see that we have
pretty much what we just looked at we
have an id we have a diagnosis
if we go all the way across you'll see
all the different columns coming across
displayed nicely
for our data
and while we're exploring the data our
seaborn which we referenced as sns
makes it very easy to go in here and do
a joint plot you'll notice that
very similar to because it is sitting on
top of the plot library so the joint
plot does a lot of work for us and we're
just going to look at the first two
columns that we're interested in the
radius mean and the texture mean we'll
just look at those two columns and data
equals data so that tells it which two
columns we're plotting and that we're
going to use the data that we pulled in
let's just run that
and it generates a really nice graph on
here
and there's all kinds of cool things on
this graph to look at i mean we have the
texture mean and the radius mean
obviously the axes you can also see
and one of the cool things on here is
you can also see the histogram they show
that for the radius mean whereas the
most commons radius mean come up and
where the most common texture is so
we're looking at the tech the
on each growth its average texture and
on each radius its average
radius on there gets a little confusing
because we're talking about the
individual objects
average and then we can also look over
here and see the histogram showing us
the median or how common each
measurement is
and that's only two columns so let's dig
a little deeper into seabourn they also
have a heat map and if you're not
familiar with heat maps a heat map just
means it's in color that's all that
means heat map i guess the original ones
were plotting heat density on something
and so ever since then it's just called
a heat map and we're going to take our
data and get our corresponding numbers
to put that into the heat map and that's
simply data dot c-o-r-r
for that that's a pandas expression
let's remember we're working in a pandas
data frame so that's one of the cool
tools in pandas for our data and this is
pull that information into a heat map
and see what that looks like
and you'll see that we're now looking at
all the different features we have our
id we have our texture we have our area
our compactness concave points
and if you look down the middle of this
chart diagonal going from the upper left
to bottom right
it's all white that's because when you
compare texture to texture they're
identical so they're a hundred percent
or in this case a perfect one in their
correspondence
and you'll see that when you look at say
area or right below it it has almost a
black on there when you compare it to
texture so these have almost no
corresponding data they don't really
form a linear graph or something that
you can look at and say how connected
they are they're very scattered data
this is really just a really nice graph
to get a quick look at your data doesn't
so much change what you do but it
changes verifying so when you get an
answer or something like that or you
start looking at some of these
individual pieces you might go hey that
doesn't match according to showing our
heat map this should not correlate with
each other and if it is you're going to
have to start asking well why what's
going on what else is coming in there
but it does show some really cool
information on here and we can see from
the id
there's no real one feature that just
says if you go across the top line that
lights up there's no one feature that
says hey if the area is a certain size
then it's going to be b9 or malignant it
says there's some that sort of add up
and that's a big hint in the data that
we're trying to id this whether it's
malignant or b9 that's a big hint to us
as data scientists to go okay
we can't solve this with any one feature
it's going to be something that includes
all the features or many of the
different features to come up with the
solution for it and while we're
exploring the data let's explore one
more area and let's look at data dot is
null we want to check for null values in
our data if you remember from earlier in
this tutorial we did it a little
differently where we added stuff up and
summed them up you can actually with
pandas do it really quickly data.is null
and summit and it's going to go across
all the columns so when i run this
you're going to see all the columns come
up with no null data
so we've just just to re hash these last
few steps
we've done a lot of exploration we have
looked at the first two columns
and seeing how they plot with the
seaborn with a joint plot which shows
both the histogram
and the data plotted on the x y
coordinates
and obviously you can do that more in
detail
with different columns and see how they
plot together and then we took and did
the seaborne heat map the sns
dot heat map of the data and you can see
right here where it did a nice job
showing us some bright spots where stuff
correlates with each other and forms a
very nice combination or points of
scattering points and you can also see
areas that don't
and then finally we went ahead and
checked the data is the data null value
do we have any missing data in there
very important step because it'll crash
later on
if you forget to do this step it will
remind you when you get that nice error
code that says no values okay
so not a big deal if you miss it but
it's no fun having to go back when
you're you're in a huge process and
you've missed this step and now you're
10 steps later and you got to remember
where you were pulling the data in
so we need to go ahead and pull out our
x
and our y let me just put that down here
and we'll set the x equal to
and there's a lot of different options
here certainly we could do x equals all
the columns except for the first two
because if you remember the first two is
the id and the diagnosis so that
certainly would be an option
but we're going to do is we're actually
going to focus on the worst the worst
radius the worst texture parameter area
smoothness compactness and so on one of
the reasons to start dividing your data
up when you're looking at this
information
is
sometimes the data will be the same data
coming in so if i have two measurements
coming in to my model it might overweigh
them it might overpower the other
measurements because it's measuring it's
basically taking that information in
twice
that's a little bit past the scope of
this tutorial i want you to take away
from this though is that we are dividing
the data up into pieces and our team in
the back went ahead and said hey let's
just look at the worst so i'm going to
create a an array and you'll see this
array radius worst texture worse
perimeter worst we've just taken the
worst of the worst and i'm just going to
put that in my x so this x is still a
pandas data frame but it's just those
columns and our y if you remember
correctly
is going to be oops hold on one second
it's not x it's data there we go so x
equals data and then it's a list of the
different columns the worst of the worst
and if we're going to take that then we
have to have our answer for our y for
the stuff we know
and if you remember correctly we're just
going to be looking at
the diagnosis that's all we care about
is what is it diagnosed is it b9 or
malignant
and since it's a single column we can
just do diagnosis oh i forgot to put the
brackets or the there we go okay so it's
just diagnosis on there and we can also
real quickly do like x dot head if you
want to see what that looks like
and y dot head
and run this
and you'll see um it only does the last
one i forgot about that if you don't do
print you can see that the the y dot
head is just mmm because the first ones
are all malignant and if i run this the
x dot head is just the first five values
of radius worse texture worse parameter
worst area worst and so on
i'll go ahead and take that out
so moving down
to the next step we've built our two
data sets our answer and then the
features we want to look at
in data science it's very important to
test your model
so we do that by splitting the data
and from sklearn model selection we're
going to import train test split so
we're going to split it into two groups
there are so many ways to do this i
noticed in one of the more modern ways
to actually split it into three groups
and then you model each group and test
it against the other groups so you have
all kinds and there's reasons for that
which is past the scope of this and for
this particular example isn't necessary
for this we're just going to split it
into two groups one to train our data
and one to test our data and the
sklearn
dot model selection we have train test
split you could write your own quick
code to do this we just randomly divide
the data up into two groups but they do
it for us nicely
and we actually can almost we can
actually do it in one statement with
this where we're going to generate four
variables
capital x train capital x test so we
have our training data we're going to
use to fit the model and then we need
something to test it and then we have
our y train so we're going to train the
answer and then we have our test so this
is the stuff we want to see how good it
did on our model
and we'll go ahead and take our train
test split that we just imported and
we're going to do x and our y our two
different data that's going in for our
split
and then the guys in the back came up
and wanted us to go ahead and use a test
size equals 0.3 that's test underscore
size random state it's always nice to
kind of switch a random state around but
not that important
what this means is that the test size is
we're going to take 30 percent of the
data and we're going to put that into
our test variables our y test and our x
test and we're going to do 70 into the x
train and the y train so we're going to
use 70 of the data to train our model
and 30 to test it
let's go ahead and run that and load
those up
so now we have all our stuff split up
and all our data ready to go and now we
get to the actual logistics part we're
actually going to do our create our
model
so let's go ahead and bring that in from
sklearn we're going to bring in our
linear model and we're going to import
logistic regression that's the actual
model we're using and this we'll call it
log model
stereo model and let's just set this
equal to our logistic regression that we
just imported
so now we have a variable log model set
to that class for us to use
and with most the
models in the sk learn we just need to
go ahead and fix it fit do a fit on
there and we use our x train that we
separated out with our y
train and let's go ahead and run this so
once we've run this we'll have a model
that fits this data that 70 percent of
our training data
and of course it prints this out that
tells us all the different variables
that you can set on there there's a lot
of different choices you can make but
for word though we're just going to let
all the defaults sit we don't really
need to mess with those on this
particular example there's nothing in
here that really stands out as super
important until you start
fine tuning it but for what we're doing
the basics will work just fine and then
let's we need to go ahead and test out
our model is it working so let's create
a variable y predict and this is going
to be equal to
our log model
and we want to do a predict again very
standard format for the sklearn library
is taking your model and doing a predict
on it and we're going to test why
predict against the y test so we want to
know what the model thinks it's going to
be that's what our y predict is and with
that we want the capital x x
test
so we have our train set and our test
set and now we're going to do our y
predict and let's go ahead and run that
and if we print
y
predict
let me go ahead and run that
you'll see it comes up and it presents
and i prints a nice array of
b and m for b9 and malignant
for all the different test data we put
in there
so it does pretty good we're not sure
exactly how good it does but we can see
that it actually works and is functional
was very easy to create you'll always
discover with our data science that as
you explore this
you spend a significant amount of time
prepping your data
and making sure your data coming in is
good
there's a saying
good data in good answers out bad data
in
bad answers out that's only half the
thing that's only half of it
selecting your models becomes the next
part as far as how good your models are
and then of course fine-tuning it
depending on what model you're using so
we come in here we want to know how good
this came out so we have our y predict
here log model dot predict x test
so for deciding how good our model is
we're going to go from the
sklearn.metrics we're going to import
classification report and that just
reports how good our model is doing and
then we're going to feed it the model
data let's just print this out
and we'll take our classification report
and we're going to put into there
our test our actual
data so this is what we actually know is
true
and our prediction what our model
predicted for that data on the test side
and let's run that and see what that
does
so we pull that up you'll see that we
have
a precision for b9 and malignant b and m
and we have a precision of 93 and 91 a
total of 92 so it's kind of the average
between these two 92
there's all kinds of different
information on here your f1 score
your recall your support coming through
on this and for this i'll go ahead and
just flip back to our slides that they
put together for describing it and so
here we're going to look at the
precision using the classification
report and you see this is the same
printout i had up above some of the
numbers might be different because it
does randomly pick out which data we're
using so this model is able to predict
the type of tumor with 91 percent
accuracy
so we look back here let's you'll see
where we have b9 and it actually is 92
coming up here but we're looking about a
92 91 precision and remember i reminded
you about domains and we're talking
about the domain of a medical domain
with a very catastrophic outcome you
know at 91 or 92 percent precision
you're still going to go in there and
have somebody do a biopsy on it very
different than if you're investing money
and there's a 92 percent chance you're
going to earn 10 percent and 8 chance
you're going to lose 8
you're probably going to bet the money
because at that odds it's pretty good
that you'll make some money and in the
long run you do that enough you
definitely will make money and also with
this domain i've actually seen them use
this to identify different forms of
cancer that's one of the things that
they're starting to use these models for
because then it helps the doctor know
what to investigate so that wraps up
this section we're finally we're going
to go in there and let's discuss the
answer to the quiz asked in machine
learning tutorial part 1.
can you tell what's happening in the
following cases grouping documents into
different categories based on the topic
and content of each document this is an
example of clustering where k-means
clustering can be used to group the
documents by topics using bag of words
approach so if you've gotten in there
that you're looking for clustering and
hopefully you had at least one or two
examples like k-means that are used for
clustering different things then give
yourself a two thumbs up
b identifying handwritten digits and
images correctly this is an example of
classification the traditional approach
to solving this would be to extract
digit dependent features like curvature
of different digits etc and then use a
classifier like svm to distinguish
between images
again if you got the fact that it's a
classification example give yourself a
thumb up and if you're able to go hey
let's use svm or another model for this
give yourself those two thumbs up on it
c behavior of a website indicating that
the site is not working as designed this
is an example of anomaly detection in
this case the algorithm learns what is
normal and what is not normal usually by
observing the logs of the website give
yourself a thumbs up if you got that one
and just for a bonus can you think of
another example of anomaly detection one
of the ones i use it for my own business
is detecting anomalies in stock markets
stock markets are very fickled and they
behave very radical so finding those
erratic areas and then finding ways to
track down why they're erratic was
something released in social media was
something released you can see where
knowing where that anomaly is can help
you to figure out what the answer is to
it in another area d predicting salary
of an individual based on his or her
years of experience this is an example
of regression this problem can be
mathematically defined as a function
between independent years of experience
and dependent variables salary of an
individual and if you guessed that this
was a regression model give yourself a
thumbs up and if you were able to
remember that it was between independent
and dependent variables and that terms
give yourself two thumbs up machine
learning has improved our lives in a
number of wonderful ways today let's
talk about some of these i'm rahul from
simply learn and these are the top 10
applications of machine learning first
let's talk about virtual personal
assistants google assistant alexa
cortana
and siri now we've all used one of these
at least at some point in our lives now
these help improve our lives in a great
number of ways for example you could
tell them to call someone you could tell
them to play some music you could tell
them to even schedule an appointment so
how do these things actually work first
they record whatever you're saying send
it over to a server which is usually in
a cloud decode it with the help of
machine learning and neural networks and
then provide you with an output so if
you ever notice that these systems don't
work very well without the internet
that's because the server couldn't be
contacted next let's talk about traffic
predictions now say i wanted to travel
from buckingham palace to large cricket
ground the first thing i would probably
do is to get on google maps so
search it
and let's put it here
so here we have the path you should take
to get to large cricket ground now here
the map is a combination of red yellow
and blue but the blue regions signify a
clear road that is you won't encounter
traffic there the yellow indicate that
they're slightly congested and red means
they're heavily congested so let's look
at the map a different version of the
same map and here as i told you before
red means heavily congested yellow means
slow moving and blue means clear
so how exactly is google able to tell
you that the traffic is clear slow
moving or heavily congested so this is
the help of machine learning and with
the help of two important measures first
is the average time that's taken on
specific days at specific times on that
route the second one is the real-time
location data of vehicles from google
maps and with the help of sensors some
of the other popular map services are
bing maps maps dot me and here we go
next up we have social media
personalization so say i want to buy a
drone and i'm on amazon and i want to
buy a dji mavic pro the thing is it's
close to one lap so i don't want to buy
it right now but the next time i'm on
facebook i'll see an advertisement for
the product next time i'm on youtube
i'll see an advertisement even on
instagram i see an advertisement so here
with the help of machine learning google
has understood that i'm interested in
this particular product hence it's
targeting me with these advertisements
this is also with the help of machine
learning let's talk about email spam
filtering now this is a spam that's in
my inbox now how does gmail know what
spam and what's not spam so gmail has an
entire collection of emails which have
already been labeled as spam or not spam
so after analyzing this data gmail is
able to find some characteristics like
the word lottery or winner from then on
any new email that comes to your inbox
goes through a few spam filters to
decide whether it's spam or not now some
of the popular spam filters that gmail
uses is content filters header filters
general blacklist filters and so on next
we have online fraud detection now there
are several ways that online fraud can
take place for example there's identity
theft where they steal your identity
fake accounts where these accounts only
last for how long the transaction takes
place and stop existing after that and
man in the middle attacks where they
steal your money while the transaction
is taking place the feed forward neural
network helps determine whether a
transaction is genuine or fraudulent so
what happens with feed forward neural
networks are that the outputs are
converted into hash values and these
values become the inputs for the next
round so for every real transaction that
takes place there's a specific pattern a
fraudulent transaction would stand out
because of the significant changes that
it would cause with the hash values
stock market trading machine learning is
used extensively when it comes to stock
market trading now you have stock market
indices like nikai they use long short
term memory neural networks now these
are used to classify process and predict
data when there are time lags of unknown
size and duration now this is used to
predict stock market trends assistive
medical technology now medical
technology has been innovated with the
help of machine learning diagnosing
diseases has been easier from which we
can create 3d models that can predict
where exactly there are lesions in the
brain it works just as well for brain
tumors and ischemic stroke lesions they
can also be used in fetal imaging and
cardiac analysis now some of the medical
fields that machine learning will help
assist in is disease identification
personalized treatment drug discovery
clinical research and radiology and
finally we have automatic translation
now say you're a foreign country and you
see billboards and signs that you don't
understand that's where automatic
translation comes of help now how does
automatic translation actually work the
technology behind it is the same as the
sequence of sequence learning which is
the same thing that's used with chat
bots here the image recognition happens
using convolutional neural networks and
the text is identified using optical
character recognition furthermore the
sequence to sequence algorithm is also
used to translate the text from one
language to the other welcome to deep
learning in python deep learning is a
subfield of machine learning that deals
with algorithms inspired by the
structure and function of the brain and
you can see we have a nice picture here
we have artificial intelligence which is
kind of the big bubble that encompasses
all these different things we're talking
about this is ability of machine to
imitate intelligent human behavior and
in there we have machine learning
application of ai that allows a system
to automatically learn and improve from
experience and if you looked at any of
our other videos you'll know that
machine learning covers a lot so deep
learning is a subcategory of that but
don't forget machine learning has all
kinds of other tools that people use to
do very basic uh descriptive and
predictive and postscriptive analytics
and then you have deep learning
application of machine learning that
uses complex algorithms and deep neural
nets to train a model let's take a look
at the biological neuron versus the
artificial neuron now remember in the
human brain and this is true for most
animals there are a lot of different
neurons going on so this is a very basic
one i mean there's hundreds of different
cells involved so when we talk about
neural networks this is why it says in a
very infant stage they're really basing
it on just the most basic thing that
we're able to figure out going on in the
neural networks and you can see right
here we have dendrites fetch information
from an adjacent neurons and pass them
on as inputs so you have your data
coming in and your data going out any
computer model should be looking at that
what's coming in what's going out the
data is fed as an input to the neurons
when we look at the artificial neuron
you can see we have our inputs they come
in each one is specially weighted into
the neuron and then the neuron has an
output the cell nucleus processes the
information received from the dendrites
and the neuron processes the information
provided as inputs axons are the cables
over which the information is
transmitted and the information is
transferred over weighted channels so
you can look at that i mentioned weights
briefly but you alter the data coming in
so those weights are what causes
different information coming in to be
weighted differently and processed
differently and the synapses receive the
information from the axons and transmit
it to the adjacent neurons that's in
your biological model and then when we
look at the artificial neuron the output
is a final value predicted by the
artificial neuron so as we dig deeper
into looking at the theory behind the
neural network and we kind of flip back
and forth between these because there's
two huge aspects of it one is from the
outside what are you seeing and what's
going on from the inside so you can find
to do what you need to do and give the
best results you can we start off with
what do we feed we feed an unlabeled
image to a machine which identifies it
without any human intervention and so
you can see here we have a circle that
comes in at 784 pixels and it comes in
by 28 by 28 and you can see how it
colors in the the circle on there and we
put a triangle in the triangle in also
comes in as 28 by 28 and it has 784
pixels so you'll see between these two
both of them are
784 pixels this machine is intelligent
enough to differentiate between the
various shapes so that's what we want to
use our neural network to do is to say
hey this is a circle this is a triangle
that's more of a categorical you can
also do a regression model where you're
actually putting out a float value or a
numerical value we'll be looking at the
true false or the categorical model
mostly that's where you usually start at
the different there is no real
difference when you as far as the way
the internal functioning goes when you
start flipping between them other than
well we'll talk about that in just a
minute so you can actually go between
the two quite easily and the neural
network provides this capability so
we're going to use this capability to
look between those two one of the things
i want you to note in here is that we're
looking at 784 pixels we're looking at
784 inputs that's very different than
stock with a high low or last year's
cells based on date we're looking at
just a couple of numbers and they're
very clear they're numbers they're very
clear what they are which is something
you put into a machine learning linear
regression model this is a step up from
that in that we're looking at complex
patterns and how do you figure those
complex patterns out so a neural network
is a system modeled on the human brain
and we looked at that comparing the two
let's go ahead and look deeper into the
neural network itself we have our inputs
coming in so the inputs are fed to a
neuron that processes the data and gives
us an output input and output this is
the most basic structure of a neural
network known as a perceptron so if you
see the term perceptron that's what
we're talking about we're talking about
this single node that has inputs and an
output however neural networks are
usually much more complex let's start
with visualizing a neural network as a
black box and i always love that symbol
it's a black box it's kind of magical we
have our inputs coming in and we want
certain outputs the box takes inputs
processes them and gives an output let's
have a look at what happens within this
box and you can see me there in my
secret agent get up i got my hidden hood
and everything i guess i'm part of the
black skull or something like that group
uh so let's take a look at what happens
within this magic box and remember we're
skipping back and forth between the
theory what's going on in the box which
you have to know how to fine tune and
how to build versus looking at it from
the outside we're programming this box
and we have an input and an output to
the box as a whole within the box exists
a network that is a core of deep
learning and you can see here we're
showing one layer and we have our grid
coming in the network consists of layers
of neurons each neuron is associated
with a number called the bias and you
can think of the bias if you overly
simplify this and we're doing a linear
regression model this is your
y-intercept in your euclidean geometry
you have to have something that offsets
it and so you always have a bias in
these cells neurons of each layer
transmit information to neurons of the
next layer over channels and so you can
see each of our layers going through
from left to right these channels are
associated with numbers called weights
these weights along with the biases
determine the information that is passed
over from the neuron to neuron so just
like the bias is your y-intercept in
euclidean geometry you could look at the
net one weight remember this is very
complicated so we're not looking at just
one weight you can look at the weight as
your slope of the line or if you're
doing x equals
m y plus c it would be the m value
neurons of each layer transmit
information to neurons to the next layer
and you can see here as they light up
going across into the final layer and
then to the output and in this case the
output is going to be either a square
and this one or it might light up the
other one which is a circle the output
layer emits a predicted output so in
this case we're looking at a
classification a true false is it a
circle is it a triangle is it a square
let's now go deeper what happens within
the neuron so we're going to dig deeper
and start getting a little bit closer to
some of the math don't worry you don't
have to be a calculus expert or know
your differential equations even though
this is one giant differential equation
you don't need to understand those to
understand what's going on within each
neuron the following operations are
performed the product of each input and
the weight of the channel it's passed
over is found this is simply addition
we're going to sum up the weight times
the output from the previous channel and
plus the bias some of the weighted
products is computed this is called the
weighted sum bias unique to the neuron
is added to the weighted sum the final
sum is then subjected to the particular
function and we'll discuss those that
particular function that part is really
important because those functions have a
huge impact on how well your model
performs under different conditions the
final sum is then subjected to a
particular function this is the
activation function so if you ever hear
the term activation function that's what
we're talking about what activates this
cell and what doesn't as we dig deeper
into activation function an activation
function takes the weighted sum of the
input as its input adds a bias and
provides an output and a lot of times
you'll actually see one formula for the
sum of the weight the weighted sum and
the bias you'll just see that as a
single line of everything added together
in here we've broken it apart because it
makes it clear that this bias is not
computed the same as the weighted sums
here are the most popular types of
activation function and i always find
these interesting because at one point i
was sitting at a table with a gentleman
who was finishing his phd he was in his
last year and he said he went through
all this stuff and he ended up just
trying the four different activation
functions on this particular problem he
was working on so knowing the math
behind it doesn't necessarily mean
you're going to know it right away so
even somebody might have a phd and be
doing the calculations on this comes
back out of it and ends up just trying
the different
activation functions to see what's going
to make a difference a lot of times
that's a final step that's the kind of
thing where you built your whole model
you've come back and you're like wait a
minute can i do a better deal with the
sigmoid function or the threshold or the
rectifier knowing what they're doing is
important so you can explain it to
somebody else and again you probably do
this on a small set of data if you're
working with big data you don't want to
take down the full server farm just to
test out your three different series you
take a small portion of that data test
it and then you put it through to the
big data so let's take a look at this we
have the sigmoid function and it's used
for models where we have to predict the
probability as an output it exists
between 0 and 1. and you'll see that's
true of all of our activation functions
we're working with either the cells on
or off it's true or false and there
might be a little variation in there
which as an output could be used to
compute uncertainty in your solution so
if you're getting a 0.7 with this
activation function it might be well i'm
not sure if that's really a square i'm
not sure it's really a triangle and that
might be a flag for it to be looked at
by a human observer at least in today's
models where we're at right now and you
can see here where we have the formula
simply equals 1 over 1 plus e to the
minus x where x is your value coming in
and it's going to give you a result that
looks very similar to the graph on there
which is somewhere between 0 and 1.
and right in the middle you can see that
there's a huge
kind of you can go through all the
different values and uncertainties
involved so the sigmoid function is
probably the default on most of them uh
the next one is the threshold function
it is a threshold base activation
function if x value is greater than a
certain value the function is activated
and fired else not pretty
straightforward yes no true false i
don't want to test for improbabilities i
just want a straight answer i don't want
to know if there's a partial value on
there it either is true or it's false
and the rectifier function it is the
most widely used activation function i
would debate that
rectifier is pretty common one although
i see the the sigmoid function is used
to be the basic one but it's up there
the rectifier function is very commonly
used because the output of x if x is
positive and zero otherwise and you can
see here again just like um uh it's
either kind of get a value going up
there so max of x of zero so it's it's
again it's like the threshold function
yes no true false uh it's either zero or
it's uh some kind of progressive value
and then we have the rectifier function
i would argue with this because the
sigmoid function used to be the most
common one but with the rectifier
function it now says it is the most
commonly used or widely used activation
function and gives an output of x if x
is positive and 0 otherwise this is kind
of nice because it now says absolutely
not or it gives you a value of
probability now when i say a value of
probability be very careful there i'm
not saying that it's going to tell you
this is 75 chance of being a circle i'm
going to tell you that it says hey if
this says 0.1 it probably needs to be
looked at or 0.2 or 0.3 it's going to
depend on your data as to what that
value means in general that just means
it's flagging it that if it's not a 1
then chances are it needs to be looked
at by a person and reevaluated and
there's a hyperbolic tangent function
this function is similar to sigmoid
function is bound to a range of minus
one to one so you can see there's our
one minus e to the minus two x and one
plus over one plus e to the minus two x
again it's very similar to the sigmoid
function the bonus of the hyperbolic
function is you have that variable
coming through the middle so again you
can look at it and you have a little bit
more weight as far as you can process
that down the line that's a little bit
more advanced than what we're looking at
right now and a lot of times it's not
even necessary in a lot of our different
uses for these activation functions now
we looked at activation functions and i
kind of said those are a little bit like
a black box because even if you know all
the math a lot of times you end up just
playing with them to find out what works
and it also depends on what model you're
working with whether you need a flat yes
no true false or you need to have
something in the middle that says hey
this isn't quite a one you might need to
process this with the human intervention
and you can look at that one example
would be self-driving cars you don't
want a car to be yes no i'm going to go
through the the light you want it to be
like okay if it's uh almost yes maybe we
stop and have human intervention so we
don't get an accident cost function is
something you can really see and measure
and is very important the cost value is
the difference between the neural net's
predicted output and the actual output
from a set of labeled training data so
we have our group of data that's a
square circle and since we're looking at
geometrical shapes we've had somebody
already labeled that data they've
already said this is a triangle this is
a square and so if this is coming up and
it's giving us and saying a square is a
triangle and it's saying a triangle is a
circle the output is wrong and so that
output can then be measured in the
versus the actual output and that's the
cost uh you might also hear this as
error because that's the error value
being returned how far off is it and
what we're looking for is the least cost
or the least error value and it's
obtained by making adjustments to the
weights and biases iteratively
throughout the training process and this
this is called back propagation and
we're going to look in that a little
deeper as we look into an example it's
really hard to see when you're just
looking at arrows without actual numbers
and where that flow is coming from but
you can look at this is here's our
inputs they put out a prediction the
prediction comes out and says hey we've
already labeled this data because we're
in training mode and the training data
is off this is the cost can we send that
error or that cost back and adjust those
weights and we do it in very small
increments across large amounts of data
so that those weights minimize that cost
or that error but what happens within
these neurons so let's look at a little
example of this kind of helps if you
have some kind of visual let's build a
neural network that predicts bike prices
based on a few of its features and we'll
see here we have our cc our mileage and
our abs and these are our three input
layers and then we have the bike price
and the output layer now it doesn't do
us very good to just pump it in from the
beginning and pump it out and to be
honest i would use a machine learning
linear regression model on this since
these are just straight numbers but
because we want a simple example we're
going to put this through and show you
as a neural network what that looks like
and we can put a hidden layer in there
the hidden layer helps in improving the
output accuracy and you could look at
this as a bunch of ores so it might say
hey when we compare these three values
on the first hidden layer neuron we're
looking at one set of features and then
we might weigh them in the second one so
these are a bunch of different ores kind
of how the math comes out and behind the
scenes and then they go out of course to
the bike place or the output layer and
each of the connections have a weight
assigned with it and you'll see here we
have a mileage cc with the weight 1 and
weight 2 going into our first neuron and
you'd also have your abs going in there
and so x1 times weight 1 plus x2 times
weight 2 plus the bias of 1. and step 2
is our activation the activation
function coming in there when does this
fire and the neuron takes a subset of
the inputs and processes it and then we
go through we do that with the second
hidden layer neuron and the third one
and so on so you process each layer in
order going forward now when i told you
this is in its infant stage they now
have neurons that fire into the same
layer or back a layer so that you now
have a time series and there's all kinds
of wild things that they're
experimenting with on these layers this
basic setup has been around since the
mid 90s it's only now because of our
technology that it's open to almost
everybody to play with it and that's why
i see this isn't an infant stage in
development is this basic math is here
but what we can do with it is amazing
and what they're actually doing with all
these different things is amazing and so
we're just at the beginning of how to
use all these different tools in our
deep learning in our neural networks and
so once we have our hidden layer
computed the information reaching the
neurons in the hidden layer is subjected
to the respective activation function
and so each one of these fires an
activation output
and then those are each weighted to the
final output layer so the processed
information is now sent to the output
layer once again over weighted channels
and you could look at this as each one
of these is i always look at this as
like a group of people they're all
looking at the bulletin board and the
first person says this is what i project
sells for the company the second person
and the third and so on and then their
perspectives are weighted based on their
expertise so your accountant might have
a very high weight where the
maybe your janitor has a very low weight
because their expertise is not in
accounting and then that goes into the
output layer and once in the output
layer it goes the output which is the
predicted value is compared against the
original value so now we have our output
layer and since we have like already a
list of bikes with their the different
setups and what their value is we can
now generate an error from this the cost
function determines the error in
prediction and reports it back to the
neural network so this is the cost this
is how far off it is this is your error
coming back and as you can see this is a
back propagation going on so now our
error is going in reverse because we
know we're not completely correct on
this particular channel the weights are
adjusted in order to reduce the error so
each time we go back we are changing
those weights to reduce that error and
we change them in small increments you
don't want to fit one input remember you
might have a data pool with a terabyte
of data you don't want to solve for the
first set of data that comes in and that
be the main solution because everything
else will be off this is going to
confuse you that's also called the bias
so we have the bias in the cell where
we're adding a value the kind of like
the y-intercept and we have a bias of
the whole neural network which means it
is weighted towards one set of answers
so we want to make small changes in
these weights so we don't create a bias
and the weights are adjusted in order to
reduce the error or the cost the network
is now trained using the new weights
once again the cost is determined and
back propagation is continued until the
cost cannot be reduced any further so
let's go ahead and plug in values and
see how our neural network works so here
we come in here and initially our
channels are assigned with random
weights this is important because if you
assign them all with the same weight you
might be able to reproduce it but it
turns out that if i put all my weights
as one or all my weights is zero it
takes longer to train where if you have
random weights they already have like a
little bit of adjustment and ors built
in and that will give us a better answer
and train faster our first neuron takes
a value of mileage and cc as inputs so
here comes our computation whatever
those inputs are and we do that again
with the second neuron with those values
coming in you can see here we have
weight three and so on and then our
third neuron coming down and of course
our fourth neuron so we're adding all
these different values coming in here in
our hidden layer the process value from
each neuron is sent to the output layer
over weighted channels so again here's
our weights coming in and we have n1 n2
n3 and n4 once again the values are
subjected to the activation function and
a single value is emitted as the output
on comparing the predicted value to the
actual value we clearly see that our
network requires training so here we
have it that our bike price
we put out we thought it was worth 2 000
on our random weights and the bike
actually was 4 000 on there guessing
that's not us dollars because that'd be
a very expensive bike but maybe it is
there's some two thousand four thousand
dollar bikes out there the cost function
is calculated and back propagation takes
place this is pretty simple you can look
at that as our we're subtracting one
value from the other we square it and
then we take half of that and that is
propagated back up and each layer
generates its own errors let's go back
one because you have your predicted y
and your actual y that goes back to the
first layer and then based on the value
of the cost function certain weights are
changed so when we look at the next
layer that error is not the original
4000 minus 2000 square divided by two
this error is based on the error of each
cell generated how far off is that cell
as far as its weights we're not going to
show you it's actually a very
complicated differential equation and
you can probably write it out if you
wanted to you just write out each
formula that goes into the next level
and you add them all together and you
can write it out all the way through
computers make it so you don't have to
and our neural network is considered
trained when the value for the cost
function is minimum so when we get our
error way down as low as we can that's
when our neural network is trained and
there i mean just recently they've come
up with all kinds of different means for
measuring that particular value a little
bit beyond the scope of today's neural
network but you can actually you can
actually see it you know how far do you
do this until the neural network doesn't
need to be trained anymore and you can
over train a neural network now the
tools that we're looking at
automatically let you know when to stop
which is really nice and that is just
like i said we're at the beginning
stages in neural networks it's just
really cool what they can do now and how
much of it's automated and how much of
it is experimental right now let's take
a look at gradient descent but what
approach do we take to minimize the cost
function so here we have a nice error
thing coming in this is our cost or our
error let's start with plotting the cost
function against the predicted value and
so you can see they fit in multiple y's
and these are the errors coming in and
the cost of each of these inputs and
changes going on note we start at a
random point on the curve so usually you
put in you know you pick up your data
and you randomly pick where to start in
your data a lot of times you just run it
from the beginning because you're going
through so much data is not that big of
a deal but you start with one point
going in so your forward propagation
goes through you're going to go ahead
and find your cost or your error it
points out on the curve and you can see
how we're plotting it right here since
the gradient at this point is positive
we may move right so we're going to move
a little bit to the right on here and
this time the gradient is negative we
move a little bit to the left eventually
we try out the point where the gradient
is zero this is the least value of cost
function you have to be a little careful
with this because this particular i mean
they make it look nice and simple in
this graph sometimes these curves look
like stair steps and so there is global
minimums and then there is local there
might be a local point where the
gradient is zero but it's not the global
one so it might be way off to the left
where it just happens to step down a
little bit and you think you're in the
right gradient and with that we have all
the right weights and we can say our
network is trained so here we have um
just some major these are some of the
big names out there right now in
development for deep learning platforms
tensorflow which we'll actually do an
example in a minute deep learning for j
which is in the java platform so if
you're a java programmer by the way
tensorflow is accessed most people are
using python to access it but it is a
system that's kind of separate from a
lot of the programming languages which
makes it a lot more flexible as far as
used deep learning 4j is java based and
then cross is just exploding right now
and this is interesting cross is working
with tensorflow it actually can sit on
top of tensorflow and it can also do its
own thing so if you're studying deep
learning you're getting into it you'll
want to know the basics of tensorflow
but you also are going to want to know
the upper level of cross sitting on top
of tensorflow we're just looking at
tensorflow today though in our example
and there's also torch on there there's
a bunch more that we didn't list on here
even sklearn or the side package in
python has a neural network you can
program a very basic one and it is the
same basic one that you could do in
tensorflow if you stripped everything
out of it and then tensorflow has a lot
of tools they've added in and so has
cross but we're going to be looking
specifically at tensorflow in our
example and tensorflow is an open source
tool used to define and run computations
on what they call tensors very common
language now so more and more we see the
term tensor as being a standard in the
deep learning language and this was
originally developed by google so let's
take a little bit in there what are
tensors tensors are just another name
for arrays so a tensor of dimension five
you can see here we have a b k m q
whatever so it's an array coming in and
the tensor of dimension five four more
like a picture very common to see that
in the picture you can also see a tensor
even more detailed in the picture as we
go to the next one tensor dimension
three three 333 this is 3d space you
might have a picture that also has
colors that might be the third dimension
you might have four dimensions because
you have both your grid and your
different color channels and your z plot
you can see where you can now process a
very high level sort of data coming in
whether as an image or features they
could be features that have nothing to
do with images so there's a lot of stuff
you can do now with the tensors coming
in this is where the term tensorflow
comes from so we have right now that
tensorflow is the most popular library
in deep learning and i did mention cross
now works with tensorflow so there's a
lot of stuff you can do between the two
it's an open source software library
developed by google so they hit a
roadblock and they realized hey this is
an infant stage technology you know we
thought it was going to be the next
greatest thing and we were going to have
a hold on it but it's really infant as
far as how it's applied and what we can
do with it let's open source it so
everybody can work on it let's take it
to the next level and that's really what
open source does to a lot of these
packages when they release them and you
can run on either a cpu or a gpu so when
we look at the details if you have your
graphic processing units what's nice
about those is they run a lot faster the
downside is you have to play with them a
little bit to get them up and running
and it's a hardware upgrade when we run
it i'll be running it in the cpu mode i
have played with it my gpu on my
personal computer you know it does
increase the processing but i did run
into some version problems with my
python and stuff like that and when i
did finally work it out i went back to
the cpu because it didn't increase my
speed enough for what i was working on
but in a larger group you might be able
to put that on if you're working with a
larger stack of computers you might want
to run it in the gpu you can create a
data flow graphs that have nodes and
edges so there's our edges coming in we
didn't talk about edges but it's very
up-and-coming way of looking at your
analytical data is how do different
nodes connect what do those edges look
like in between them and it's used for
machine learning applications such as
neural networks it is mostly a neural
network but they have all kinds of tools
which sit on top of our basic neural
network they have new stuff evolving
into the tensorflow library so it's very
much just exploding great time to jump
into tensorflow there's all kinds of
cool things you're doing with it and all
kinds of cool applications you can now
use tensorflow for so let's take a look
at implementation in tensorflow and
we're going to build a neural network to
identify handwritten digits using the
mnist database or the mnist database and
that stands for modified national
institute of standards and technology
database it is a collection of seventy
thousand handwritten digits and the
digit labels identify each of the digits
from zero to nine this is a cool example
because it's simple enough that you
could actually run this through some
basic machine learning categorizing
algorithms and train them and you'll get
about the same answer because again it's
simple grid the digits on the grid don't
have a huge amount of variation like you
would say an automated driving car
looking at the environment so you can
still do this with a lot of your
different linear models and stuff like
that you can solve this and you'll get
about the same answer when i ran a
comparison between tensorflow and
between some basic uh regression models
or category models in machine learning
they came up pretty even as far as their
output
so this is kind of where we start to see
the complexity of something coming in in
this case a tensor you know or a grid of
information where the deep learning
model does as good as the regular models
and when you get past this kind of
complexity and features suddenly the
neural networks come up with better
answers better solutions and a better
build and that's why there's such a move
into neural networks is we live in a
complicated world and it's just really
cool we can do with this so the
handwritten digits from the nist
database they come in the data set is
used to train the machine a new image of
a digit is fed and the digit is
identified and if you've looked at any
of our other machine learning tools
where we're doing training where we
train our model to fit and then you test
it out this will look pretty familiar
and there is some tools out there for
say untrained categorizing uh where it's
just looking for features that fit
together so there are tools that don't
need that training but this is where we
talk about neural networks we do need to
train them and this is what we're
looking at
so for this i'm going to use the
anaconda navigator just because it's a
very nice visual tool you might be in
pycharm or one of your other ides for
editing python because we are looking at
python tensorflow and under anaconda we
have the notebook which is something we
use pretty regularly and they have the
jupiter lab the jupiter lab is the
jupiter notebook but with tabs and a few
new features so we'll be using the
jupiter lab today and under the
environment you'll want to go ahead and
and if you haven't yet you'll see that i
have a number of different setups in
here right now i have the python version
three six and the tensorflow in this
case i have tensorflow 1.12 if we scroll
down you can see that here we go
tensorflow and it's version 1.12 and in
here if you haven't yet you'll need to
install those and go in and just open
our terminal and if you've never used
the anaconda or if you're in your other
thing you might have something simple
like pip conda is what i use for my
install and you can simply do conda
install tensorflow that should bring in
the most current version now when i
installed this a few months ago python
version i'm not going to run this
because i already have installed on here
python version 3.7 the newest one out
still had a couple glitches with the
tensorflow i believe they fixed it as of
writing of this but um i'm going to
stick with 3 6 just so i don't get any
surprises on there so this is python
version 3.6 with tensorflow 1.12 on here
and if you haven't installed it yet you
also want to install numpy for this
example that's numbers python or
numpy
you just simply run install on there
keep in mind if you're in anaconda and
you've created one of these environments
specific to this keep with conda if
you're going to use conda if you're
going to use pip keep with pip don't
install one package with pip and one
under conda because that's how they
track those version numbers and how they
fit together and you can end up with a
problem they don't pip doesn't see conda
and vice versa so just keep that in mind
when you're running your installs we'll
go ahead and open up jupiter lab we're
going to launch that so here's my
jupiter lab one of the really cool
features of jupiter lab is you have tabs
now so you can open up multiple uh
notebooks this is nice because i have my
notes i'm working on and then our actual
window we're looking in and we'll go
ahead and zoom in a little bit here
there we go so you have a nice
hopefully easy to see fonts and then
we'll go ahead and do a simple or get
our imports out of the way and so we're
going to import our tensorflow as tf
that's pretty much a standard for
tensorflow numpy our number is python as
py and we'll import our matte plot
library as plt again these are very
common so if you see tf or py or plt
this is a standard that most people use
do you have to no you could just do
import numpy instead of doing as py and
then from tensorflow.exe
this is always nice because they
actually include data set we're going to
play with so we're going to import input
data so there's our data coming in
that's all we're doing is telling it
this is where it's coming from and if we
can tell where it's coming from we need
to go ahead and create a variable with
that information in it and we'll just
call this uh mnist nist or minst you
know i don't really know how they
pronounce that i should probably look
that up it's a very common data set to
use and there's our input data and we're
going to read data sets and this is if
you look at this we imported input data
from our tensorflow and so this is a
tensorflow read statement for their
tutorials so this isn't like some
special python setup this is just their
setup makes it easy to pull it in so
once we get into their data sets we need
to go and tell what kind of data set and
again this is what we brought in but
it's going to be the ninth data and this
part is very important one hot equals
true this means that instead of
importing a value from zero to nine we
evaluate the data set it's going to
bring it in as one hot whenever you see
one hot encoder we're flattening that
out and we have true false for zero true
false for one true false for two so our
output if you remember from our output
uh from the slide we did earlier uh in
this case i grabbed the one for bike
price doesn't really matter which one we
use this has one output so we have our
bike price on this we're going to have
instead of one output we're going to
have 10 outputs representing each of the
digits in there and this code really
isn't going to show us anything it's
good to see what we're actually looking
at so let's go ahead and do a figure ax
equals go into our plot library subplots
10 comma 10. and that is if you remember
we talked about tensor tensor being data
coming in this is a 10 by 10 grid or 100
pixels on there and if we're going to
display it uh let's go do k
0 for i in range 10 just a simple loop
through on the data let's do what is it
for j in range 10. so i actually
misquoted that 10 uh 10 by 10 is not the
actual size of the pixels uh the actual
pixels are going to be um we look at the
shapes and we'll get to that in just a
second here we'll take a quick look at
the shape on there uh turns out they're
what are they are
i believe 28 by 28. uh so let's take a
look at that and we're just going to
plot these what are we looking at what
are we working with as a data scientist
you should always be looking back at
your data and seeing what it looks like
and get that human perspective
because you just never know you know the
the computer might put something out
that looks makes no sense and at that
point you want to go back and reevaluate
what you did uh so we're going to go
ahead and plot we're going to plot 10
digits you know 10 of the digits by 10
of the digits and here's our ax we'll
create the ij on our subplots and we're
going to do an image show we're going to
look at the training image for images of
k
and then we want to reshape this we're
going to reshape this and we're going to
reshape this 28 by 28. that's how i knew
i had it wrong is because i looked down
my notes it's like oh no that says 28
it's not 10 by 10. and i should know
that already because i've done enough
messing with this data set that i should
remember but it's 28 by 28 and the
aspect we're going to do is auto and
this is all if you look at this here's
our variable nist the nist is coming
from data set so this is all part of the
tf tensorflow learning or examples
tutorial in there and then we'll go
ahead and do k
plus equals one so we just keep paging
through our different images and let's
see what that looks like let's go ahead
and do a plot
show and we'll go ahead and run this so
we take a look and see what we have here
and so we have a nice plot here and you
can just see that we have uh some random
numbers showing up in each one of these
little subplots
if you're wanting a copy of this code
put a note down in the youtube video and
let us know or come visit us at
www.simplylearn.com and we'll send you
out a copy of what we're working on and
get a copy of that for your own setup so
now we've taken a look we can just see
we have here's our pictures that are
coming on we plotted them so we have an
idea of what we're looking at let's go
ahead and print let's look at the shape
of the features uh so when we have this
we have our nist train images and we'll
do the shape on there let's take a look
and just see what we're looking at
as far as uh our count and everything
and so you can see here we have 55 000
that's basically how many images we have
and this by 784 and in this data set
there's also our labels so let's take a
look at that we have our next train
labels shape let's take a look and see
what that looks like uh and there we
have 10 because there's 10 digits so we
brought in that's our output we're
looking at and so we have there we go 55
000 they match they should match because
you should have equal numbers in both of
those you know here's our data in and
here's our answer if you remember this
is a bunch of zeros and with one each
each one will be zero zero zero one
would be what letter four or something
like that so let's take a look at what
our one hot encoding did for the first
observation and this is when we're
exploring data you really want to dig in
there and just see what the heck am i
looking at so we're gonna look at the
labels and this would be the first label
that comes up and we'll go ahead and run
this and we look at that you can see
this is what i'm talking about zero zero
our one is zero two is zero three is
zero four zero five is zero six is zero
seven equals one so our very first label
is a seven but a very first label comes
up that it's a seven and so we don't
have like zero through nine we have a
bunch of zeros and just the one to mark
it as a seven on here so now we've kind
of looked a quick look at the data and
in here you might ask some questions
like what is 784 24 times 24. remember
that's the size of our grid on there or
our tents are coming in so 784 is a
setup on there and we've gone through
all this viewing the data we'll go ahead
and start looking at our tensorflow so
let's take our x variable this is going
to be our training set we'll do a
placeholder and then we're going to have
these come in as float now if i remember
correctly they're actually you know 0 or
1 for the values because they're either
but we have them coming in as a float
value and we have a little bit of a
shape coming in here and there's our 784
uh so we let it know that this is what's
what our input is for our tensorflow and
this is our training set so we'll just
put a label on there to help us track
that train set and then w and with w
we'll go ahead and do tf variables and
we'll do this as
zeros variables to have zeros and we'll
set this as
784 by 10 10 being the output 784 being
our number of variables in and this is
our weights remember we have a bias in
there too and i'll go back over this in
just a second as we see how that fits
together in our tensorflow and we'll do
this one with our variables again we
have 10 so we're going to do the bias we
do it the same kind of format and setup
on here and so we'll do that as as tf 0s
of 10. so just create an array of 10
there and this is our bias so with these
three lines
and there's actually they're coming out
with the eager execution which would
bypass some of what we're doing but this
is important to understand is the first
thing you have to do with tensorflow is
we have to allocate a space for the
variables in our tf placeholder and our
tf variable with our weights and our
biases this actually hasn't done
anything yet so all it is is
placeholders that's why it's okay to use
zeros you could have just as easily used
ones or anything else and it wouldn't
matter the next stage is to go ahead and
set up some of the functions going on
but before we do that just note that
this hasn't done anything even if i
execute it all it's done is created
placeholders until we do the final
initialization
keep track of what's going on we're
finding weighted sum of inputs plus the
bias uh so there's our plus b the bias
and then we need to go ahead keep them
let's do y underscore and again another
placeholder and this one will set it's
actually we'll put in as tf placeholder
on here tf placeholder float nun 10
there's our one hot encoder going on
there so our 10 values coming out and
we'll do a cross
entropy on here and this is going to be
minus tf reduce
sum and we'll do y here's our y
underscore which is remember we have
your y output and your actual output uh
so this will be our y underscore times
the t f log of y and then finally um
before we do the actual initialization
of all our variables we'll set up our
train step this equals our gradient
descent optimizer very important
remember we looked at that chart on our
slides and so we've set up all these
formulas and here's our gradient descent
optimizer and as it keeps looking it
keeps looking for that zero value that's
what we're doing with that particular
formula so let's take a look and see
what we're doing here we just put
together all of our pieces for
tensorflow
and you know the devil's in the details
we have here our training set coming in
we have to put a placeholder on there we
have our
variables with our weights we have our
biases coming out and then we put in our
the weighted sum so here's uh summizing
our summation here then we have our y
variable output so there's our y um how
it works and then of course the actual
output on there and then we have our
cross entropy coming in and that's our
minus tf dot reduced sum the y times the
tf log of y and then the training step
gradient descent optimizer and we're
using a 0.01 in this and we're going to
minimize cross entropy so we're going to
let it do all the work so once we've set
up all of these different layers we've
allocated for them we need to go ahead
and initialize them so we're going to do
an init tf initialize and it's going to
be all variables one of the cool things
is they're in the process of doing away
with this so all these steps would be
bundled into one instead of having to
add placeholders you initialize them in
the same process going on and then
finally everything in tensorflow is
based on your session now this is
changing that there's other options to
be able to run this but we want to go
ahead and do a session there's our tf
which is a tf session and then we want
to go ahead and do session run and what
are we going to run well we did
initialization of all our variables so
this is what we're running and this is
we're actually once we do this we
actually create our tensorflow object so
this whole piece of code right here is
our tensorflow object we have our input
coming in with our weighted variables
coming in our soft max for our metamol
going out how does it added together for
our y value and then we have the actual
float value coming out checking on our
all the way down so you can see all the
different stages going through that
we're setting up and this is one of the
reasons that a lot of people like
tensorflow is because you can designate
all these different pieces one step at a
time this is also one of the reasons
people don't like tensorflow is because
you have to designate all the different
layers coming down and there's a lot of
steps being made right now to minimize
this to make it either easier to
automate it or to allow you to do more
complicated things and all those steps
are still at play so it's worth looking
into the more advanced version and
what's going on with cross on top of
tensorflow it's also important to
understand what's going on in these
individual levels if you're going to
play with them it's important to
understand hey what's going on with the
finding the weighted sum of the inputs
plus the bias because there's other ways
to do that there's all kinds of other
tools in there now but this is the basic
setup that you want to do on a
tensorflow coming in and we want to go
ahead and just run and init our
tensorflow so let's go ahead and do that
let's run this we do get a warning here
because there's a move to use global
variables this is one of the changes
they're making but as far as this
example is not going to make a
difference because we're doing once we
initialize it this is initializing our
variables and again these are only
placeholders up here until we initialize
them and i would highly suggest put a
note down there or go over to
simplylearn.com and let them know and
have them email you a copy of the code
so you can actually play with this code
right here because this is the body of
what's going on in tensorflow this is
the build in neural networks and then
once we've done that now comes kind of
the fun part is we need to go ahead and
train it so we've created our tensorflow
we've created our network and now we
need to go ahead and train it uh so
let's put together that training code
and let's just do for i and range
1000 zero to one thousand so we're just
going to look at the first 1000 in our
training and the way we pull that data
from our mints train next batch of 100
so you look at this we're going to be
doing groups of 100 and then there's
going to go through a thousand of them
this is very important that tensorflow
builds this in this is one of the
downsides of doing sklearn or one of the
older packages is they don't let you
batch groups in they want to have it all
up front and then you have to build your
own batch programs right now this lets
us go ahead and do that and you can see
here we have batch x of s batch y of s
so there's our x and our y you can look
at this as our training of x and our
train of y or the data in and the answer
in uh and then we simply do our session
run uh so here's our session that we've
created we're going to run it and we
want to do the train step where we
initialized our train step up here in
our tf and so there's our train step
feed it's a dictionary dictionary coming
in which we're going to create right
here is x is our batch x of our sample
comma and our y underscore is going to
be our batch of our y sample uh and so
this goes through and we've now hit the
run button and we've trained our session
we've trained this setup on here and
once we've trained it then we need to go
ahead and find out how good our accuracy
was and actually start running some
predictions through there so we'll go
ahead and create a correct prediction
when this is where our tf.equal we'll
use our arg max y of one and t f argmax
of y of underscore of one to help us get
the correct predictions on there and we
wanna use that to feed into an accuracy
and so our accuracy is going to be tf
reduce
mean and we'll take that we'll do a cast
and this is the correct prediction that
we're sending in there and it is a
float value keep it simple and let's go
ahead and print this out so we can see
what we're looking at so what are we
printing out uh we need to do a session
run this session runs going to be on the
accuracy what accuracy comes from this
is our we're casting our tf on there
with the correct predictions on that so
here's our accuracy feed in so it needs
a dictionary for the data coming in
we're going to create our dictionary and
x is going to be our nist test images
and y underscore there is going to be
our nist dot test
labels let me just double check and make
sure i have that typed in there
correctly there we go and let's go ahead
and run that and see what comes up and
we end up with a
0.9165 for our accuracy which means our
trained neural network does a pretty
good job letting us know what these
different symbols are i'm guessing that
a seven and a three and a four uh
something that as humans we kind of take
for granted i even have trouble reading
this so i don't know if i would be able
like that first one i would sit there
for a long time figuring out that's a
seven versus a two that could have
easily been a two to me so you can see
we do a pretty good job analyzing this
data and this is used to analyze
something very complicated on these
images very different than just a
straight value of cost of cells and
here's our return and our marketing we
can now create this nice neural network
that does all kinds of cool things now
we've covered a number of really cool
things here in our simply learn
hopefully you've had a chance to explore
you'll have a chance to get in there and
dig into tensorflow and all the upcoming
cool things connected to tensorflow what
we'll do is we'll go ahead and dig into
use case imitation with tensorflow to do
that i'm actually going to go into
in this case of you using the anaconda
navigator and you can use either jupiter
lab or jupiter notebook most people are
very familiar with jupiter notebook it's
very commonly web-based the jupiter lab
is the next version of jupiter notebook
and it just lets you have multiple tabs
open when you're working on it and if
you're using anaconda you'll go under
environments and you want to make sure
that you have your tensorflow installed
and you can simply we'll do this i have
it installed uh but you could do all the
do all you can do a search and draw for
tensor and you can see all the different
tensors it's actually installed in here
version 1.1 3.1 if it wasn't you could
check the box and then run the install
on there and bring it right in but we'll
go and start up our jupiter lab which is
going to open up in this case i use
google chrome and in our jupyter lab or
jupiter notebook if you're in the
notebook you only have one tab and you
won't have the added options like
there's a folder and different things
you can do in the lab that you can't do
in the notebook but everything we're
going to do you can easily do in the
notebook and you'll start up a new
project deep learning is what i'm going
to call this and if you're not familiar
you can definitely we have some
tutorials out on the use of jupyter
notebook and how to run it and set it up
and things like that the most basic is
we put our code in here it has a nice
display a nice interface especially for
data science i can display all kinds of
things on this page and then you can
just run this page right here there's no
code in it so it's not going to show any
thing until i put some code in there and
of course you can cut your cells and
things like that so the first thing we
want to do is we want to import our
tools now if you haven't remember you
gotta install tensorflow and we'll also
use pandas pandas is a nice database
setup and that again is underneath your
environment and you can see here your
whatever you're working on my simply
learn setup where i've installed
tensorflow and pandas in here and i'll
simply go up here and run this not going
to see anything so we've just imported
those into our notebook that we're
working on so those are now available to
us and it helps to have some data to
work with and we have here going to
create a path and a test path and
we'll go ahead and let's just highlight
this whole path and you can always post
a note either down below in the youtube
video or you can post a note on
simplylearn.com and ask for this path if
you're not quite picking it up but it is
over here at the uci edu on their setup
and it's in their archive so it's
archive.ics.uci.edu
forward slash ml for machine learning
slash machine dash learning dash
databases slash adult that's quite a
mouthful and in this case we have adult
data and adult test well let's go and
just take a look at that let me just
paste that right in there to our browser
window and here's our adult data and if
i click on there it's going to come down
as a download i'm going to go ahead and
open it as a text my notepad um and the
guys in the back were kind enough to
look up to find out what the actual
columns were in this uh coming across so
let me do and take that to pull that
information it doesn't matter whether i
put it before or below because these are
just variables
but we can see here that we have age
work class final wgt i'm guessing that's
final we'll look that up in just a
second see what that matches in fact
let's pull that up and just put them
next to each other so we can kind of see
we got here so we have age we have our
working class state gov maybe final wage
77 5 16 education of bachelors education
number 13 marital never married admin
clerical relationship not in family so
on and so on so it goes all the way
across here so we've pulled out this
information native country label etc
we'll go ahead and run this and so now
we've loaded all our different uh paths
and this path by the way this is the
same columns on here so i don't need to
create a separate columns on the adult
test and once we've run this we've set
those variables let's go ahead and pull
that data in and to do that we'll use
pandas and we'll create a df train a df
test each one is going to have our pd
for pandas dot read csv they'll have our
path we put in there our path test the
first one went ahead and skip initial
space true names columns there's our
columns in there index column equals
false there's no index column on the
second one if we went back into here and
we open up adult test let me just go
ahead and open that up pat you'll see
there's an actual row up here we want to
skip a 1 by 3 cross validator with all
the same data in it so we're looking at
the same data in there and here we're
going to go ahead and bring in our data
and then once you bring it in it's
always nice to see what kind of shape
your data is in and of course when we
talk about shape we're talking about how
many rows and columns not whether it's
been lifting weights we can see here we
have each one has 15 columns and that
goes with our columns right here if we
counted them there's going to be 15. and
the first data set has 32
rows where the second one has 16 281
rows and it's also good to see just how
the data came in so we'll use the
pandas
d types we'll run that and you can see
here where age came in as an integer
integer 64. working class has an object
which makes sense
and then we have our
fnlwgt the education as objects or well
this is an integer integer object so on
all the way down and if we flash back to
the data we look at the last column it's
less than or equal to 50k and if we
scroll down enough we'll see it's also
greater than or equal to 50k so we'd
like to kind of give that its own
special setup on that label so on that
feature we're going to set the label
equal to
if it's less than or equal to 50k it's
going to be zero and if it's greater
than or equal to 50k it's going to be
one so it's one or the other that's
always an easy easy thing to read and
then we can take this and we go
dftrain.label equals label item for item
and df train label and this just loops
through all the labels there's a lot of
ways we can do this pandas this might be
actually kind of a slower way there's a
way to do just that setup and do the
logic within the
setup instead of doing a loop but for
this this thing it'll work fine we're
not dealing with a lot of data you know
it's a large data set but it's not that
big of a data set as data goes and we
also want to do it for our test data i
didn't really mention that we created
two date we're looking at two different
data sets one we're going to train the
data and then we're going to take it and
run the test data to see if it works so
we have our two different data sets and
we didn't catch it off the bat if you
were pulling up this you're going to
pull up one the this is the training set
and if we go back in here and open up
the test set let me just go back and do
that adult test one of the things that
we didn't notice that you'll want to
pull up is at the end there's a period
so we're pre-processing our data we want
to make sure that we include that period
in every line on the second set up so i
go back to my jupiter notebook i've got
to have a label t which is less than or
equal to 50k period or greater than
equal to 50k period for one otherwise
it's doing the exact same thing we're
going to change the df train label and
the df test label to zero or one we'll
just run that we'll go ahead and print
uh the dftrain label dot value counts
and the df test label value counts this
is always a good idea because we want to
know is there any weird stuff going on
there if there's no value stuff like
that this will turn up on that setup and
we can see here we have zeros how many
zeros how many ones and so on on there
just a quick view of the data that we're
going through and if we go back up here
go ahead and print the train d types
again and we run that you could actually
run it up there and give you the new
answer because it's loaded this
information uh we now see it's an
integer and if you go back up here it
was an object so that makes life a
little easier as far as what we're doing
with this now at this point we're going
to look at the data and we can see we
have a lot of numbers and we have a lot
of categories in here
so categories would be
united states male never married versus
seven and we can also see that when we
looked at this we have our integers we
have our objects working class so the
next thing we want to do on there is we
want to go ahead and take that where we
have integers and the objects and we
want to bring that down here we want to
create those categories in a way that
the computer can see them and we'll
start with our continuous features like
age we can see age integer fnl wgt is an
integer capital gain is an integer
educational number there's our
educational numbers in integer and so on
so if we're going to have these as
continuous features where they're an
integer we also need to make a list of
the categorical features we want to work
with such as working class education
marital occupation relationship race sex
and native country and again these are
all objects uh so that makes sense and
when we flip back over to the data we
can see here we're actually looking at
united states if we continue down see if
i can find another one a lot of united
states on this particular one i was
getting worried there for a second that
we only had united states and it was a
very biased uh census which it probably
is for wherever it came from and of
course bachelor's associate vocational
some college so you can see this is more
categorical versus an actual number
so now we have our categorical and we
have our continuous features and this is
just the list of these so let's go ahead
and run that and load that list in there
so we can now start manipulating our
data with it now we get our first line
of
flow code which is exciting and we're
going to create a variable continuous
features and what we're doing in here is
we're going to go into tf
feature columns so we have the feature
columns we're going to set those up
numeric columns k for k in continual
features so this is going to go in here
and says each one of these is a
continual feature and we're going to
feed that into the feature column not
very exciting on the output because
we're just creating this variable here
letting it know what columns are what
then we're going to create a
relationship uh setup so we have
continuous features and then we have a
relationship and again we're doing tf
but in this case we use feature column
uh so just like this one we're telling
it feature column and now we do
categorical column width vocabulary list
so that's one of the things we can do
with tensorflow and we're going to feed
it one we have uh relationship and so
we're just drilling down to the
relationship column and these are the
options they had so this is going to be
the vocabulary attached to this column
and we'll go ahead and run that so we
load up our relationship and then we're
going to do one more uh way of loading
uh in this one we're going to do
categorical features and so in
categorical features we're going to do
tf feature column here's our command
we've already seen before it's going to
be categorical column with hash bucket
we're going to create buckets in this
case for k and categorical features so
it's going to create a bucket for each
one of these uh categorical features and
the bucket size is 1 000. so we're
looking at and we've actually kind of
repeated something because relationship
is also in the bucket setup on there but
we want to show you three major ways of
loading in your different features one
is our features that we know where it's
going to be a number uh so our
continuous features then we can set it
as a relationship in this case we
actually created a vocabulary husband
not and family very clear vocabulary on
there and then we also are loading just
general categories into buckets you can
set different bucket settings in here we
went ahead and just went with a thousand
so pretty much everything since there's
not a huge number of categories each one
gets their own kind of bucket setup in
there and as far as the initial setup we
need to go ahead and create a model so
this is where it starts to come together
we've as far as the pre-setup we have
our tf we have an estimator we're going
to do linear classifier on the estimator
in classes equals two so we know there's
only two classes we're looking at we
have ongoing train feature columns and
then we have our different we have a
categorical features plus continuous
features so this basically creates our
model what data is going in and we'll go
ahead and run this and you can see here
that it gives us a little information uh
that we had our tensorflow using default
config you can change a lot of defaults
you can change as far as the model
directory random seed saving summary
checkpoints there's all kinds of things
you can go in here and set up rewrite
options keep checkpoint mix etc at this
point the model hasn't done anything all
we've done is create the model so let's
just do a real quick rehash of what
we've done so far what we started off
with is we grabbed some data in this
case uh an adult an adult test we have a
training data set and a test data set
we set the columns up we took a very
short brief exploration of the data in
its shape as far as what we're working
with we changed our label around a
little bit so that the label makes a
little bit more sense of zero one
instead of for the machine it's easier
to spit out a zero or a one we can look
up here we double check to make sure we
how many zeros and ones we have double
check our data make sure it's integer
64. nothing weird's going on and then we
look to three different ways that we can
kind of label the data as far as the way
we're going to read it we have our
continuous features and a categorical
features here's our relationship which
is one of them we went ahead and created
our model we did not put the
relationship in here which you can do
you can actually maybe take it out of
categorical and then have its own on
here instead of having categorical
features and continuous features and so
on so we've created our setup for our
model the next thing we need to do is we
need to go ahead and create a function
letting it know how to read the data
into our model how are we going to train
it and let's go ahead and create two
variables the first one is going to be
features this is just all the features
that are in there and then the second
one is going to be our label and this is
basically we're looking at all the
different information we can put into it
and then is that person based on that
information going to make less than or
greater than 50k that's what that comes
down to now the next part the definition
we're going to create has a lot in it
and we're going to feed this definition
into our model training so there's a lot
of stuff that goes on here first we'll
call it get input and function def get
input function we have our data set
number of epochs equals none in batch
equals 128 shuffle equals true so we're
running this and it's going to return a
tf estimator inputs pandas input
function and in this case it's going to
be x equals our pd data frame k data set
k values for k in features y is pd
series data set label values batch size
equals n batch number of epochs equals
number of epochs shuffle equals shuffle
so in here we're passing in the number
of epochs we're not too worried about
we're going to just go once through the
data because there's a lot of data in
there we don't need to rerun it epics is
how many times do you cover all the data
and then how many groups of data do you
pull in and batch at a time so we're
only going to look at 128 do the reverse
propagation like we talked about uh and
then it'll go to the next batch and the
next batch and the next batch and it
shuffles them so shuffle means that
we're randomly picking where they're
coming from uh like again we're only
doing we're not too worried about the
number of epics for this particular
model depending on how much data you
have and depending what you're running
depends on how many epics you need to
run and there's a lot of rules on how
many epics you need to run one of them
is if you're
training data and you're testing data
because you'll check your testing data
against your training data if your
testing data starts having a better
results in your training data that means
you're no longer fitting towards the
data but you're fitting to the answer so
it's kind of these little weird things
you start to on here and tensorflow is
really cool because it actually checks a
lot of that for you but we're just gonna
set number of epics equal to zero and
then we have our data set going in so
we're creating our get function how do
we get the data into training our model
and we'll go ahead and run that so now
we have our data function and now it
knows where the data is coming from uh
so we need to go ahead and train it and
that simply would take our model we
created way up here that's where we take
the model there we've told it what
columns is going to pull in so it knows
what columns it's looking at know what
the definition was going to get the
information from so now we want to go
ahead and train it and here's our input
function equals in this case get input
function and here we tell it that our
data set is a df train number of epochs
equals none which is already
automatically set up there in batch
equals 128 which is what we have up here
shuffle equals false and we're going to
do 1000 steps so we're actually going to
go through
128 batches but we're going to do that a
thousand times and we'll go ahead and
run this and i just ran an update so
it's going to give me some warnings
because of that update and then we're
back here and it's still going to
construct pipelines use tf data module
not a big problem we let it go ahead and
run all the way through one here and it
takes it just a moment there we go
there's our thousand coming out as you
can see here here's a
checkpoints for one thousand ongoing
training a thousand and one global steps
and this is just all the reverse
propagation going on that's what we're
doing here uh one of the things we
didn't cover is we do it in small
increments so it's not all done like one
error goes all the way back you'd only
do a part of that error and each one
sends back a little piece and so you
slowly adjust your different weights
going all the way back and then if
you're going to train your model we want
to know how it did so we're going to do
model evaluate and our input function
equals remember our input function up
here that we created way up here we're
going to take this input function and
instead of the data set that's coming in
we put in the data set here for training
where's our training input train there
we go df underscore train
now we're going to go ahead and evaluate
and here it is a git input function test
so we're going to test the data out
number of epochs one we don't need to
rerun it more than once per batch 128
so on shuffle and steps a thousand so
we're going to go ahead and evaluate
this let's just see how good our test
data did uh how good our model was
programmed on our training data and how
it evaluates on the test we can see it
going on down here where it's got the
evaluating graph was finalized let me
just highlight that ongoing model
checkpoint tensorflow running local init
uh evaluate 100 out of a thousand and so
on and once it gets to the end we get a
nice uh output here we have an accuracy
in this case of 0.79
with a baseline of 0.76 so now we've
created a model uh let's go ahead and
tweak it a little bit so we have our
accuracy up here what we're going to do
is we're going to look at age and let's
just go ahead and create a new square
value for age and the reason we want to
look into the square value of age is we
know that if you really look through the
data you'll find that as a young person
the age keeps increasing as you get
close to retirement it begins to
decrease so we square the value of age
and that's very data specific when we're
looking at data you'll find that any
kind of data that has that kind of like
uptick and downtick by squaring it or
square rooting it you can get some very
different results and so we're going to
go and square our age and this is kind
of it's interesting because at this
point even at the beginning of this
we're focused on deep learning and on
tensorflow but before i would begin even
looking at any of this i would have
probably run some kind of heat map or
some kind of evaluation in r or sk learn
in python to find out the correlation
between different features to see just
how well they correlate to each other
and there certainly are some wonderful
tools for that because sometimes you can
just mark off some features and other
features you bring in but for the deep
learning we can see how we can just dump
it all in there and let it sort it out
itself and we're going to just write a
quick little function here to take the
square variable in this case we have dft
dfte this is our training and your test
variable and the variable age coming in
and we just want to go ahead and create
a new under dft and the new is going to
be the variable name whatever we put in
there which will be age so let's load
this here's our functions now loaded and
certainly we could have just done that
as a line of code but you start to get
the feeling that when you build these
functions you might use it you can now
use this function if you had a number of
different features that had this kind of
quality to them and we have our df train
new so we're going to create a new
training and a new test and it's going
to equal the square variable dftrain or
dftest and the variable name is age
let's just go ahead and run that so now
we have our new our df train new and df
test new and just like we did before
let's just double check the shape of our
data and make sure it all matches and
when we look at the output here really
what's important is that each one of
these has 16 features in it we want to
make sure we're not getting something
weird on there and our training set has
561 rows in it and this one has just
over 16 000 in there and everything's
pretty much the same except that in our
continuous features new we now have the
new column we put in there so we need to
change that and we have our continuous
features new down here which we're going
to load up with our tf feature column
numerical this would all look familiar
because we just did this and so we're
going to load that up with the new being
the new value in there let's go ahead
and run that and we'll create a model
that we'll call it model one and this is
the same that we did before except now
we have our continuous features new in
here so here's our new model in this
case model one instead of model and
we're going to build that model right
there now we haven't trained it all
we've done is told it where to get the
data and how to get the data and what
features are coming in we haven't
actually told it everything on the
features coming in because we still need
to also build our full our get input
function so where's the input coming
from so we built the model with the
features in it and now we need to go
ahead and create our git input function
this is the same as before but you'll
see
we now have it with the data set coming
in is going to be the same data set up
here and so if we scroll a little bit to
the right we should see the new and
there it is sure enough there's our new
on the right and so let's go ahead and
run that now we've defined our model we
defined where the information is coming
from and again you can go back and
review the first part because this is
identical that we did before except now
we have new as the column for the age
and we'll go ahead and do our model one
and let's go ahead and train it there's
our input function git input function
that we defined up here dftrain is going
to be the same and everything else is
going to be the same let's go ahead and
run that and it should go through here
and run the tensor info coming in and
it's going to go through in this case we
have steps 1000 shuffling so it's going
to go randomly 128 per batch
and then the epics is automatic we're
not worried about that today so now we
have a trained tensorflow model and with
our new model just like we did before we
want to go ahead and evaluate it so it's
the same setup we had before with our
same git input function with our df test
new in here coming in so there's our new
data coming in and this is really common
when you're doing these models you make
little tiny tweaks to see if you can
improve it one of the best articles i
read recently was you build your model
to fail you want a running model so that
you actually have something to compare
against and then you continually tweak
it till you get a better accuracy now i
don't expect the accuracy necessarily to
get better on this
because of the way we partition the data
we can see here we now have an accuracy
of 0.76 which is a little bit over the
baseline and it's about what i would
have expected it to be kind of the same
the reason is because we split the data
at the 50 the people making over 50k and
those making less and so the age factor
shouldn't be a huge factor it would be
if we were looking at more discrete
buckets like 40 to 50 50 to 60 60 to 70
when we create buckets but in this i
didn't really expect it to go up that
much in fact we could probably run it a
dozen times which would be very bad data
science and we see we actually had a
slightly better one up here but our
baseline accuracy was 0.76 and we come
down here we still see uh here's our
accuracy baseline 0.763 that didn't
really change and you know the accuracy
didn't really go up that much i could
hit the run button a few times i would
probably upbeat the one above so not a
big change but that's all right that's
how we learned is how we go through and
figure out what's going to work with our
data and what's not what's going to
improve the quality of our data so we
have a better prediction and what's not
and we can now go ahead and utilize this
model this is where it gets exciting
when you're actually working with
somebody or with your clients and you
come in and say okay here's my
predictions we're going to take a create
a list and we're going to use model 1
and we're going to predict and our input
function is get input function df test
new again this probably doesn't make too
big of a difference but we'll go ahead
and stick with the new data we created
number of epics 1 batch 128 so all this
should look pretty familiar but we're
running the prediction so we're going to
load all our predictions into the
predictions and let's go ahead and run
that and you'll see it go through the
tensorflow setup so it's running done
running local ops and then let's just go
ahead and print the df test new
ilocation 0 so row 0 and we're going to
look at the predictions also for the
same location 0. let's go ahead and run
that and we can see here that we have
age 25 work class private it has all the
information coming in for that
individual and then it comes down here
we go ahead and get our
prediction and in this particular
instance there's our label zero uh and
then we come down here and we see it
takes a little bit for the setup to look
up but there's our array which also
returns a zero and it has information
for us on there probabilities logistics
on here so you can see there's all kinds
of additional information you can pull
from this and likewise we could do it
for uh position three let me go ahead
and run that and what's kind of nice
about this is you can now see here's
label one and here's our logistics
output and again to kind of hunt for a
little bit in this particular setup but
here's the output array and there's our
one and they match label one one so we
predicted for the very first one
location zero that it's going to be a
zero on the label it's going to make
under fifty thousand and the individual
in two working class uh private whatever
set up on here capital gain capital f
loss etc came up as one meaning they're
going to make over fifty thousand so we
covered a lot i mean this is the basics
and you can see as you dig deeper when
you look at some of this code let me
just go back up here we're way back up
here at the very top a little too far
overshot as you start working in here we
have one defining your features and at
this point we didn't show this but i
would probably use either python or r to
show a relationship correlation because
they have some really easy packages in
there to pull that up so you can see
what features are really connected and
how they're connected uh and then we
showed you different features like we
have ones that are integers and then we
have ones like sex that are objects
you're zero or one you're male or female
you're uh same thing with the race
probably have just a maybe 16 different
races listed there ethnicities things
like that native country again that's
you don't have like infinite number of
native countries you just have a handful
so we look at this we have our features
we looked at that we have our continuous
features like age which is a number or
in this case an integer an education
number how many years and so on along
with your race your sex your
relationship which are just very
abbreviated uh categorical data uh so we
looked at that we went in there and we
showed you how to um where was it here
we go we go back up here
so we create our model the model has
knows what categories are coming in
that's really important and this is
probably the one of the more complicated
parts of this is our input function and
this input function is so important so i
want to just re-hash the input function
for that reason uh this lets us know how
we're pulling the data it lets us know
um if we're going to go through all the
data 20 times
or we're going to let the or we're just
going to let tensorflow itself keep
going until the training model reaches a
point that point is based on
what they call bias you can become
biased on your training data and so when
it hits a certain point where it becomes
overly biased to just that data then it
doesn't really work really good in the
outside world you start losing keep it
generic but as close as possible to the
right answer so generic answers for a
huge amount of data and then we have our
batch size
are we going to shuffle it which we did
and then also our estimator inputs so
you have your estimator function here
and then of course where the actual data
is coming from so you can see all this
is in that get input function that's
where a lot of the work comes in putting
this together and then we train our
model um that's pretty straightforward
once you have your input function and
all your setup training the model is
quick and then we go ahead and evaluate
and then we can go ahead and create a
predict and then you know look at our
predictions and how they work on
individuals so it's pretty it gives you
a whole roundabout setup on here and how
this is set up and how it's working
certainly there are
a lot more things you can do with
tensorflow this is the basic tensorflow
and it's always developing so it's
exciting this is going to be one of the
most exciting fields right now because
it is really in an infant stage and just
exploding in the market in today's
exciting world of ai artificial
intelligence we're going to cover some
of the many uses is being applied to
health care entertainment composing
music image coloring robotics image
captioning advertising earthquake
prediction and there's many more it's
just an exciting time to be in the field
of ai and deep learning and artificial
intelligence
now all these fields are just booming
it's just amazing what's going on so
let's take a quick glance at some of the
things going on and we'll start with our
healthcare we take a look at healthcare
deep learning is reshaping healthcare
industry by delivering new possibilities
to improve people's lives and we have
computer-aided disease detection i know
a number of startups have come up where
they're working on you take a picture
like if you have some kind of irritation
or rash and they use that or even you
know some infection in the eye and they
use the deep learning to help identify
what it is hey this is uh 99.99
nothing don't worry about it or this is
93 percent chance um it usually doesn't
come out 93 chance if you do deep
learning but it says hey you know you
should probably take this into the
doctor you know have them take a look at
it and see what it is these are the
things it could be analyzing genomes
that's a big one very controversial
nowadays with all the different genome
editing and options they have and things
they're doing but deep learning is
definitely diving into the genome
projects we have discovering new drugs
and this there's so many directions for
new drugs going on it's like one of the
booming industries especially in the us
but all across the world and they range
from
exploring different plants and the
opening up of let's say marijuana in the
u.s and number of cities are exploring
that for medical use to how do you
reprogram t cells in the human body to
combat disease there's whole industries
in data analysis another one is
chemistry how do you use a chemical cell
or a chemistry molecule not cell a
chemical molecule to imitate the t cell
so you can then put those molecules in
there and then they grab the diseased
cells out or the cancer cells or
whatever out just like the human body
would so discovering new drugs and how
to apply that is just a huge industry
all these are huge industries and
medical imaging we'll even take a glance
closer at that but being able to analyze
you know you get your mri you get your
cat scans the doctors can spend a long
time looking at those and taking careful
measurements and most of that's done by
hand but as we start applying deep
learning the deep learning can do a lot
of that work not only do it the same but
it'll be uniform from one hospital to
the next meaning that as a industry it
continues to progress and you get better
results and better services so deep
learning is reshaping healthcare
industry by delivering new possibilities
to improve people's life and deep
learning helps in early detection of
cancer cells and tumors improves a
time-consuming process of synthesizing
new drugs and inverse sophisticated
medical instruments and not even
sophisticated they're using iphones and
deep learning to help with medical
diagnosis so it's at all levels it's
just amazing what they're doing in the
healthcare industry with deep learning
and they've just barely tapped what
there's possible they're just now
evolving into the beginning of this
where it's exploding out there so
entertainment that's always a fun one a
lot of people go into the entertainment
and deep learning because it's just fun
you know what's my favorite movie
all that fun stuff deep learning is used
in the entertainment industry such as
netflix amazon and filmmaking and you
have like your recommendations that's
probably the most common one you see and
you can see here where they have india
transform the true story the third
pillar now markets in the state leave so
it comes up and says hey this is based
on whoever of course this is showing up
on amazon or amazon prime netflix does a
good job of grouping movies for you and
says since you like these movies you
might like these movies over here same
thing with vivo it does that also amazon
netflix and vivo use recommender systems
to provide personalized experience to
its viewers using their show preferences
time of access history etc so really
this is one of the cool things is
instead of having to dig for the
information deep learning starts doing
that for you so instead of spending
hours trying to figure out what you want
to watch you can actually just enjoy the
movies and have them come up deep
learning is used in the entertainment
industry such as netflix amazon and
filmmaking continue on in deep learning
we have things like the ibm watson this
is just really cool i didn't know this
until i read this until we did this
slide wimbledon 2018 used ibm watson to
analyze player emotions and expressions
through hundreds of hours of footage
then it auto-generated highlights for
the telecast so you can imagine somebody
sitting there looking through all the
boring stuff i want to look at the
interesting stuff it helps us sort that
out again you know just like the netflix
and referral it helps you find your
choices without having to do all the
heavy work of digging through really bad
b rated movies and music and audio
generation another huge part of the
industry and this kind of blends right
in with video and movie making voice and
audio recognition technology can be used
to train deep learning network to
produce music compositions so it learns
the patterns and generates new music
google's wavenet and beidou's deep
speech can train a computer to learn the
patterns and the statistics that are
unique to the music it can then generate
a complete new composition that's a
little scary i always thought that
creativity would always be the human
factor that we'd always have our
creativity but you know computers can do
some of that too and then we have our
reeds lip movements oxford and google
scientists created a neural network
called lipnet that could read people's
lips with 93 success this can be used to
add sounds to silent movies i like that
it'd be fun to hear what they actually
were saying back there they probably
said something totally different than
what's actually on the movie that'd be
pretty funny on the scary note this
would allow surveillance equipment to
pull what people are saying even if
they're really far away as long as they
can see the lips that's a little scary
coloring images and videos deep learning
can be used to color images and videos
by taking the objects in their context
within the photograph so you have your
black and white images fed in and you
have a convolutional neural network is
used to learn the patterns and usually
you train it you train it with hundreds
of black and white photos that you
already have the color image for so you
know what to expect then you take the
new one and it recreates the image by
adding the colors and this is also used
in the movie industry to add in special
effects
there's all kinds of cool things they
can do with this it goes way beyond just
coloring pictures of course the coloring
pictures is something that you can
probably do in your own lab on your own
computer and build your own neural
network to do that robotics one of my
favorites robotics all these tools that
make them so exciting is that you can go
out and
even now used to be you'd have to spend
four five six ten thousand us dollars to
buy your own robot and then start
programming it and doing neural networks
now it's around two thousand dollars and
that continues to plummet uh there's
even kid robots much cheaper robotic
hands all of that that you can purchase
and generate your own neural network and
start trying to figure out how to get it
to do things and so we talk about deep
learning it's heavily used these days in
building robots to perform human-like
tasks robots are built to understand the
world around them very important how to
figure out what's what i remember if you
go back 20 years they could not get a
robot to figure out the difference
between a coke can and a pencil because
they're both cylinders and he just they
just had no idea how to do that back
then you know they did the beginning of
robotics really the neural networks was
mid-90s where it started really taking
off and the theory started coming in and
so you go back to that time and figuring
out those differences was almost
impossible before then and they trained
to make better and safer decisions
without supervision and you can see in
this case you know in outer space having
a robot up there uh you know if the
window blows out air pressure is lost
the robot is you know not going to be
hurt by it because they don't need air
and oxygen and their decisions usually
instead of being like a human's tired in
this case the robot never is tired so
you know there's definitely a lot of
tasks for a robot that can be used to
replace humans would be safer think uh
nuclear reactors that melted down after
the tsunami in japan using robotics to
go in there and clean up would be really
important instead of putting a person in
a hazmat suit that might or might not
protect him from the radiation in boston
dynamics we have uh spot mini he's fun
to watch if we pull up the video or the
atlas robots by boston dynamics react to
people pushing them around get up when
they fall can unload a dishwasher and do
other tasks as well so we're starting to
see this kind of robotics coming into
the house the atlas obviously is a very
expensive robot but there is certainly
more common ones you can actually bring
into the house and then spot mini is fun
to watch run you can i forget how fast
he goes but he goes pretty fast image
caption generation another
part of the industry in deep learning
deep learning is used to display the
contents of an image i love this with my
google photos the system is trained with
very large convolutional neural networks
for detecting objects in the photographs
and then a recurring neural network like
an lstm is used to turn the labels into
coherent sentence dog catching a ball so
this is awesome this is like you go into
your google photos and you say hey i
want all the pictures of my dog or i
want all the pictures of kids or
whatever it is and they get to the point
where you can now do i want pictures
where my dog is catching the ball
advertising one of the better paid
fields in ai is in marketing and
advertising especially if you are
working on bonuses and commissions so
advertising and advertising deep
learning allows optimizing a user's
experience so deep learning helps
publishers and advertisers to increase
the relevancy of the ads and boost the
advertising campaigns allows the network
to reduce costs by dropping the cost per
acquisition of a campaign from sixty to
thirty dollars create data-driven
predictive advertising real-time bidding
of their ads and target display
advertising and again this goes uh from
experimental where i'm just going to
guess what people want and we'll put out
a pink sign that says
you want to add on widget to your order
well nobody wants widgets and nobody
wants to see the pink sign maybe you got
three people want to see the pink sign
and you find out that the blue sign a
lot of people are reading that and they
really want a widget number two whatever
that is uh so when you talk about
advertising it also deals with marketing
and also uh preference of merchandise so
it becomes really huge as far as what
you're advertising and generating profit
and sales for a company and that's
across the board whether you're talking
big real estate or
property management and rentals or
amazon uses this for all their
merchandise coming out of their
warehouses any of those are generated
from the ai generates more sales and
that's the bottom dollar business is
always looking at the bottom dollar
where can i make money on this uh
earthquake prediction so now we're
getting to something uh safety human
safety you can also think weather
predictions all those fun things deep
learning model can be used to predict
earthquakes by considering a factor
called von mice's yield criterion
scientists at harvard use deep learning
to teach a computer perform viscoelastic
computations that is quite the mouthful
which are used in prediction of
earthquakes this application helped to
improve the earthquake calculation by 50
000 percent
that's amazing we went from just
guessing when an earthquake is going to
happen where we have almost no
reliability to being able to have a
decent gas as when the earthquakes are
going to hit that's pretty impressive hi
guys i'm rahul from simply learn and
today i'm going to tell you how you can
become an ai engineer so first off let's
ask the important question what is
artificial intelligence now artificial
intelligence is the ability of a
computer system to mimic human behavior
now this is the sort of intelligence
that's demonstrated by machines and this
is in contrast to natural intelligence
that's shown by humans as well as
animals so how does artificial
intelligence work firstly it learns from
past data now whatever machines that are
artificially intelligent learn from
their actions which are positive or
negative now with this new information
the machine is able to make corrections
to itself so that these problems don't
resurface and make some adjustments to
handle new inputs and finally the
machine is able to perform human-like
tasks so who is an artificial
intelligence engineer an ai engineer
builds ai models using machine learning
algorithms and deep learning neural
networks to draw business insights now
these insights can be used to make
business decisions that affect the
entire organization not to mention they
also create weak or strong ais depending
on what goal they want to achieve now
air engineers have a sound understanding
of programming software engineering as
well as data science they use different
tools and techniques so that they can
process data and they develop as well as
maintain ai systems now let's talk about
the responsibilities of an ai engineer
firstly they need to develop test and
deploy ai models this can be done
through a number of different
programming algorithms like random
forest logistic regression linear
regression and so on they need to be
able to convert the machine learning
models into apis or application program
interfaces so that other applications
can use it they're responsible for
building ai models from scratch and help
the different components of the
organization such as product managers
and stakeholders understand what they
stand to gain from the model they need
to build data ingestion and data
transformation infrastructure they need
to automate infrastructure that's used
by the data science team they need to be
able to perform statistical analysis and
tune the results so that the
organization can take better informed
decisions they need to set up as well as
manage ai development and product
infrastructure and they need to be good
at teamwork since they'll be
coordinating work with teams of data as
well as business analysts next up let's
talk about the skills required to become
an ai engineer first of programming
skills now the first skill required to
become an ai engineer is programming
skills now for you to become well-versed
in ai it is very important that you
start learning programming languages
such as python r java and c plus plus so
that you're able to build as well as
implement so that you'll be able to
build as well as implement models the
second skill required is linear algebra
probability and statistics now to
understand as well as implement
different ai models such as hidden
markov models nave base gaussian mixture
models linear discriminant analysis and
so on you need to have detailed
knowledge of linear algebra probability
and statistics the third skill required
is knowledge about spark and big data
technologies now since ai engineers work
with large volumes of data which could
be streaming or real-time production
level data production level data in
terabytes or even petabytes they need to
know about spark and other big data
technologies to make sense of this along
with apache spark you could also use
other big data technologies like hadoop
cassandra and mongodb the next skill
that you require is to be well versed
with algorithms and frameworks now
understanding how machine learning
algorithms like linear regression k nn
naive bayes svm and others work will
help you implement machine learning
models with ease also to build ai models
with unstructured data you need to
understand deep learning algorithms like
cnn which is the convolutional neural
network rnn which is the recurrent
neural network and gan which is the
generative adversarial network and so so
that you can implement it using a
framework some of the frameworks used in
artificial intelligence a pie torch
theano tensorflow and cafe the final
skill required to become an ai engineer
is communication and problem solving
skills now you need to be very good at
communication so that you are able to
pitch your product and idea to the
stakeholders you should also have
excellent problem solving skills to
resolve obstacles for decision making
and draw helpful business insights now
let's talk about an ai engineer's salary
the average salary of an ai engineer is
hundred and eleven thousand dollars per
annum in the united states and rupees 13
lakhs per annum in india now let's talk
about the career and roles in artificial
intelligence since several industries
around the world use ai to some degree
or the other there has been an
exponential growth in the career
opportunities within the field of ai
let's have a look at some of these job
roles first off we have ai developer now
these individuals work closely with
electrical engineers and develop
software to create artificially
intelligent robots next up we have ai
architect now these people work closely
with clients so that they can provide
business as well as system integration
services while at the same time creating
and maintaining the entire architecture
the next role we're going to talk about
is machine learning engineer now these
individuals build predictive models
using wasps using vast volumes of data
have in-depth knowledge of machine
learning algorithms deep learning
algorithms and deep learning frameworks
next up we have data scientists now data
scientists collect clean analyze and
interpret large and complex data sets by
leveraging both machine learning and
predictive analytics and finally we have
bi developer or business intelligence
developer they're responsible for
designing modeling and analyzing complex
data to identify business as well as
market trends so how can simply learn
help you simply learn has now tied up
with ibm and is offering the ai
engineers masters program this program
consists of a number of different
courses such as introduction to
artificial intelligence data science
with python machine learning deep
learning fundamentals by ibm deep
learning with tensorflow and the ai
capstone project after completing this
course you will get a certificate from
both ibm as well as simply learn which
is recognized across the world ibm is
the second largest predictive analysis
and machine learning solutions provider
globally a joint partnership with simply
learn and ibm introduces you to
integrated blended learning and making
you an expert in artificial intelligence
and data science the program code
developed with ibm will make you
industry ready for artificial
intelligence as well as data science job
roles as benefit you get simply learn
job assist you perform capstone and 15
plus real life projects and assistance
with 20 plus in-demand skills and tools
tools such as numpy scipy apache spark
watson keras python r and much more you
also have certain other benefits such as
access to exclusive forums which are
moderated by expert faculty and industry
thought leaders thousand two hundred
dollars worth of ibm cloud credits that
you can leverage for hands-on exposure
access to ibm cloud platforms such as
ibm watson which is ibm's own
supercomputer and other software for 24
7 practice access to digital badges from
ibm and of course the industry
recognized master certificate from
simply learn so if your dream is to
become an ai engineer i suggest you go
on to simplylearn.com and get started on
your journey to getting certified and
getting ahead hello everyone welcome to
this session i'm mohan from simply learn
and today we'll talk about interview
questions for
machine learning now this video will
probably help you when you're attending
interviews for machine learning
positions and attempt here is to
probably consolidate 30 most commonly
asked questions and to help you in
answering these questions we tried our
best to give you the best possible
answers but of course what is more
important here is rather than the
theoretical
knowledge you need to kind of add to the
answers or supplement your answers with
your own experience so the responses
that we put here are a bit more generic
in nature so that if there are some
concepts that you are not clear this
video will help you in kind of getting
those concepts cleared up as well but
what is more important is that you need
to supplement these responses with your
own practical experience okay so with
that let's get started so one of the
first questions that you may face is
what are the different types of machine
learning now what is the best way to
respond to this there are three types of
machine learning if you read any
material you will always be told there
are three types of machine learning but
what is important is you would probably
be better off emphasizing that there are
actually two main types of machine
learning which is supervised and
unsupervised and then there is a third
type which is reinforcement learn so
supervised learning is where
you have some historical data and then
you feed that data to your model to
learn now you need to be aware of a
keyword that they will be looking for
which is labeled data right so if you
just say past data or historical data
the impact may not be so much you need
to emphasize on labeled data so what is
label data basically let's say if you're
trying to do train your model for
classification you need to be aware of
for your existing data which class each
of the observations belong to right so
that is what is labeling so it is
nothing but a fancy name you must be
already aware but just make it a point
to throw in that keyword labeled so that
will have the right impact okay so that
is what is supervised learning when you
have existing labeled data which you
then use to train your model that is
known as supervised learning and
unsupervised learning is when you don't
have this label data so you have data it
is not labeled so the system has to
figure out a way to do some analysis on
this okay so that is unsupervised
learning and you can then add a few
things like what are the ways of
performing uh supervised learning and
unsupervised learning and what are some
of the techniques so supervised learning
we perform or we do
regression and classification and
unsupervised learning uh we do
clustering and clustering can be of
different types similarly regression can
be of different types but you don't have
to probably elaborate so much if they
are asking
for uh just the different types you can
just mention these and just at a very
high level but if they want you to
elaborate give examples then of course i
think there is a different question for
that we will see that later then the
third so we have supervised then we have
unsupervised and then reinforcement you
need to provide a little bit of
information around that as well because
it is sometimes a little difficult to
come up with a good definition for
reinforcement learning so you may have
to little bit elaborate on how
reinforcement learning works right so
reinforcement learning works in in such
a way that it basically has two parts to
it one is the agent and the environment
and the agent basically is working
inside of this environment and it is
given a target that it has to achieve
and uh every time it is moving in the
direction of the target so the agent
basically has to take some action and
every time it takes an action which is
moving uh the agent towards the target
right towards a goal a target is nothing
but a goal okay then it is rewarded and
every time it is going in a direction
where it is away from the goal then it
is punished so that is the way you can
little bit explain and
this is used primarily or very very
impactful for teaching the system to
learn games and so on examples of this
are basically used in alphago you can
throw that as an example where alphago
used reinforcement learning to actually
learn to play the game of go and finally
it defeated the co-world champion right
this much of information that would be
good enough okay then there could be a
question on overfitting uh so the
question could be what is overfitting
and how can you avoid it so
what is overfitting so let's first try
to understand the concept because
sometimes overfitting may be a little
difficult to understand overfitting is a
situation where the model has kind of
memorized the data so this is an
equivalent of memorizing the data so we
can draw an analogy so that it becomes
easy to explain this now let's say
you're teaching a child about
recognizing some fruits or something
like that okay and you're teaching this
child about recognizing let's say three
fruits apples oranges and pineapples
okay so this is a small child and for
the first time you're teaching the child
to recognize fruits then so what will
happen so this is very much like that is
your training data set so what you will
do is you will take a basket of fruits
which consists of apples oranges and
pineapples okay and
you take this basket to this child and
there may be let's say hundreds of these
fruits so you take this basket to this
child and keep showing each of this food
and then first time obviously the child
will not know what it is so you show an
apple and you say hey this is apple then
you show maybe an orange and say this is
orange and so on and so forth and then
again you keep repeating that right so
till that basket is over this is
basically how training work in machine
learning also that's how training works
so till the basket is completed maybe
100 fruits you keep showing this child
and then the process what has happened
the child has pretty much memorized
these so even before you finish that
basket right by the time you are halfway
through the child has learnt about
recognizing the apple orange and
pineapple now what will happen after
halfway through initially you remember
it made mistakes in recognizing but
halfway through now it has learned so
every time you show a fruit it will
exactly 100 accurately it will identify
it will say the child will say this is
an apple this is an orange and if you
show a pineapple it will say this is a
pineapple right so that means it has
kind of memorized this data now let's
say you bring another basket of fruits
and it will have a mix of maybe apples
which were already there in the previous
set but it will also have in addition to
apple it will probably have a banana or
maybe another fruit like a jackfruit
right so this is an equivalent of your
test data set which the child has not
seen before some parts of it it probably
has seen like the apples it has seen but
this banana and jackfruit it has not
seen so then what will happen in the
first round which is an equivalent of
your training data set towards the end
it has 100 it was telling you what the
fruits are right apple was accurately
recognized orange was accurately
recognized and pineapples were
accurately recognized right so that is
like a hundred percent accuracy but now
when you get another a fresh set which
we're not part of the original one what
will happen all the apples maybe it will
be able to recognize correctly but all
the others like the jackfruit or the
banana will not be recognized by the
child right so this is an analogy this
is an equivalent of overfitting so what
has happened during the training process
it is able to recognize or reach 100
accuracy maybe very high accuracy okay
and we call that as very low
loss right so that is the technical term
so the loss is pretty much zero and
accuracy is pretty much hundred percent
whereas when you use testing there will
be a huge error which means the loss
will be pretty high and therefore the
accuracy will be also low okay this is
known as overfitting this is basically a
process where training is done training
processes it goes very well almost
reaching 100 accuracy but while testing
it really drops down now how can you
avoid it so that is a extension of this
question there are multiple ways of
avoiding overfitting there are
techniques like what you call
regularization that is the most common
technique that is used for
avoiding overfitting and within
regularization there can be a few other
subtypes like drop out in case of neural
networks and a few other examples but i
think if you give example or if you give
regularization as the technique probably
that should be sufficient so so there
will be some questions where the
interviewer will try to test your
fundamentals and your knowledge and
depth of knowledge and so on and so
forth and then there will be some
questions which are more like trick
questions that will be more to stump you
okay then the next question is around
the methodology so when we are
performing machine learning training we
split the data into training and test
right so this question is around that so
the question is what is training set and
test set in machine learning model and
how is the split done so the question
can be like that so in machine learning
when we are trying to train the model so
we have a three-step process we train
the model and then we test the model and
then once we are satisfied with the test
only then we deploy the model so what
happens in the train and test is that
you remember the labeled data so let's
say you have 1000 records with labeling
information now one way of doing it is
you use all the thousand records for
training and then maybe right which
means that you have exposed all these
thousand records during the training
process and then you take a small set of
the same data and then you say okay i
will test it with this okay and then you
probably what will happen you may get
some good results all right but there is
a flaw there what is the flaw this is
very similar to human beings it is like
you are showing this model the entire
data as a part of training okay so
obviously it has become familiar with
the entire data so when you are taking a
part of that again and you are saying
that i want to test it obviously you
will get good results so that is not a
very accurate way of testing so that is
the reason what we do is we have the
label data of this thousand records or
whatever we set aside before starting
the training process we set aside a
portion of the data and we call that
test set and the remaining we call as
training set and we use only this for
training our model now the training
process remember is not just about
passing one round of this data set so
let's say now your training set has 800
records it is not just one time you pass
this 800 records what you normally do is
you actually as a part of the training
you may pass this data through the model
multiple times so this thousand records
may go through the model maybe 10 15 20
times till the training is perfect till
the accuracy is high till the errors are
minimized okay now so which is fine
which means that your that is what is
known as the model has seen your data
and gets familiar with your data and now
when you bring your test data what will
happen is this is like some new data
because that is where the real test is
now you have trained the model and now
you are testing the model with some data
which is kind of new that is like a
situation like a realistic situation
because when the model is deployed that
is what will happen it will receive some
new data not the data that it has
already seen right so this is a
realistic test so you put some new data
so this data which you have set aside is
for the model it is new and if it is
able to accurately predict the values
that means your training has worked okay
the model got trained properly but let's
say while you're testing this with this
test data you're getting lot of errors
that means you need to probably either
change your model or retrain with more
data and things like that now coming
back to the question of how do you split
this what should be the ratio there is
no fixed
number again this is like individual
preferences some people split it into 50
50 50 test and 50 training some people
prefer to have a larger amount for
training and a smaller amount for test
so they can go by either 60 40 or 70 30
or some people even go with some odd
numbers like 65 35 or
63.33 and 33 which is like one third and
two thirds so there is no fixed rule
that it has to be something this ratio
has to be this you can go by your
individual preferences all right then
you may have questions around uh data
handling data manipulation
or what you call data management or
preparation so these are all some
questions around that area there is
again no one answer one single good
answer to this it really varies from
situation to situation and depending on
what exactly is the problem what kind of
data it is how critical it is what kind
of data is missing and what is the type
of corruption so the whole lot of things
this is a very generic question and
therefore you need to be little careful
about responding to this as well so
probably have to illustrate this again
if you have experience in doing this
kind of work in handling data you can
illustrate with example saying that i
was on one project where i received this
kind of data these were the columns
where data was not filled or these were
this many rows where the data was
missing that would be in fact a perfect
way to respond to this question but if
you don't have that obviously you have
to provide some good answer i think it
really depends on what exactly the
situation is and there are multiple ways
of handling missing data or corrupt data
now let's take a few examples now let's
say you have data where some values in
some of the columns are missing and you
have pretty much half of your data
having these missing values in terms of
number of rows okay that could be one
situation another situation could be
that you have records or data missing
but
when you do some initial calculation how
many records are correct or how many
rows or observations as we call it has
this missing data let's assume it is
very minimal like 10 percent okay now
between these two cases how do we so
let's assume that this is not a mission
critical situation and in order to fix
this 10 percent of the data the effort
that is required is much higher and
obviously effort means also time and
money right so
it is not so mission critical and it is
okay to let's say get rid of these
records so obviously one of the easiest
ways of handling the data part or
missing data is remove those records or
remove those observations from your
analysis so that is the easiest way to
do but then the downside is as i said in
as in the first case if let's say 50
percent of your data is like that
because some column or the other is
missing so it is not like every in every
place in every row the same column is
missing but you have in maybe 10 percent
of the records column one is missing and
another ten percent column two is
missing another ten percent column three
is missing and so on and so forth so it
adds up to maybe half of your data set
so you cannot completely remove half of
your data set then the whole purpose is
lost okay so then how do you handle then
you need to come up with ways of filling
up this data with some meaningful value
right that is one way of handling so
when we say meaningful value what is
that meaningful let's say for a
particular column you might want to take
a mean value for that column and fill
wherever the data is missing fill up
with that mean value so that when you're
doing the calculations your analysis is
not completely way off so you have
values which are not missing first of
all so your system will work number two
these values are not so completely out
of whack that your whole analysis goes
for a task right there may be situations
where if the missing values instead of
putting mean may be a good idea to fill
it up with the minimum value or with a
zero so or with the maximum value again
as i said there are so many
possibilities so there is no like one
correct answer for this you need to
basically talk around this and
illustrate with your experience as i
said that would be the best otherwise
this is how you need to handle this
question okay so
then the next question can be how can
you choose a classifier based on a
training set data size so again this is
one of those questions where you
probably do not have like a
one-size-fits-all answer first of all
you
may not let's say
decide your classifier based on the
training set size maybe not the best way
to decide the type of the classifier and
even if you have to there are probably
some thumb rules which we can use but
then again every time so in my opinion
the best way to respond to this question
is you need to try out few classifiers
irrespective of the size of the data and
you need to then decide on your
particular situation which of these
classifiers are the right ones this is a
very generic issue so
you will never be able to just by if
somebody defines a problem to you and
somebody even if they show the data to
you or tell you what is the data or even
the size of the data i don't think there
is a way to really say that yes this is
the classifier that will work here no
that's not the right way so you need to
still
you know test it out get the data try
out a couple of classifiers and then
only you will be in a position to decide
which classifier to use you try out
multiple classifiers see which one gives
the best accuracy and only then you can
decide then you can have a question
around confusion matrix so the question
can be explained confusion matrix right
so confusion matrix i think the best way
to explain it is by taking an example
and drawing like a small diagram
otherwise it can really become tricky so
my suggestion is to take a piece of pen
and paper and
explain it by drawing a small matrix and
confusion matrix is about to find out
this is used especially in
classification
learning process and when you get the
results and our model predicts the
results you compare it with the actual
value and try to find out what is the
accuracy okay so in this case let's say
this is an example of a confusion matrix
and
it is a binary matrix so you have the
actual values which is the labeled data
right and which is so you have how many
yes and how many no so you have that
information and you have the predicted
values how many yes and how many know
right so the total actual values the
total yes is 12 plus 130 and they are
shown here and the actual value those
are 9 plus 3 12 okay so that is what
this information here is so this is
about the actual and this is about the
predicted similarly the predicted values
there are yes are 12 plus 3 15 yeses and
no are 1 plus 9 10 nos okay so this is
the way to look at this confusion matrix
okay and
out of this what is the meaning convey
so there are two or three things that
needs to be explained outright the first
thing is for a model to be accurate the
values across the diagonal should be
high like in this case right that is one
number two the total sum of these values
is equal to the total observations in
the test data set so in this case for
example you have 12 plus 3 15 plus 10 25
so that means we have 25 observations in
our test data set okay so these are the
two things you need to first explain
that the total sum in this matrix the
numbers is equal to the size of the test
data set and the diagonal values
indicate the accuracy so by just by
looking at it you can probably have a
idea about is this uh an accurate model
is the model being accurate if they're
all spread out equally in all these four
boxes that means probably the accuracy
is not very good okay now how do you
calculate the accuracy itself right how
do you calculate the accuracy itself so
it is a very simple mathematical
calculation you take some of the
diagonals right so in this case it is 9
plus 12 21 and divide it by the total so
in this case what will it be let me take
a pen so your your diagonal values is
equal to if i say d is equal to 12 plus
9 so that is 21 right and the total data
set is equal to right we just calculated
it is 25 so what is your accuracy it is
21 by your accuracy is equal to 21 by 25
and this turns out to be about 85
percent right so this is 85
so that is our accuracy okay so this is
the way you need to explain draw diagram
give an example and maybe it may be a
good idea to be prepared with an example
so that it becomes easy for you don't
have to calculate those numbers on the
fly right so a couple of uh hints are
that you take some numbers which are
with which add up to 100 that is always
a good idea so you don't have to really
do this complex calculations so the
total value will be 100 and then
diagonal values you divide once you find
the diagonal values that is equal to
your percentage okay all right so
the next question can be a related
question about
false positive and false negative so
what is false positive and what is false
negative now once again the best way to
explain this is using a piece of paper
and pen otherwise it will be pretty
difficult to explain this so we use the
same example of the confusion matrix
and
we can explain that so a confusion
matrix looks somewhat like this and
when we just
yeah it looks somewhat like this and we
continue with the previous example where
this is the actual value this is the
predicted value and
in the actual value we have twelve plus
one thirteen yes's and three plus nine
twelve nose and the predicted values
there are twelve plus three fifteen
yeses and 1 plus 9 10 nos okay now in
this particular case which is the false
positive what is a false positive first
of all the second word which is positive
okay is referring to the predicted value
so that means the system has predicted
it as a positive but the real value so
this is what the false comes from but
the real value is not positive okay that
is the way you should understand this
term false positive or even false
negative so false positive so positive
is what your system has predicted so
where is that system predicted this is
the one positive is what yes so you
basically consider this row okay now if
you consider this row so this is this is
all positive values this entire row is
positive values okay now the false
positive is the one which where the
value actual value is negative predicted
value is positive but the actual value
is negative so this is a false positive
right and here is a true positive so the
predicted value is positive and the
actual value is also positive okay i
hope this is making sense now let's take
a look at what is false negative false
negative so negative is the second term
that means that is the predicted value
that we need to look for so which are
the predicted negative values this row
corresponds to predicted negative values
all right so this row corresponds to
predicted negative values and what they
are asking for false so this is the row
for predicted negative values and the
actual value is this one right this is
predicted negative and the actual value
is also negative therefore this is a
true negative so the false negative is
this one predicted is negative but
actual is positive right so this is the
false negative so this is the way to
explain and this is the way to look at
false positive and false negative same
way there can be true positive and true
negative as well so again positive the
second term you will need to use to
identify the predicted row right so if
we say true positive positive we need to
take for the predicted part so predicted
positive is here okay and then the first
term is for the actual so true positive
so true in case of actual is yes right
so true positive is this one okay and
then in case of actual the negative now
we are talking about let's say true
negative true negative negative is this
one and the true comes from here so this
is true negative right 9 is true
negative the actual value is also
negative and the predicted value is also
negative okay so that is the way you
need to explain this the terms false
positive false negative and true
positive true negative then uh you might
have a question like what are the
steps involved in the machine learning
process or what are the three steps in
the process of developing a machine
learning model right so it is around the
methodology that is applied so basically
the way you can probably answer in your
own words but the way the model
development of the machine learning
model happens is like this so first of
all you try to understand the problem
and try to figure out whether it is a
classification problem or a regression
problem based on that you select a few
algorithms and then you start the
process of training these models okay so
you can either do that or you can after
due diligence you can probably decide
that there is one particular algorithm
which is most suitable usually it
happens through trial and error process
but at some point you will decide that
okay this is the model we are going to
use okay so in that case we have the
model algorithm and the model decided
and then you need to do the process of
training the model and testing the model
and this is where if it is supervised
learning you split your data the label
data into training data set and test
data set and you use the training data
set to train your model and then you use
the test data set to check the accuracy
whether it is working fine or not so you
test the model before you actually put
it into production right so once you
test the model you're satisfied it's
working fine then you go to the next
level which is putting it for production
and then in production obviously new
data will come and
the inference happens so the model is
readily available and only thing that
happens is new data comes and the model
predicts the values whether it is
regression or classification now so this
can be an iterative process so it is not
a straightforward process where you do
the training through the testing and
then you move it to production now so
during the training and test process
there may be a situation where because
of either overfitting or things like
that the test doesn't go through which
means that you need to put that back
into the training process so that can be
an iterative process not only that even
if the training and test goes through
properly and you deploy the model in
production there can be a situation that
the data that actually comes the real
data that comes with that this model is
failing so in which case you may have to
once again go back to the drawing board
or initially it will be working fine but
over a period of time maybe due to the
change in the nature of the data once
again the accuracy will deteriorate so
that is again a recursive process so
once in a while you need to keep
checking whether the model is working
fine or not and if required you need to
tweak it and modify it and so on and so
forth so net net this is a continuous
process of
tweaking the model and testing it and
making sure it is up to date then you
might have question around deep learning
so because deep learning is now
associated with ai artificial
intelligence and so on so can be as
simple as what is deep learning so i
think the best way to respond to this
could be deep learning is a part of
machine learning and
then obviously the question would be
then what is the difference right so
deep learning you need to mention there
are two key parts that interviewer will
be looking for when you are defining
deep learning so first is of course deep
learning is a subset of machine learning
so machine learning is still the bigger
let's say uh scope and deep learning is
one part of it so then what exactly is
the difference deep learning is
primarily when we are implementing these
our algorithms or when we are using
neural networks for doing our training
and classification and regression and
all that right so when we use neural
network then it is considered as deep
learning and the term deep comes from
the fact that you can have several
layers of neural networks and these are
called deep neural networks and
therefore the term deep
deep learning uh the other difference
between machine learning and deep
learning which the interviewer may be
wanting to hear is that in case of
machine learning the feature engineering
is done manually what do we mean by
feature engineering basically when we
are trying to train our model we have
our training data right so we have our
training label data and
this data has several let's say if it is
a regular table it has several columns
now each of these columns actually has
information about a feature right so if
we are trying to predict the height
weight and so on and so forth so these
are all features of human beings let's
say we have census data and we have all
this so those are the features now there
may be probably 50 or 100 in some cases
there may be 100 such features now all
of them do not contribute to our model
right so we as a data scientist we have
to decide whether we should take all of
them all the features or we should throw
away some of them because again if we
take all of them number one of course
your accuracy will probably get affected
but also there is a computational part
so if you have so many features and then
you have so much data it becomes very
tricky so in case of machine learning we
manually take care of identifying the
features that do not contribute to the
learning process and thereby we
eliminate those features and so on right
so this is known as feature engineering
and in machine learning we do that
manually whereas in deep learning where
we use neural networks the model will
automatically determine which features
to use and which to not use and
therefore feature engineering is also
done automatically so this is a
explanation these are two key things
probably
will add value to your response all
right so the next question is what is
the difference between or what are the
differences between machine learning and
deep learning so here this is a quick
comparison table between machine
learning and deep learning and in
machine learning learning enables
missions to take decisions on their own
based on past data so here we are
talking primarily of supervised learning
and
it needs only a small amount of data for
training and then works well on low end
systems so you don't need large machines
and most features need to be identified
in advance and manually coded so
basically the feature engineering part
is done manually and the problem is
divided into parts and solved
individually and then combined so that
is about the machine learning part in
deep learning deep learning basically
enables machines to take decisions with
the help of artificial neural network so
here in deep learning we use neural nets
that is the key differentiator between
machine learning and deep learning and
usually deep learning involves a large
amount of data and therefore the
training also requires usually the
training process requires high-end
machines because it needs a lot of
computing power and the machine learning
features are the or the feature
engineering is done automatically so the
neural networks takes care of doing the
feature engineering as well and in case
of deep learning therefore it is said
that the problem is handled end-to-end
so this is a quick comparison between
machine learning and deep learning in
case you have that kind of a question
then you might get a question around the
uses of machine learning or some real
life applications of machine learning in
modern business the question may be
worded in different ways but the meaning
is how exactly is machine learning used
or actually supervised machine learning
it could be a very specific question
around supervised decision learning so
this is like give examples of supervised
machine learning use of supervised
machine learning in modern business so
that could be the next question so there
are quite a few examples or quite a few
use cases if you will for supervised
machine learning the very common one is
email spam detection so you want to
train your application or your system to
detect between spam and non-spam so this
is a very common business application of
supervised machine learning so how does
this work the way it works is that you
obviously have historical data above
your emails and they are categorized as
spam and not spam so that is what is the
labeled information and then you feed
this information or the all these emails
as an input to your model right and the
model will then get trained to detect
which of the emails are to detect which
is spam and which is not spam so that is
the training process and this is
supervised machine learning because you
have labeled data you already have
emails which are tagged as spam or not
spam and then you use that to train your
model right so this is one example now
there are a few industry specific
applications for supervised machine
learning one of the very common ones is
in healthcare diagnostics in healthcare
diagnostics you have these images and
you want to train models to detect
whether from a particular image whether
it can find out if the person is sick or
not whether a person has cancer or not
right so this is a very good example of
supervised machine learning here the way
it works is that existing images it
could be x-ray images it'd be mri or any
of these images are available and they
are tagged saying that okay this x-ray
image is deflective or the person has an
illness or it could be cancer whichever
illness right so it is tagged as uh
defective or clear or good image and
defective something like that so we come
up with a binary or it could be
multi-class as well saying that this is
defective to 10 this is 25 and so on but
let's keep it simple you can give an
example of just a binary classification
that would be good enough so
you can say that in healthcare
diagnostics using image we need to
detect whether a person is ill or
whether a person is having cancer or not
so here the way it works is you feed
labeled images and you allow the model
to learn from that so that when new
image is fed it will be able to predict
whether this person is having that
illness or not having cancer or not
right so i think this would be a very
good example for supervised machine
learning in modern business all right
then we can have a question like so
we've been talking about supervised and
unsupervised then so there can be a
question around semi-supervised machine
learning so what is semi-supervised
machine learning now semi-supervised
learning as the name suggests it falls
between supervised learning and
unsupervised learning but for all
practical purposes it is considered as a
part of supervised learning and the
reason this has come into existence is
that in supervised learning you need
labeled data so all your data for
training your model has to be labeled
now this is a big problem in many
industries or in many under many
situations getting the label data is not
that easy because there's a lot of
effort in labeling this data let's take
an example of diagnostic images we can
just let's say take x-ray images now
there are actually millions of x-ray
images available all over the world but
the problem is they are not labeled so
their images are there but whether it is
effective or whether it is good and
information is not available along with
it right in a form that it can be used
by a machine which means that somebody
has to take a look at these images and
usually it should be like a doctor and
then say that okay yes this image is
clean and this image is cancerous and so
on and so forth now that is a huge
effort by itself so this is where
semi-supervised learning comes into play
so what happens is there is a large
amount of data maybe a part of it is
labeled then we try some techniques to
label the remaining part of the data so
that we get completely labeled data and
then we train our model so i know this
is a little long winding explanation but
unfortunately there is no
quick and easy definition for semi
supervised machine learning this is the
only way probably to explain this
concept
we may have another question as
what are unsupervised machine learning
techniques or what are some of the
techniques used for performing
unsupervised machine learning so it can
be worded in different ways so how do we
answer this question so unsupervised
learning you can say that there are two
types clustering and association and
clustering is a technique where similar
objects are put together and there are
different ways of finding similar
objects so their characteristics can be
measured and if they have in most of the
characteristics if they are similar then
they can be put together this is
clustering then association you can i
think the best way to explain
association is with an example in case
of association you try to find out how
the items are linked to each other so
for example if somebody bought
maybe a laptop the person has also
purchased a mouse so this is more in an
e-commerce scenario for example so you
can give this as an example so people
who are buying and laptops are also
buying the mouse so that means there is
an association between laptops and mouse
or maybe people who are buying bread are
also buying butter so that is a
association that can be created so this
is unsupervised learning one of the
techniques okay all right then we have
very fundamental question what is the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised machine learning so
machine learning these are the two main
types of machine learning supervised and
unsized and in case of supervised and
again here probably the key word that
the person may be wanting to hear is
labeled data very often people say we
have historical data and if we run it it
is supervised and if we don't have
historical data yes but you may have
historical data but if it is not labeled
then you cannot use it for supervised
learning so it is it's very key to
understand that we put in that keyword
label okay so when we have labeled data
for training our model then we can use
supervised learning and if we do not
have label data then we use unsupervised
learning and there are different
algorithms available to perform both of
these types of trainings so
there can be another question a little
bit more theoretical and conceptual in
nature this is about inductive machine
learning deductive machine learning so
the question can be what is the
difference between inductive machine
learning and deductive machine learning
or
somewhat in that manner so that the
exact phrase or exact question can vary
they can ask for examples and things
like that but that could be the question
so let's first understand what is
inductive and deductive training
inductive training is induced by
somebody and you can illustrate that
with a small example i think that always
helps so whenever you're doing some
explanation try as much as possible as i
said to give examples from your work
experience or give some analogies and
that will also help a lot in explaining
as well and for the interviewer also to
understand so here we'll take an example
or rather we will use an analogy so
inductive training is when we induce
some knowledge or the learning process
into a person without the person
actually experiencing it okay what can
be an example so we can probably tell
the person or show a person a video that
fire can burn the thing burn his finger
or fire can cause damage so what is
happening here this person has never
probably seen a fire or never seen
anything getting damaged by fire but
just because he has seen this video he
knows that okay fire is dangerous and if
a fire can cause damage
right so this is inductive learning
compared to that what is deductive
learning so here you draw conclusion or
the person draws conclusion out of
experience so we will stick to the
analogy so compared to the showing a
video let's assume a person is allowed
to play with fire right and then he
figures out that if he puts his finger
it's burning or if throw something into
the fire it burns so he is learning
through experience so this is known as
deductive learning okay so you can have
applications or models that can be
trained using inductive learning or
deductive learning all right i think
probably that explanation will be
sufficient
the next question is are knn and k means
clustering similar to one another or are
they same right because that the letter
k is kind of common between them okay so
let us take a little while to understand
what these two are one is k nn
completely different k means clustering
is completely different k nnn is a
classification process and
therefore it comes under supervised
learning whereas k means clustering is
actually a
okay when you have k and n when you want
to implement k n which is basically k
nearest neighbors the value of k is a
number so you can say k is equal to 3
you want to implement k n with k is
equal to 3 so which means that it
performs the classification in such a
way that how does it perform the
classification so it will take three
nearest objects and that's why it's
called nearest neighbor so basically uh
based on the distance it will try to
find out its nearest objects that are
let's say three of the nearest objects
and then it will check whether the class
they belong to which class right so if
all three belong to one particular class
obviously this new object is also
classified as that particular class but
it is possible that they may be from two
or three different classes okay so let's
say they are from two classes and then
if they are from two classes now usually
you take a odd number you assign an odd
number to so if there are three of them
and two of them belong to one class and
then one belongs to another class so
this new object is assigned to the class
to which the two of them belong now the
value of k is sometimes tricky whether
should you use three should you use 5
should you use 7 that can be tricky
because the ultimate classification can
also vary so it's possible that if you
are taking k as 3 the object is probably
in one particular class but if you take
k is equal to 5 maybe the object will
belong to a different class because when
you are taking three of them probably
two of them belong to a class one and
one belong to class two whereas when you
take five of them it is possible that
only two of them belong to class one and
the three of them belong to class two so
which means that this object will belong
to class two right so you see that so it
is the class allocation can vary
depending on the value of k now k means
on the other hand is a clustering
process and it is unsupervised where
what it does is the system will
basically identify how the objects are
how close the objects are with respect
to some of their features okay and but
similarity of course is the the letter k
and in case of k means also we specify
its value and it could be three or five
or seven there is no technical limit as
such but it can be any number of
clusters that you can create okay so
based on the value that you provide the
system will create that many clusters of
similar objects so there is a similarity
to that extent that k is a number in
both the cases but actually these two
are completely different processes
we have what is known as naive bayes
classifier and people often get confused
thinking that naive bayes is the name of
the person who found this classifier or
who developed this classifier which is
not 100 percent true base is the name of
the person bays is the name of the
person but naive is not the name of the
person right so naive is basically an
english word and that has been added
here because of the nature of this
particular classifier naive bayes
classifier is a probability based
classifier and
it makes some assumptions that presence
of one feature of a class is not related
to the presence of any other feature of
maybe other classes right so which is
not a very strong or not a very what do
you say accurate assumption because
these features can be related and so on
but even if we go with this assumption
this whole algorithm works very well
even with this assumption and that is
the good side of it but the term comes
from that so that is the explanation
that you can
then there can be question around
reinforcement learning it can be
paraphrased in multiple ways one could
be can you explain how a system can play
a game of chess using reinforcement
learning or it can be any game so the
best way to explain this is again to
talk a little bit about what
reinforcement learning is about and then
elaborate on that to explain the process
so first of all reinforcement learning
has an environment and an agent and the
agent is basically performing some
actions in order to achieve a certain
goal and this goals can be anything
either if it is related to game then the
goal could be that you have to score
very high score a high value high number
or it could be that your
number of lives should be as high as
possible don't lose life so this could
be some of them more advanced examples
could be for driving the automotive
industry self-driving cars they actually
also make use of reinforcement learning
to teach the car how to navigate through
the roads and so on and so forth that is
also another example now how does it
work so if the system is basically there
is an agent and environment and every
time the agent takes a step or performs
a task which is taking it towards the
goal the final goal let's say to
maximize the score or to minimize the
number of lives and so on or minimize
the debts for example it is rewarded and
every time it takes a step which goes
against that code right contrary or in
the reverse direction it is penalized
okay so it is like a carrot and a stick
system now how do you use this to create
a game of chess or to create a system to
play a game of chess now the way this
works is and this could probably go back
to this alphago example where alphago
defeated a human champion so the way it
works is in reinforcement learning the
system is allowed for example
in this case we are talking about chess
so we allow the system to first of all
watch playing a game of chess so it
could be with a human being or it could
be the system itself there are computer
games of chess right so
either this new learning system has to
watch that game or watch a human being
play the game because this is
reinforcement learning is pretty much
all visual so when you're teaching the
system to play a game the system will
not actually go behind the scenes to
understand the logic of your software of
this game or anything like that it is
just visually watching the screen and
then it learns okay so reinforcement
learning to a large extent it works on
that so you need to create a mechanism
whereby your model will be able to watch
somebody playing the game and then you
allow the system also to start playing
the game so it pretty much starts from
scratch okay and as it moves forward it
it's at right at the beginning and the
system really knows nothing about the
game of chess okay so initially it is a
clean slate it just starts by observing
how you're playing so it will make some
random moves and keep losing badly but
then what happens is over a period of
time so you need to now allow the system
or you need to play with the system not
just one two three four or five times
but hundreds of times thousands of times
maybe even hundreds of thousands of
times and that's exactly how alphago has
done it played millions of games between
itself and the system right so for the
game of chess also you need to do
something like that you need to allow
the system to pitch us and then learn on
its own over a period of repetition so i
think you can probably explain it after
this much to this extent and it should
be
sufficient
now this is another question which is
again somewhat similar but here the size
is not coming into picture so the
question is how will you know which
machine learning algorithm to choose for
your classification problem now this is
not only classification problem it could
be a regression problem i would like to
generalize this question so if somebody
asks you how will you choose how will
you know which algorithm to use the
simple answer is there is no way you can
decide exactly saying that this is the
algorithm i am going to use in a variety
of situations there are some guidelines
like for example you will obviously
depending on the problem you can say
whether it is a classification problem
or a regression problem and then in that
sense you are kind of restricting
yourself to if it is a classification
problem there are you can only apply a
classification algorithm right to that
extent you can probably let's say limit
the number of algorithms
but now within the classification
algorithms you have decision trees you
have svm you have logistic regression is
it possible to outright say yes for this
particular problem since you have
explained this now this is the exact
algorithm that you can use that is not
possible okay so we have to try out a
bunch of algorithms see which one gives
us the best performance best accuracy
and then decide to go with that
particular algorithm so in machine
learning a lot of it happens through
trial and error there is no real
possibility that anybody can just by
looking at the problem or understanding
the problem tell you that okay in this
particular situation this is exactly the
algorithm that you should use then the
questions may be around application of
machine learning and this question is
specifically around how amazon is able
to recommend other things to buy so this
is around recommendation engine how does
it work how does the recommendation
engine work so this is basically the
question is all about so the
recommendation engine again works based
on various inputs that are provided
obviously something like uh you know
amazon on a website or e-commerce site
like amazon collects a lot of data
around the customer behavior who is
purchasing what and if somebody is
buying a particular thing they are also
buying something else so this kind of
association right so this is the
unsupervised learning we talked about
they use this to associate and link or
relate items and that is one part of it
so they kind of build association
between items saying that somebody
buying this is also buying this that is
one part of it then they also profile
the users right based on their age their
gender their geographic location they
will do some profiling and then when
somebody is logging in and when somebody
is shopping kind of the mapping of these
two things are done they try to identify
obviously if you have logged in then
they know who you are and your
information is available like for
example your age may be your agenda and
where you're located what you purchased
earlier right so all this is taken and
the recommendation engine basically uses
all this information and comes up with
recommendations for a particular user
today we're going to help you prepare
for interview questions dealing with
deep learning and we're going to go from
the very basics of neural networks and
deep learning into some of the more
commonly used models so you can have an
understanding of what kind of questions
are going to come up and what you need
to know in interview questions we'll
start with a very general concept of
what is deep learning this is where we
take large volumes of data in this case
on cats and dogs or whatever a lot of
times you use
a training setup to train your model
remember it's kind of like a magic black
box going on there then we use that to
extract features or extract information
and in this case classify the image of a
cat and a dog so the primary takeaway
we're talking about deep learning is it
learns from large volumes of structured
and even unstructured data and uses
complex algorithms to train neural
network it also performs complex
operations to extract hidden patterns
and features and if we're going to
discuss deep learning in this very
simplified overview and we also have to
go over what is a neural network this is
a common image you'll see of a drawing
of a forward propagation neural network
and it's it's a human brain inspired
system which replicates the way humans
learn so this has inspired how our own
neurons in our brain fire but at a much
simplified level obviously it's not
ready to take over the human uh
population and be our leader yet not for
many years it's very much in its infant
stage but it's inspired by how our
brains work and they use a lot of other
inspirations you can study brains of
moths and other animals that they've
used to figure out how to improve these
neural networks the most common one
consists of three layers of network and
this is generally how you view these
networks is you have an input you have a
hidden layer and an output and the
neural network is uh broken up into many
pieces but we focus just on the neural
network it's always on the hidden layers
that we're making all the adjustments
and figuring out how to best set up
those hidden layers for their functions
to both train faster and to function
better when we look at this of course we
have our input hidden and output each
layer contains neurons called as nodes
perform various operations and you can
see here we have the list of the nodes
we have both our input nodes and our
output nodes and then our hidden layer
nodes and it's used in deep learning
algorithm like cnn rnn jn etc we'll
address some of these models a little
closer at least the most common models
as we go down the list and we study the
deep learning and the neural network
framework
let's start with what is a multi-layer
perceptron or mlp a lot of time is
referred to and you'll see these
abbreviations i'll be honest i have to
write them down on a piece of paper and
go through them because i never remember
what they all mean even though i play
with them all the time what is a
multi-layer perceptron well if you look
at the image on the right it's very
similar to what we just looked at you
have your input layer your hidden layer
and your output layer and that's exactly
what this is it has the same structure
of a single layer perceptron with one or
more hidden layers except the input
layer each node in the other layers uses
a non-linear activation function what
that means is your input layers your
data coming in and then your activation
function is based upon all those nodes
and weights being added together and
then it has the output mlp uses
supervised learning method called back
propagation for training the model very
key word there is back propagation
single layer perceptron can classify
only linear separable classes with
binary output 0 1 but the mlp can
classify non-linear classes so let's
break this down just a little bit the
multi-layer perceptron with an input
layer and a hidden layer and an output
layer as you see that it comes in there
it has adds up all the numbers and
weights depending on how your setup is
that then goes to the next layer that
then goes to the next hidden layer if
you have multiple hidden layers and
finally to the output layer the back
propagation takes the error that it sees
so whatever the output is it says hey
this has an error to it it's wrong and
it sends that error backwards from where
it came from and there's a lot of
different functions used to
train this based on that error and how
that error goes backwards in the notes
so forward is you get your answers
backward is for training you see this
every day even my uh google pixel phone
has this it they train the neural
network which takes a lot more data to
train than it does to use and then they
load up that neural network into in this
case i have a pixel 2 which actually has
a built-in neural network for processing
pictures and so it's just the forward
propagation i use when it processes my
photos but when they were training it
use the back propagation to train it
with the errors they had we'll be coming
back to different models that are used
for right now though multi-layer
perceptron mlp put that down is your
vocabulary word and of course back
propagation what is data normalization
and why do we need it this is so
important we spend so much time in
normalizing our data and getting our
data clean and setting it up so we talk
about data there's a pre-processing step
to standardize the data so whatever we
have coming in we don't want it to be a
one gigabyte file here a two gigabyte
picture here and a three kilobyte text
there even as a human i can't process
those all in the same group i have to
reformat them in some way that loops
them together so the standardized format
we use this uh data normalization in
pre-processing to reduce it and
eliminate data redundancy a lot of times
the data comes in and you end up with
two of the same images or
the same information in different
formats then we want to rescale values
to fit into a particular range for
achieving better convergence what this
means is with most neural networks they
form a bias we've seen this in recently
in attacks on neural networks where they
light up one pixel or one piece of the
view and it skews the whole answer so
suddenly
because one pixel is really bright it
doesn't know what to do well when we
start rescaling it we put all the values
between say minus one and one and we
change them and refit them to those
values it helps get rid of that bias
helps fix for some of those problems and
then finally we restructure the data and
improve the integrity we want to make
sure that we're not missing values or we
don't have partial data coming in one
way to look at this is uh bad data in
bad data out
so we want clean data in and you want
good answers coming out one of the most
basic models used is a boltzmann machine
so let's address what is a boltzmann
machine and if you know we just did the
mlp multi-layer perceptron so now we're
going to come into almost a simplified
version of that and in this we have our
visible input layer and we have our
hidden layer the boltzmann machines are
almost always shallow they're usually
just two layer neural nets that make
stochastic decisions whether a neuron
should be on or off true false yes no
first layer is a visible layer and
second layer is the hidden layer nodes
are connected to each other across
layers but no two nodes of the same
layer are connected hence it is also
known as restricted boltzmann machine
now that we've covered a basic mlp or
multi-layer perceptron and we've gone
over the boltzmann machine also known as
the restricted boltzmann machine let's
talk a little bit about activation
formulas and this is a huge topic that
can get really complicated but it also
is automated so it's very simple so you
have both a complicated and a simple at
the same time so what is the role of
activation functions in a neural network
activation function decides whether a
neuron should be fired or not that's the
most basic one and that actually changes
a little bit because it's either whether
fired or not in this case activation
function or what value should come out
when it's fired but in these models
we're looking at just the boltzmann
restricted layers so this is what causes
them to fire either they don't or they
do it's a yes or no true false all or
nothing it accepts the weighted sum of
the inputs the bias as input to any
activation function so whatever
activation function is it needs to have
the sum of the weights times the input
so each input if you remember on that
model and let's just go back to that
model real quick and then you always
have to add a bias and you can look at
the bias if you remember from your
euclidean geometry you draw a straight
line formula for that line has a
y-coordinate at the end it's always
cx plus m or something like that where m
is where it crosses the y-coordinates if
you're doing a straight line with these
weights it's very similar but a lot of
times we just add it in as its own
weight we take it as a node of a one
value coming in and then we compute its
new weight and that's how we compute
that bias just like we compute all the
other weights coming in the node which
gets fires depends on the y value and
then we have a step function and the
step function this is where remember i
said it's going to get complicated and
simple all at the same time we have a
lot of different step functions we have
the sigmoid function we have just the
standard step function we have the relu
it's pronounced like ray the ray from
the sun and lu like a name so relu
function and we have the tangent h
function and if you look at these they
all have something similar they all
either force it to be
one value or the other they force it to
be in the case of the first three is
zero or one and in the last one it's
either a minus one or a one and you can
easily convert that to a zero one yes no
true false and on this one of the most
common ones is the step function itself
because there is no middle value there
is no um discrepancy that says well i'm
not quite sure but as you get into
different models probably the most
commonly used used to be the sigmoid was
most commonly used but i see the relu
used more often really depending on what
you're doing you just have to play with
these and find out which one works best
depending on the data and your output
the reason to have a non-zero one answer
or something kind of in the middle is
when you're looking at this and it's
coming out you can actually process that
middle ground as part of the answer into
another neural network so it might be
that the rayleigh function says hey this
is only a 0.6 not a 1. and even though
the 1 is what's going into the next
neural network or the next hidden layer
as an input the 0.6 value might also be
going in there to let you know hey this
is not a straight up 1 or straight up 0
is someplace in the middle this is a
little uncertain what's coming out here
so it's a very powerful tool but the
basic neural network you usually just
use the step function it's yes or no
let's take a a big step back and take a
kind of an overview the next function is
what is a cost function that we're going
to cover this is so important because
this is your end result that you're
going to do over and over again and use
to decide whether the model is working
or not whether you need to try a
different step function whether you need
to try a different activation whether
you need to try a fully different model
used so what is the cost function cost
function is the measure to evaluate how
good your model's performance is it is
also referred as loss or error used to
compute the error of the output layer
during back propagation there's our back
propagation where we're training our
model that's one of our key words mean
squared error is an example of a popular
cost function and so here we have the
cost function c equals half of y minus y
predicted and then you square that so
the first thing is
you know real quick if you haven't done
statistics this is not a percentage it's
not a percentage of how accurate it is
it's just a measurement of the error and
we take that error for training it and
we push that error backwards through the
neural network and we use that through
the different training functions
depending on what model you're using to
train the neural network so when you
deploy the network you're usually done
training it because it takes a lot of
computational force to train it this is
a very simple model and so you deploy
the trained one but we want to know how
your error is and so how do we do that
well you split your data part of your
data is for trading and part of your
data is for testing and then we can also
test the error on there so it's very
important and then we're going to go one
more step on this we got to look at both
the local and the global setup it might
work great to test your data on what you
have on your computer but that's
different than in the field so when
we're talking about all these different
tests in the error test as far as your
loss you don't you want to make sure
that you're in a closed environment when
you do initial testing but you also want
to open that up and make sure you follow
up with the testing on the larger scale
of data because it will change it might
not fit the larger scale there might be
something in there in the way you
brought the data in specifically or the
data group you used or any of those
could cause an error so it's very
important to remember that we're looking
at both the local and the global context
of our error and just one other side
note on a lot of the newer models of
neural networks by comparing the error
we get on the data our training data
with a portion of the test data we can
actually figure out how good the model
is whether it's overfitted or not we'll
go into that a little bit more as we go
into some of the different models so we
have our output we're able to figure out
the error on it based on the square
means usually although there's other
functions used so we want to talk about
what is gradient descent another
vocabulary word gradient descent is an
optimization algorithm to minimize the
cost function or to minimize the error
aim is to find the local or global
minima of a function determine the
direction the model should take to
reduce the error so as we're looking at
this we have our squared error that we
just figured out the co based on the
cost function it says how bad is my
model fitting the data i just put
through it and then we want to reduce
that error so how do you figure out what
direction to do that in well it could be
that you're looking at just that line of
that line of data coming in so that
would be a local minima we want to know
the error of that particular setup
coming in and then you have your global
your global minima we want to minimize
it based on the overall data we're
putting through it and with this we can
figure out the global minimum cost we
want to take all those local minimum
costs of each piece of data coming in
and figure out the global one how we're
going to adjust this model to fit all
the data we don't want it to be biased
just on three or four lines of data
coming in we wanted to kind of
extrapolate a general answer for all the
data coming in but this of course we
mentioned it briefly about back
propagation this is where really comes
in handy is training our model neural
network technique to minimize the cost
function helps to improve the
performance of the network back
propagates the error and updates the
weights to reduce the error so as you
can see here is a very nice depiction of
a back propagation we have our
predicted y coming out and then we have
since it's a training set we already
know the answer and the answer comes
back and uh based on case of the square
means was one of the functions we looked
at uh one of the activation functions
based on cost function that cost
function then depending on what you
choose for your backpropagation method
and there's a number of them we'll
change the weights it will change the
weight going to each of the one of those
nodes in the hidden layer and then based
upon the error that's still being
carried back it'll change the way it's
going to the next hidden layer and then
it computes an error level on that and
sends that back up and you're going to
say well if it computes the air into the
first hidden layer and fixes it why
would it stop there well remember we
don't want to create a biased neural
network so we only make small
adjustments on these weights we don't
make a big adjustment that changes
everything right off the bat so no
matter how far back you go you're always
going to have a small amount of error
and that's still going to continue to go
all the way back up the hidden layers
for right now focus on the back
propagation is taking that error and
moving it backwards on the neural
network to change the weights and help
program it so that it'll have the
correct answers so far we've been
talking about forward propagation neural
networks everything goes forwards goes
left to right but let's just take a
little detour and let's see what is the
difference between a feed forward neural
network and a recurrent neural network
now this is in the function not when
we're training it using the back
propagation so you've got new
information coming in and you want to
get the answer and there's a couple
different networks out there and we want
to know we have a feed forward neural
network and we have a new vocabulary
term recurrent neural network a feed
forward neural network signals travel in
one direction from input to output no
feedback loops considers only the
current input cannot memorize previous
inputs one example of one of these feed
forward neural networks and we've
covered a number of them but one of the
ones that has a big highlight nowadays
is the cnn a convolutional neural
network tensorflow the one put out by
google is probably most known for their
cnn where the information goes forward
it first takes a picture splits it apart
goes through the individual pixels on
the picture so it picks up a different
reading then calculates based on that
goes into a regular feed forward neural
network and then gives your
categorization on there now we're not
covering the cnn today but we do have a
video out that you can look up on
youtube put out by simply learn the
convolutional neural network wonderful
tutorial check that out and learn a lot
more about the convolutional neural
network but you do need to know that the
cnn is a forward propagation neural
network only so it's only moving in one
direction so we will look at a recurrent
neural network signals travel in both
directions making it a looped network
considers the current input along with
the previous received inputs for
generating the output of a layer has the
ability to memorize past data due to its
internal memory and you can see they
have a nice image here we have our
input and for some reason they always do
the recurrent neural network in reverse
from bottom up in the images kind of a
standard although i'm not sure why your
x goes into your hidden layer and your
hidden layer the answer for part of the
answer from that it generates feeds back
into the hidden layer so now you have an
input of both x and part of the hidden
layer and then that feeds into your
output now if we go back to the forward
let me just go back a slide and we're
looking at
our forward propagation network one of
the tricks you can do to use just a
forward propagation network is if you're
in a what they call a time sequence
that's a good term to remember are a
time series meaning that a sequential
data each term comes after the other you
can trick this by creating your input
nodes as with the history so if you know
that you have values 1 5 and 7 going in
and you know what the output is from one
with those outputs are you can expand
the input to include the history input
that's one of the ways to trick a
forward propagation network into looking
at that but when you do with the
recurrent neural network you let the
hidden layer do that for you it sends
that data and reprocesses it back into
itself what are some of the applications
of recurrent neural network the rnn can
be used for sentiment analysis and text
mining getting up early in the morning
is good for health and it's a positive
sentiment one of the catches you really
want to look at this when you're looking
at the language is that i could switch
this around and totally negate the
meaning of what i'm doing so would no
longer be positive so when you're
looking at a sentence knowing the order
of the words is as important as the
meaning of the words you can't just
count how many good words there are
versus bad words to get some positive
sentiment you now have to know what
they're addressing and there's lots of
other different uses
kids are playing football or soccer as
we call it in the u.s rn can help you
caption an image so based on previous
information coming in it refeeds that
back in and you have a image setter and
then time series problems like
predicting the prices of stocks in a
month or quarter or sell a product can
be solved using an rnn and this is a
really good example you have whatever
your stocks were doing earlier this
month will have a huge effect on what
they're doing today if you're investing
so having an rnn model a recurrent
neural network feeding into itself what
was happening previously allows it to
take that model and program in the whole
series without having to put in the
whole a month at a time of data you only
put in one day at a time but if you keep
them in order it will look back and say
oh this because what happened yesterday
i need some information from that and
i'm going to use that to help predict
today's and so on and so on we're going
to go back to our activation functions
remember i told you rayleigh was one of
the most common functions used uh so
let's talk a little bit more about relu
and also softmax softmax is an
activation function that generates the
output between 0 and 1. it divides each
output such that the total sum of the
outputs is equal to 1. it is often used
in the output layers softmax l of the n
equals e to l on the n over the absolute
value of e to the l so what does this
function mean i mean what is actually
going on here so we have our output
notes and our output nodes are giving us
let's say they give us 1.2 0.9 and 0.4
as a human being i look at that and i
say well the greatest value is 1.2 so
whatever category that is if you have
three different categories maybe you're
not just doing if it's a cat or it's a
dog or well let's say it's a cow maybe
we had cats and dogs earlier why the
cats and dogs are hanging out with a cow
i don't know but we have a value and it
might say 1.2 is a cat 0.9 is the dog
and 0.4 is a cow for some reason it
thinks that there's a chance of it being
any one of these three items and that's
how it comes out of the output layer
well as a human i can look at 1.2 and
say this is definitely what it is it's
definitely a cat or whatever it is maybe
it's looking at different kinds of cars
might be a better whether it's a car
truck or a motorcycle maybe that'd be a
better example well from a computer
standpoint that might be a little
confusing because they're just numbers
waving at us and so with the soft max we
want all those numbers to always add up
to one so when i add three numbers
together i want the final output to be
one on there and so it goes through this
formula changes each of these numbers in
this case it changes them to 0.46 0.34
and 0.20 they all add up to 1. and
that's a lot easier to register because
it's very set it's a set output it's
never going to be more than one it's
never going to be less than zero and so
you can see here that there's probably a
pretty high chance that it's the first
one so you're a human being we have no
problem knowing that but this output can
then also go into say another input so
it might be
an automated car that's picking up
images and it says that image in front
of us is probably a big truck we should
deal with it like it's a big truck it's
probably not a motorcycle or whatever
those categories are that's the soft max
part of it but now we have the relu well
where's the relu coming from well the
ray lu is what's generating the 1.2 and
the 0.9 and the 0.4 and so if you
remember our relu stands for rectified
linear unit and is the most widely used
activation function we looked at a
number of different activation functions
including tangent h the step function
remember i said the step function is
really used if that's what your actual
output is because then you know it's a
zero or one but the ray loop if you have
that as your output you now have a
discrepancy in there and if that's going
into another neural network or another
process having that discrepancy is
really important and it gives an output
of x if x is positive and 0 otherwise so
it says my x value is going to be
somewhere between 0 or 1 and then the
usually unless it's really uncertain the
output's usually a one or zero and then
you have that little piece of
uncertainty there that you can send
forward to another network or you can
look at to know that there's uncertainty
involved and is often used in the hidden
layers this is what's coming out of the
hidden layers into the output layer
usually or as we reference the
convolutional neural network the cnn
you'd have to go to another video to
review the relu is the most common used
for
convolutional part of that network it
has a bunch of little pieces that are
very simplified looking at all the
different images or different sections
of the map and the rayleigh works really
good for that like i said there's other
formulas used but that this is the most
common one and you'll see that in the
hidden layers going maybe between one
layer and the next layer so just a quick
recap we have our soft max which means
that if you have numerous categories
only one of them is going to be picked
but you also want to have some value
attached to it how well it picked it and
you put that between 0 1 so it's very uh
standardized so we have our soft max we
looked at that let's go back one we
looked at that here where it transforms
the numbers and then we have our relu
function which takes the information and
the summation and puts it between a zero
and a one where it's either clearly a
zero or depending on how confident our
model is it'll go between the zero and
one value what are hyper parameters well
this is a great interview question hyper
parameters when you are doing neural
networks this is what you're playing
with most the time once you've gotten
the data formatted correctly a
hyperparameter is a parameter whose
value is set before the learning process
begins determines how a network is
trained and the structure of the network
this includes things like the number of
hidden units how many hidden layers are
you going to have and how many nodes in
each layer learning rate learning rate
is usually multiplied once you've
figured out the error and how much you
want to change the weights we talked
about or i mentioned it earlier just
briefly you don't want to just make a
huge change otherwise you're going to
have a biased model so you only take
some little incremental changes and
that's what the learning rate is is
those small incremental changes epics
how many times are you going to go
through all the data in your training
set so one epic is one trip through all
the data and there's a lot of other
things depending on which model you're
working with and which programming
script you're working with like the
python sk learn package will have a
slightly different than say google's
tensorflow package which will be a
little bit different than the spark
machine learning package so these are
just some examples of the hyper
parameters and so you see in here we
have a nice image of our data coming in
and we train our model then we do a
comparison to see how good our model is
and then we go back and we say hey this
this model is pretty good but it's
biased so and we send it back and we
change our hyper parameters to see if we
get an unbiased model or we can have a
better prediction on it it matches our
data closer what will happen if learning
rate is set too low or too high we have
a nice couple graphs here we have one
over here so the learning rate set to
load you can see that it slowly works
its way down the curve and on the right
you can see a learning rate set too high
it's just bouncing back and forth when
your learning rate is too low that's
what we studied at two slides where
that's what the learning rate was
training of the model will progress very
slowly as we are making very tiny
updates to the weights we'll take many
updates before reaching the minimum
point so i just mentioned epic going
through all the data you might have to
go through all the data a thousand times
instead of 500 times for it to train
learning rate too high causes
undesirable divergent behavior to the
loss function due to drastic updates and
weights at times it may fail to converge
or even diverge so if you have your
learning rate set too high and it's
training too quickly maybe you'll get
lucky and it trains after one epic run
but a lot of times it might never be
able to train because the weights are
changing too fast
they flip back and forth too easy and
you see down here we've introduced two
new terms converge and diverge a
converge means that our model has
reached a point where it's able to give
a fairly good answer for all the data we
put in all those weights have adjusted
and it's minimized the error diverged
means that the data is so chaotic that
it can never manage to to train to that
data the data is just too chaotic for it
to train so we have two new words there
converge and diverge are important to
know also what is dropout and batch
normalization dropout is a technique of
dropping out hidden and visible units of
a network randomly to prevent
overfitting of data it doubles the
number of iterations needed to converge
the network so here we have our standard
neural network and then after applying
dropout now it doesn't mean we actually
delete the node the node is still there
and we're still going to use that node
what it means is that we're only going
to work with a few of the nodes
a lot of times i think the most common
one right now used is twenty percent uh
so you'll drop out twenty percent of the
nodes when you do your training you
reverse propagate your data and then
you'll randomly pick another 20 nodes
the next time you go through an epic
data training so each time you go
through one epic you will randomly pick
20 of those nodes not not to mess with
and this allows for less overfitting of
the data so by randomly doing this you
create some i guess it just kind of
pulls some nodes off to the side it says
we're going to handle the data later on
so we don't overfit batch normalization
is a technique to improve the
performance and stability of neural
network the idea is to normalize the
inputs in every layer so that they have
mean output and activation of zero and
standard deviation of one this question
covers a lot of different things which
is great it's a great uh interview
question because it pulls in that you
have to understand what the mean value
is so a mean output activation of zero
that means our average activation is
zero so when you normalize it remember
usually we're going between minus one
and one on a lot of these it's a very
standard setup so you have to be very
aware that this is your mean output
activation of zero and then we have our
standard deviation of one so we want to
keep our error down to just a one value
the benefits of this doing a batch
normalization is it provides
regularization it trains faster higher
learning rates and weights are easier to
initialize what is the difference
between batch gradient descent and
stochastic gradient descent batch
gradient descent batch gradient computes
the gradient using the entire data set
it takes time to converge because the
volume of data is huge and weights
update slowly so you can look at the
batch as a lot of times if you're using
big data batch the data in but you still
go through a full epic you still go
through all the data on there so bash
graded descent means you're going to use
it to fit all the data and look for
convergence there stochastic gradient
descent stochastic gradient computes the
gradient using a single sample it
converges much faster than batch
gradient because it updates weight more
frequently explain overfitting and
underfitting and how to combat them
overfitting happens when the model
learns the details and noise and the
training data to the degree that it
adversely impacts execution of the model
on the new information it is more likely
to occur with non-linear models that
have more flexibility when learning a
target function an example of this would
be if you're looking at say cars and
trucks and motorcycles it might only
recognize trucks that have a certain
box-like shape it might not be able to
notice a flatbed truck unless it's only
a specific kind of flatbed truck or only
ford trucks because that's what it saw
on the training set this means that your
model performs great on your train data
and great on maybe a small test amount
of data but when you go to use it in the
real world it leaves out a lot and start
and is not very functional outside of
your small area your slow laboratory
data coming in under fitting doing the
opposite when you under fit your data
under fitting alludes to a model that is
neither well trained on training data
nor can generalize to new information
usually happens when there is less and
improper data to train a model has a
verb performance and accuracy so if
you're using underfitted data and you
generate a model and you distribute that
in a commercial zone you'll have a lot
of people unhappy with you because it's
not going to give them very good answers
so we've explained overfitting and under
fitting so now we want to ask how to
combat them combating overfitting and
under fitting resampling the data to
estimate the model accuracy k-fold
cross-validation having a validation
data set to evaluate the model so we do
the re-sampling we're randomly going to
be picking out data and we'll run it a
few times to see how that works
depending on our random data and how we
sample the data to generate our model
and then we want to go ahead and
validate the data set by having our
training data and then keeping some data
on the side testing data to validate it
how are weights initialized in a network
initializing all weights to zero all the
weights are set to zero this makes your
model similar to a linear model so if
you have linear data coming in doing a
basic setup like that might work all the
neurons in every layer perform the same
operation given the same output and
making the deep net useless right there
is a key word it's going to be useless
if you initialize everything to zero at
that point be looking into some other
machine learning tools initializing all
weights randomly here the weights are
assigned randomly by initializing them
very close to zero it gives better
accuracy to the model since every neuron
performs different computations and here
we have the weights are set randomly we
have our input layer the hidden layers
and the output layer and w equals np
random random in layer size l layer size
l minus one this is the most commonly
used is to randomly generate your
weights what are the different layers in
cnn convolutional neural network first
is the convolutional layer that performs
a convolutional operation we have our
other video out if you want to explore
that more so go into detail exactly how
to see the convolutional layer works on
the cnn as far as creating a number of
smaller picture windows to go over the
data the second step is as a rayleigh
layer relu brings non-linearity to the
network and converts all the negative
pixels to zero output is rectified
feature map so it goes into a mapping
feature there pooling layer pulling is a
down sampling operation that reduces the
dimensionality of the feature map so we
have all our relu layer which is pulling
all these little maps out of our
convolutional layer it's taking that
picture and little creating little tiny
neural networks to look at different
parts of the picture then we need to
pull it together and then finally the
fully connected layer so we flatten our
pulling layer out and we have a fully
connected layer recognizes and
classifies the objects in the image and
that's actually your forward propagation
reverse propagation training model
usually i mean there's a number of
different models out there of course
what is pooling in cnn and how does it
work pooling used to reduce the spatial
dimensions of a cnn performs down
sampling operation to reduce the
dimensionality creates a pooled feature
map by sliding a filter matrix over the
input matrix i mentioned that briefly on
the previous slide it's important to
know that you have if you see here they
have a rectified feature map and so each
one of those colors like the yellow
color that might be one of the a smaller
little neural network using the relu
you'll look at it'll just kind of
go over the main picture and look at all
the different areas on the main picture
so you might step one two three four
spaces and then you have another one
that's also looking at features and it
has a 2785 each one of those is a map so
it might be the first one might be a map
looking for cat ears the second one
looking for human eyes when it does this
you then have this rectified feature map
looking at these different features and
the max pooling with the two by two
filters and a stride of two stride means
instead of skipping every pixel you're
going to go every two pixels you take
the maximum values and you can see over
here we look at a pulled feature map one
of the features says hey i had a max
value of eight so somewhere in here we
saw a human eye labeled as eight pretty
high label and maybe seven was a human
hand and maybe four was cat whiskers or
something that we thought might be cat
whiskers four is kind of a low number in
this particular case compared to the
other ones so you have your full pool
feature map you can see the process here
is we have our stepping we look for the
max value and then we create a pool
feature map of the max values i hope
this helps you in your interview with
that we reached the end of the complete
artificial intelligence course i hope
you enjoyed this video do like and share
it thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from simply learn
[Music]